OKAY GOOD MORNING WITH
LET'S. LET'S BEGIN TODAY
HEARING IS OUR OUR CAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ADJUST THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WILL HEAR
THE OTHER HIRED SEGMENTS AT A
LATER DATE TODAY'S. HEARING IS
A DISTANCE- THAT COATED RELATED
HEARING BECAUSE OF- THE
PANDEMIC STILL HAVE- LIMITED
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION HERE IN
PERSON AND OVER THE PHONE AS
WELL- BUT THE SHOW GOES ON SO
TODAY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT OF
COURSE THE LARGEST SEGMENT OF
HIGHER EDUCATION IN THE COUNTRY
PROVIDING SERVICES FOR OVER TWO
MILLION CALIFORNIANS WE KNOW
KOBE NINETEEN HAS HAD A
DRAMATIC IMPACT ON OUR-
STUDENTS AND HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEMS- PREDOMINATELY THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- WE'VE LOST.
AT LEAST A HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS THIS YEAR FROM
ENROLLMENT FROM JUST A YEAR AND
A HALF AGO WE KNOW THAT.
PANDEMIC HAND IMPACTS LOW
INCOME FAMILIES OF PEOPLE OF
COLOR EVEN MORE. AND THIS OF
COURSE THE LARGEST SEGMENT EVER
COMMUNICATE SYSTEM YESTERDAY WE
DID STEP UP AND PROVIDE A MORE
FINANCIALLY IN SUPPORT FOR
STUDENTS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SO THAT. IS THAT IS A BIG
EFFORT AS WELL AS AS WELL WE
STEPPED UP TO PROVIDING HELP TO
GET- SOME ARE STUDENTS WHO ARE
FOOD INSECURE- INTO THE
CALFRESH PROGRAM WHICH YOU KNOW
IS A PRIORITY. OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE ASSEMBLY-
TODAY WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS FOR-
K. FOURTEEN PROP NINETY EIGHT
HOW THE IMPACT OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES- YOU KNOW WE FOR ONE
OF FOCUS ON MAKE SURE THE
COLLEGES REMAIN WHOLE- BUT ALSO
FOCUSED ON THE STUDENTS STUDENT
BASIC NEEDS- SUPPORT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND ALL THE
OTHER PIECES THAT. FOCUS ON
STUDENT SUCCESS- OTHER PROGRAMS
IN OUR VERY AN INFLUENTIAL AND
IMPORTANT ARE THE MESA PLENTY
OF MODE YOUR PROGRAMS- THIS
EMERGING PROGRAM THE RISING
SCHOLARS WHICH IS AT ITS CAMPS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA WHEN I TAKE A
LOOK AT EXPANDING THAT- AS WELL
ANOTHER PIECE THAT'S RELATED
TO- COMMUNICATE JUST AS WELL AS
THE FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM THEIR
CALTRANS WHICH WE TALKED ABOUT
IS- CAL GRANT REFORM- WHICH
WILL CONTINUE TO. ENGAGE WITH A
LASTLY WE HAVE AN UPDATE ON THE
CAL BRIGHT COLLEGE THE ONLINE
COLLEGES THERE'S NO NEW MONEY
IN THE BUDGET BUT THERE IS AN
EXTREME INTEREST IN THIS TOPIC
THERE IS A AUDIT COMING OUT IN
A FEW WEEKS AS WELL. BY NOTE.
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT
HOW THIS IS. BEING PLAYED OUT
AS- SINCE WE'RE DOING MORE
ONLINE. LEARNING ANYWAY THROUGH
THE PANDEMIC IN OUR
COMMUNICATIONS- SO WITH THAT
LET'S BEGIN WITH OUR AGENDA.
TRY TO FINISH ON TIME TODAY. SO
FIRST WE HAVE ISSUE NUMBER ONE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICATORS BASE
FUNDING INA ROMAN AND WE HAVE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE L. A. L.
O. AND THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
I BELIEVE WITH US. SO I SEE IT
WE SAT THERE BUT I THINK WE'RE
GONNA START WITH DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. GOOD MORNING SURE
NEVER STAND IN OUR DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- FOR THE FIRST ITEM
OUT THERE AND OVER OF THE-
THANK BUT RELATED TO APARTMENT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY.
LOOKING AT THE BIG PICTURE THE
GOVERNOR QUITE BUT TEN POINT
BILLION AND LOCAL THE SINCE FOR
CAN YOU COLLEGE. AND ADULT THAT.
IT'S A NEW ESTIMATE THAN WORK
BUT FACTORS. THE GOVERNMENT BY
PROJECT TOTAL COPY THAT FOR THE
STUDENT CENTER FUNDING FOR. OF
SEVEN POINT SIX SIX SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. SHOP
FROM THE PROJECT OF SEVEN POINT
FOUR THREE FIVE DOLLARS. FOR
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TWENTY ONE
AT THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET AT.
INCLUDED IN THIS AMOUNT ARE
TWENTY ARE YOU TWENTY TWENTY.
ONE TWENTY TWO COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT OF ONE POINT 5% OR
ONE HUNDRED AND ELEVEN POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS- AND
FUNDING FOR POINT 5% ENROLLMENT
GROWTH FOR TWENTY THREE POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS. IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CONTINUE TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THEIR STUDENTS. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REQUIRES
SEVERAL CONDITIONS FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT UPON
RECEIVING THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO- COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT. FEATURING COLLEGE
DISTRICT- FIRST EACH CLINIC
DISTRICTS HAVE. A REPORT THE
SPECIFIC ACTIONABLE. ON HOW
THEY PLAN TO CLOSE THE- GAPS BY
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN. IN
FURTHERANCE OF THE GOALS
OUTLINED IN THE VISION PERSICA.
THE SECOND COMMUNITY DISTRICTS
CHUCK POLICIES TO MAINTAIN.
ONLINE COURSE IN PRO AT A LEVEL
THAT IT PERCENTAGE POINT HIGHER.
THAN TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETY ALL.
BECAUSE THE COLLEGES OF ALL
SHIPPED TO PROVIDE ONLINE ARE
PROVIDING AND THAT IS ON
COMPLETE THE ONLINE. AS A
RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC
ADMINISTRATION BILL CONFIDENT
THAT THIS GOAL IS RIGHT THAT
THE. I WOULD OFTEN AT SIMILAR.
FOR THE UC AND C. OR ESTABLISH
AT THE GOVERNOR BUDGET WELL.
ENTER OF DEFERRAL. AS YOU KNOW
TWENTY TWENTY BY ACTIVE BIRD
ONE POINT FIVE THREE. AND
TWENTY ONE PORTION OF. THE
GIVEN EXPECT INCREASE IN THE
PROVINCE NINETY GUARANTEE. THE
PROJECT THE GOVERNMENT BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO REDUCE TO TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO TO FOR ALL THE
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX
POINT FIVE BILLION. PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND OF A
PORTION OF. ADDITIONALLY THIS
BUDGET PROPOSES TO REPAY THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO FOR
ALL. OF ONE POINT FOUR FIVE
THREE BILLION USING SOURCES
FROM MULTIPLE FISCAL YEARS.
INCLUDING A HUNDRED AND FORTY
FOUR POINT SIX MILLION IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY. FIVE HUNDRED POINT
EIGHT MILLION- FROM VEHICLE
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVEN
POINT NINE MILLION FROM FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. BY GETTING IT IMPLEMENTED
A FOR ALL ALBEIT SIGNIFICANTLY
LOWER LEVEL. SAID MINISTRATION
IS ABLE TO INCLUDE ADDITIONAL
PROPOSAL DESIGNED TO TRACK
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF TOWN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS. AND
HELP THEM TO THE STATE TIME. AS
WELL TRY TO CATCH A THE-
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN ROME TO.
REPORTED FOR THE FALL TWENTY
TWENTY TERM. I WOULD RATHER NOT
HEAR THAT IMMEDIATE. PACKAGE BY
THE INSTEAD INCLUDED TWENTY
MILLION ONE TIME. THE REPORT
EVERITT TO INCREASE STUDENT AND
INVOLVED. ALSO HELP COLLEGES
ADDRESS DECLINING COUNSELOR OF
THE- WITH THAT I'M CONFIDENT
ANY QUESTION ABOUT. WELCOME
BACK YOU IF I. L. A. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER. PASTI
HOUSING WE ANALYSTS OFF. LAST
OUR OFFICE WILL AND NOW. OF
GOVERNOR. CAL COMMITTEE
PROPOSED ITS TITLED THE TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WHICH YOU SHOULD HAVE
A COPY OF. SO THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF PROPOSALS AND ISSUE
ONE. REGARDING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED ONE POINT 5% COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT FOR A PORTION
IT'S WE KNOW IN OUR REPORT THAT
DISTRICTS ARE FACING A NUMBER
OF COST PRESSURES. IN THE
UPCOMING. YEAR HEALTH CARE
PREMIUM INCREASES ARE. ARE
FACTORED PENSIONS BOB WITH
COSTS REALLY RAMPING UP IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. YOU
ARE ALSO IT'S HAVE JUST BASIC
OPERATING COSTS ARE GOING UP-
AND JUST INCREASED- PRESSURED
FOR EMPLOYEE SALARIES
ESPECIALLY AFTER NOT RECEIVING
A COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT IN
THE CURRENT YEAR. SO THE CALL
RATE WHICH IS BASED ON A PRICE
INDEX. FOR STATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WILL BE UPDATED IN
APRIL AND THEN IN MAY THAT
LEGISLATION WILL HAVE A MUCH
BETTER IDEA OF WHAT REVENUES
ARE- AND THAT WILL IMPACT
WHAT'S AVAILABLE AND
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING FOR K. FOURTEEN
EDUCATION. SO IF ADDITIONAL.
ONGOING PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE IN
MAY THE LEGISLATURE MAY I WISH
TO PROVIDE AN EVEN LARGER. COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT FOR A
PORTION IT'S THAN WHAT THE
GOVERNOR IS CURRENTLY
PROPOSING. THE LEGISLATURE
COULD ALSO CONSIDER RE
PURPOSING LOWER PRIORITY
PROPOSALS AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET TO SUPPORT A LARGER BASE
OF PORTION INCREASING
THROUGHOUT OUR BUDGET ANALYSIS-
IN THIS HEARING- WE WILL
IDENTIFY WE IDENTIFY SOME OF
THOSE PROPOSALS THAT MIGHT BE
GOOD CANDIDATES. FOR SUCH A
REDIRECTION. WITH THREE TO THE
PROPOSAL FOR DISTRICTS TO
DEVELOP STUDENT EQUITY PLANS AS
A CONDITION OF RECEIVING THEIR
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT WE
WOULD NOTE THAT SUCH A
REQUIREMENT WOULD REALLY BE
REDUNDANT THIS IS BECAUSE
DISTRICTS. ALREADY MUST DEVELOP
AN UPDATE STUDENT EQUITY PLANS
AS A CONDITION OF RECEIVING
STUDENT EQUITY ACHIEVEMENT
CATEGORICAL FUNDS SO WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
REJECT THAT PROPOSED CONDITION.
AS REGARDS TO THE PROPOSED
CONDITION ON MAKING THAT CALL
OUR TO DO ONLINE INSTRUCTION
MAINTAIN TEN PERCENTAGE POINTS
HIGHER THAN PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS.
THIS PROPOSAL REALLY STRIKES
ISN'T ARBITRARY YOU HAVE-
COASTLINE IN COLLEGE IN ORANGE
COUNTY THAT'S ALREADY IT. 78%
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN NOT SURE WHAT'S
NECESSARILY DESIRABLE ABOUT
HAVING HIM STAY AT EIGHTY EIGHT
PERCENT. OUR OTHER COLLEGES
HISTORICALLY DO MOSTLY IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION BECAUSE THEY
HAVE MORE OF AN EMPHASIS ON
CURRENT TECHNICAL EDUCATION TO
BE MORE HANDS ON OVER THERE AND
RURAL AREAS WHERE STUDENTS
MIGHT HAVE LOWER INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY SO WE RECOMMEND
REJECTING. THAT PROPOSAL. ONE
OF THE PROPOSED PAY- WE THINK
THE GOVERNOR'S ON THE RIGHT
TRACK HE WOULD. HE WOULD
ELIMINATE ONE ABOUT ONE POINT
ONE BILLION OF THE ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION IN DEFERRALS- IN
THE BUDGET YEAR BUT LEAVING.
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WOULD JUST BE AN
ONGOING DEFERRAL UNTIL THAT'S
PAID OFF- AND WITH NO TIMELINE
OF WHEN THAT MIGHT BE PAID OFF.
BY THE ADMINISTRATION. SO WE
THINK THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
THINK ABOUT GOING EVEN FURTHER
THAN THE GOVERNOR USING ONE
TIME FUNDS TO RETIRE MORE OF
THESE DIFFERENT ROLES IN THE
BUDGET YEAR HAS SEVERAL
ADVANTAGES INCLUDING HELPING
DISTRICTS WITH THEIR-
BORROWING- THEY DON'T HAVE TO
BORROW AS MUCH FOR CASH FLOW
PURPOSES. IT ALSO GIVES THE
LEGISLATURE MORE BUDGET TOOLS
TO RESPOND TO FUTURE ECONOMIC
DOWNTURNS. AND WE ARE.
THROUGHOUT OUR BUDGET HOUSES WE
IDENTIFY LOWER PRIORITY
PROPOSALS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THAT WE THINK COULD BE
USED INSTEAD. TO PAY DOWN MORE
DEFERRALS OR TO HELP DISTRICTS
IN OTHER WAYS SUCH AS BY
MITIGATING THEIR FUTURE PENSION
COSTS INCREASED. SO THE LAST
ISSUE IN THAT LAST TOPIC IN
ISSUE ONE. CONCERN THIS
AGREEMENT PROPOSAL. WHICH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MENTIONED
ZERO POINT 5% ENROLLMENT GROWTH
TWENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
SO IT'S OF COURSE HIGHLY IN
THIS POINT WHAT A MOMENT DEMAND
WILL BE IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. OH REALLY UNCLEAR AT THIS
POINT WHAT MIGHT BE NEEDED AS
FAR AS A MOMENT THE FUNDING. IF
COLLEGES KATE SCHOOL WHERE MANY
CAN YOU AND THEIR- LARGELY REAL.
THEIR PHYSICAL. IN THE FALL AND
THE ECONOMY SLOW TO RECOVER.
THEIR COMMITTEE COLLEGES COULD
SEE A SURGE ENROLLMENT.
ATTENTION ON THE OTHER HAND OF
COLLEGE AND SCHOOLS REMAIN
PRIMARILY.ONLINE IN THE FALL
WE COULD SEE THESE CURRENT
ENROLLMENT- TRENDS PERSIST. SO
LATER THIS THE CHANCELLOR
pOFFICE IS X. TO RE UPDATED IN.
ON AND ROMAN GROWTH USE AMONG
ALL OF. IN THE CURRENT YEAR IS
WELL AS WILL HAVE NUMBERS WITH
PRIORITY. AND BY SPRING WILL
LIKELY HAVE A CLEAR PICTURE OF
WHAT STATE AND WHAT THIS OF
WHAT SCHOOL AMONG. WHERE HEADED
INTO OF THEIR FOLLOW THE
OPENING PLAY. SO LEGISLATURE IS
GOING TO HAVE ENOUGH. TO USE
THAT INFORMATION ALL THAT
INFORMATION TO MAKE A CALL ON
THE ROLE THAT FUNDING AT THAT
TIME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE
CHANCELLOR OFFICE. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN MCCARTY AND MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY SUBCOMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION MY NAME IS THE SECOND
OF IT I SERVE AS THE VICE
CHANCELLOR COLLEGE FINANCE AT
THAT CALIFORNIA COULD BE
COLLEGES I WANT TO FIRST BEGAN
BY THINKING THE ASSEMBLY FOR
YOUR RESPONSIVENESS IN SUPPORT
OF THE EARLY ACTION BUDGET
PACKAGE YOUR EFFORTS PUT
STUDENTS FIRST THEY RECOGNIZE
THE HARDSHIP COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS FACED AND WILL ENABLE
OUR SYSTEM TO RESPOND QUICKLY
SO THAT THE EDUCATIONAL GOALS
OF THE GENERATION ARE NOT
FURTHER JEOPARDIZE. SO NOW
NEARLY TWELVE MONTHS INTO THE
COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC THE
DISRUPTIONS IT'S COSTS ARE ALL
TOO FAMILIAR MOST CONCERNING IS
THAT THE PANDEMIC THREATENS TO
HAVE LINGERING SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES OF
COLOR THIS IS WHERE WE ASK
CALIFORNIA'S ME COLLEGES CAN
PLAY A CLIP ARTICLE ROLE TO
SUPPORT THE ROAD TO RECOVERY AS
A STRATEGIC INVESTMENT LEADING
TO A MORE EQUITABLE. AND
RESILIENT CALIFORNIA. WE THAT.
FOR ITS GROUP THAT LAYS A
STRONG FOUNDATION FOR THE POST
PANDEMIC RECOVERY. SO DURING
THIS CRISIS IS PROVIDING
STABILITY HAS BEEN OUT OUR
OFFICE IS TOP PRIORITY TO THAT
END THE CHANCES OFFICE HAS USED
A MULTI FACETED APPROACH TO
PROVIDE FINANCIAL STABILITY TO
DISTRICTS DURING THIS UNCERTAIN
DURING. THE PRO CHOICE INCLUDED
THE APPLICATION OF THE TITLE
FIVE EMERGENCY CONDITION
ALLOWANCES TO DISTRICTS WHOSE
ENROLLMENT. WAS IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC. AND TO PER IN AND-
WHEN CALCULATE THE ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DEFERRALS THAT
WERE YOU INCLUDED FOR A SYSTEM
DITION ENSURING THAT EACH
DISTRICT RECEIVED AT LEAST 83%
OF THEIR REVENUE FROM ALL
SOURCES. AND PREVENTED
DISTRICTS IN LOW PROPERTY
WEALTH COMMUNITIES FROM BEARING
THE BURDEN OF DEFERRALS AS THE
TRADITIONALLY DO. THESE ACTIONS
ALSO PROVIDED SOME FINANCIAL
STABILITY DURING A VERY COMPLEX
PERIOD. HOWEVER THE PANDEMIC
CONTINUES AND- WE KNOW THAT A
RETURN TO ANY FORM OF NORMAL
WILL BE DIFFICULT AND SEEMS
DESTINED AND SO WE- BELIEVE
IT'S CRITICAL TO EVALUATE THE
LONG TERM FISCAL RESILIENCY OF
OUR SYSTEM. THAT INCLUDES
PROVIDING ONGOING RESOURCES TO
DISTRICTS AS THEY PREPARE FOR
INCREASED COST IN RECURRING
EXPENSES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
STATE'S CAMPUS REOPENING PAIN
DEFERRALS AND CONTINUING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA WHICH
PRESENTS OUR SYSTEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MORE
INTENTIONALLY FOCUS ON AND
ROLLING. AND SERVING LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. IN SUPPORTING
THEIR SUCCESSFUL JOURNEY. I NO
THE NATIONAL EVENT OVER THE
LAST YEAR HAVE COLD ASKING. TO
DISMISS STRUCTURES AND
PRACTICES THAT PERPETUATE
SYSTEMIC RACISM SINCE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS HAS SERVED AS
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
NORTH STAR TO CLOSING THE GAPS.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
PRESENTS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ALIGN SEVERAL PLANS THAT ARE
COLLEGES ALREADY PRODUCE
INCLUDING STUDENT EQUITY AND
ACHIEVEMENT PLANS ARE LOW AND
OUR LOCAL VISION GOALS. THESE
EFFORTS ARE NOT NEW TO OUR
SYSTEM BUT RATHER THE PROPOSAL
ALLOWS US TO APPROACH THESE
EFFORTS. MORE COHESIVELY. AND
AS WAS MENTIONED BY THE HOUR-
PER FOR CALL COULD TO GROW. AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GLAD SEE
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS IN I'M GOING FUNDS
INCLUDING A COLA AND GROWTH. WE
SURELY BIT ABOUT GROW. UNDER
THE S. PATH GROWTH CAN MORE THE
TRADITIONAL NOTION OF INCREASED
ENROLLMENTS IT CONSERVE TO
SUPPORT EFFORTS OF COLLEGES
THAT HAVE SEEN INCREASES IN THE
NUMBER OF LOW INCOME STUDENTS
THAT THEY ENROLL. AND IN THE
SUCCESSES THAT THEY PROVIDE TO
ALL THE STUDENTS THEY SERVE
WHERE POSSIBLE WE ENCOURAGE
ONGOING SUPPORT- WE ENCOURAGE
SUPPORT OF THE GROWTH AND WE
ENCOURAGE ON GOING SUPPORT FOR-
OUR OPERATIONAL NEEDS. WELL WE
URGE SHOULD ANY NEW RE. BECOME
OF AND MAYBE. PRIORITY PLACED
ON PAYING DOWN TO. SO THAT
DISTRICTS ARE NOT THREATENED BY
FUTURE UNCERTAINTIES M.
PRESENTED BY THESE REMAINING
DATS- WITH THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY QUESTIONS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER S. THE QUESTION
FOR DEPARTMENT FINANCE IN THE-
COMMENTS FROM THE L. A. O. VERY
SPECIFICALLY REGARDING THE-
REDIRECTING THE RESOURCES OF
UNPAID DOWN THE DEFERRALS- HOW
CAN HOW CAN WE MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. IT IT'S CLEAR THAT TO-
FOR TALKING ABOUT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WE GOT ONE
POINT ONE BILLION- BEING USED
TO PAY IT DOWNAND WE HAVE ONE
POINT FIVE AND- ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION THE DEFERRALS- WHY
CAN'T WE- CHANGE THAT- AND RE
DIRECT. TO TAKE CARE OF THESE
DEFERRALS. AT TEN IN OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THE
ADMINISTRATION UNDERSTANDS THAT
OUR GUARD COMMUNICORP STUDENTS
AND THE COLLEGES THEMSELVES ARE
ARE REALLY IN NEED OF.
IMMEDIATE RESOURCES TO HELP
THEM WEATHER THE STORM OF CUT
THE NINETEEN AND HELP ADDRESS
YOU KNOW THEIR STUDENTS
STUDENTS BASIC NEEDS AND
PROVIDE EMERGENCY FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE GRANTS AND SUCH SO-
BY CONTINUING A SMALL BUBBLE TO
FOR ALL THAT YOU KNOW YOU KNOW
THE ADMINISTRATION BUDGET
MULTIPLE. AFTER TO SIGNAL
REDUCE THAT. THANK YOU. A SMALL
BUBBLE PROFIT PRESENT FOR TO
USED TO BETTER THE NEED OF-
STUDENTS IN COLLEGES IN THE
SHOW TERM. THERE ARE. THAT ARE
PRICE- AS NOTED BY THE- IS THIS
SOMETHING THE ADMINS WILL COME.
I THINK GIVING- YOU KNOW NEW
PER. AND ALL THE FACTORS THAT
GO INTO MAYOR VISION I THINK.
PERHAPS TO GET THERE ARE NUMBER
OF AND- THEN- AS AS WE GO INTO
AMERICA'S AND I COULD CERTAINLY
A BACK. IF I MAY MISTER- THE
OTHER. HOW TO DO WITH THE STOOD.
SUPPORT OUR BENEFITS. AND THE
WAY I DO WANT TO SAY THAT I AM
A- BY BY THE GOVERNOR PROPOSAL.
TO REPAY THESE. TO AND
ENCOURAGE. RECRUIT EVERY TEN.
SO STILL MENTOR HEALTH AND
ADDRESS BY. NEEDS SO THERE'S A
LOT OF. IN THE BUT I THAT- AS
WE LOOK AT THE VALUE OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND- THE
NEEDTO PROVIDE MORE PROTECTION
AND MORE- MORE FUNDING. IN THE
AREAS THAT ARE THAT ARE NEEDED
MOST. I THINK WE REALLY NEED TO
LOOK AT THAT- WE RECOGNIZE THAT.
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE WILL THE
COMMUTER COLLEGES ARE RECEIVING
STUDENT COMPARED IT TO THE UC
SYSTEM IS ONE QUARTER- IT'S ONE
THIRD OF CSU SYSTEMS AND 40%
LESS THAN K. THROUGH TWELVE
WE'VE GOT TWO POINT ONE MILLION
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND UNFORTUNATELY AT
LEAST FROM THE NUMBERS OR
RECEIVING MANY OF THEM ARE IN
POVERTY AND THERE'S SO MUCH
MORE THAT WE NEED TO DO SO
SPECIFICALLY REGARDING THE
STUDENT SUPPORT PROPOSALS-
ELLIE- IS RECOMMENDING THAT THE
DISTRICTS BE GIVEN MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO USE THE FUNDS.
IT ISN'T THE END COMBINATION
REGARDING FOOD AND HOUSING AND
MENTAL HEALTH TECHNOLOGY
SERVICES DEPENDING ON THE NEEDS
OF THE SPECIFIC- DISTRICT AGAIN
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL CONSIDER. I
GET IT THAT THE- AS THE
VETERANS ARE GAP THAT THAT-
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
GOING TO CONSIDER IT PART OF
THAT THE MARRIAGE THE SENATE
CERTAINLY AND I CAN'T BACK A
THINK IN. THE GOVERNOR'S BY
REALLY TO IDENTIFY. BASIC ME
THAT WE FEEL- HAVE BEEN PRETTY
IMPACT AS THERE'S OF A COMPANY
IN AND ARE SORT OF ON GOING BE-
PARKING IN YOUR- DID. AND THEIR
OF THE BUDGET REALLY TOPICS
THOSE INTERN YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENING GET YOUR CAR. ABOUT
HOW THE TO CHECK UP THAT GOAL.
STAND ALONE THE SAME LINES IT'S
CLEAR THE- WE DO. THAT THERE
ARE SOME THAT. THE AYE THE
COMMUTE COLLEGES SHOULD PLAY A
LARGER ROLE IN A- THE CROSS.
ALIGNMENT BETWEEN TWELVE. AND
FOR YOUR UNIVERSE. I AGREE I
AGREE WITH THIS- COMMITTEE
COLLEGE WITHOUT DOUBT OUR THE
BRIDGE BETWEEN THE K. TWELVE.
AND THE FOR YOUR- BUT WE ALSO
HAVE TO BE SURE TO PROTECT
THOSE STUDENTS TO PROVIDE THE
FUNDING. FOR THEM- SO I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR RESPONSE. OKAY
THANK YOU. MISTER DONNA. THANK
YOU AND I APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK OF THE COMMITTEE COLLEGES
I'M PRODUCT OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA
AND JUST A COMMENT ON THE
DEFERRALS- I JUST I WOULD
ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO THINK OF
THIS A COUPLE DIFFERENT WAYS WE
CAN FRIGHTEN CARNATIC CLAWBACK
FOR SOME OF THOSE DOLLARS BUT I
PREFER THAT WE PAY ATTENTION OF
COAL HERE VISITING THE COAST
TOO LOW FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES- THAT'S WHAT THAT'S
WHERE I'D LIKE TO PUT MY FIGHT
SO I JUST THINK WE SHOULD
THINK. OPENLY ABOUT HOW WE
APPROACH THE DEFINING TOPIC
BECAUSE THE CALL IS ON GOING
THE FOR US WOULD BE ESSENTIALLY
ONE TIME ARGUABLY SO- I AM VERY
CONCERNED AT THE CALL HERE IS
TOO LOW AND THAT'S SOMETHING
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO TALK-
HAVE MORE MORE CONVERSATION.
ABOUT AS WE MOVE FORWARD. THANK
YOU. SOMEONE REVISED THAT AS- I
WOULD AGREE THAT YOU KNOW
FEDERAL FUNDS COULD FREE UP
GENERAL FUNDS TO EITHER PAY
DOWN DEFERRALS OR INCREASE THE
COLOR SO I THINK WE NEED TO
TAKE A MEASURED APPROACH BUT
BUT ALSO REALISTIC I DO HAVE A
QUESTION FOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FINANCE- THE CURES ACT
FUNDING INCLUDED TO A NINETY
TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR DIRECT AID TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS BUT
THERE WAS NO STATE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS RESULTING IN
LIMITED INFORMATION ON HOW
FUNDS WERE ALLOCATED. IS THE
EDITOR ADMINISTRATION
CONSIDERING INCLUDING REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR ANY OF THE
FEDERAL FUNDS. AT I BUT THAT
HARRIS FROM THE FINANCE THAT-
AT THIS TIME THAT WE DON'T HAVE
ANY THINKS ABOUT ABOUT
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS RELATED
TO THAT- THAT'S THE ONLY THING
THAT I CAN I CAN TAKE BACK AND
WE CAN GET THAT ARE ARE THE
MAJOR VISION PAPA BUT AT THE
TIME WITH OTHER THAN RELATED TO
THE POINT. I IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE ARE WE ARE ACCOUNTABLE
WITH OUR FUN. SO I WOULD. THE
THANK YOU. I'M AND THEN. OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE HERE. AT
COLLEGES. OUR STUDENTS NOT
ENROLLING BECAUSE- THEY'RE OR
THEY'RE NOT RE ENROLLING
WHERE'S THE LOSS OCCURRING FROM
IS IT STUDENTS THAT ARE NOT RE
ENROLLING OR NEW STUDENTS NOT
ENROLLING. GOOD MORNING LIZ
THAT NUMBER AT WITH BIG
CALIFORNIA RECALL CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE I'M HAPPY TO. BRIEFLY
ADDRESS A WHAT WE KNOW AND OUR
EARLY RECORDINGS SO WE ARE JUST
NEEDING ANALYSES OF ENROLLMENT-
FOR FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY AND
GETTING. UPDATES FROM OUR
COLLEGES BUT WHAT WE'RE SEEING
IS THAT THE COMBINATION OF
STUDENTS ARE TAKING FEWER
UNITS- TO ACCOMMODATE FOR
COMPLEXITIES IN THEIR PERSONAL
LIVES. AND WE'RE ALSO SEEING-
NEW STUDENTS NOT NECESSARILY
AND ROLL AND OUR COLLEGES AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE WANT
TO LOOK LOOK INTO TWENTY GONNA
FIGHT WHO ARE THESE POPULATIONS
WHAT REGIONS ARE THEY AND- WHAT
MORE CAN WE DO TO ENCOURAGE
THEM. TO COME BACK TO OUR
CAMPUSES- TO RECOGNIZE THAT.
YOU KNOW WE OFFER A VERY
PROGRAMS- THROUGH DISTANCE
LEARNING. AND THAT OUR IN
PERSON AND- I SENT CITY PRO ARE
SAFE SO ARE ALL AFTER THAT WILL
CONTINUE IN COMING MONTHS.
RIGHT YOU. SEVENTEEN YOUR
QUESTION OKAY GO BACK TO
FILARET AND OUR I'D LIKE. TO-
REGARDING COMMENTS FOR MR I
HAVE AGREE AND WITH THE COURSE
WOULD BE THAT IN THE GOVERNOR'S.
THE FOR COMEDIC IS ONE POINT 4%
BECAUSE OF LIVING WHERE'S THE
CATER TO IS. THREE EIGHT FOUR.
EVERYBODY TO GET OUR STUDENTS
BACK. AND THERE'S THE ISSUE OF
THAT. SO TO A EXTENT TO THIS
BUT- COAL PROMOTE EQUITY. AMONG
OUR COULD CALL CASE TWELVE AND
FOR YOUR DINNER. YOU WANT THAT
FOR THE OF FINE FOR THE-
DEPARTMENT FIND. FOR DO WE HAVE
DANIEL HANOVER STILL THERE. MY
APOLOGIES- FOR BEING OF YOU AND
DOES NOTHING- SO THAT THEY YOU-
YEAH THINK OVERALL FIRST OFF
I'D SAY THAT THE ONE POINT FIVE
TO COLA IS- ARE CALCULATED
PREVENTIVE TRADITION USE- FOR
THE BUDGET- BY IN GENERAL I
THINK ARE THE MINISTER. FOCUSED
THAT BY WAS REALLY. TO- THE
NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS I THINK
ALSO SEEN WITH SOMETHING THAT
STATE ENROLLMENT DECLINE
EVERYTHING. AT THE CLINIC ARE
AS A RESULT OF THE NINETEEN AND
THAT AND- WITHOUT DURING THE
LAST THAT THOSE STUDENTS THAT.
BUT DO NOT TEND TO BACK
COMMUNITY COLLEGE I THINK WITH
THE AS A BIG BOMB THREAT TO-
THE BUDGET OF OUR COLLEGE SO.
SAID THAT THE GOAL OF THE
BUDGET FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
BUDGET PROVIDE FOR THE BASIC
NEEDS OF OUR STATE AND ENSURE
THAT THEIR NEEDS ARE BEING TO
KEEP AND ALL. POSE FOR K.
THROUGH TWELVE. THERE STILL
REMAINS THE ISSUE OF EQUITY AND
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I
WOULD LIKE THE ADMINISTRATION
TO. TO CONSIDER YEAH AND- IN
THESE NEGOTIATIONS. YEAH RIGHT
I'LL JUST JUMP IN HERE I WANT
TO LET THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS GO
FIRST AND YOU PRETTY MUCH
ADDRESSED THE ISSUES I WAS
GOING TO SAY AND- I'M I'M I'M
NOT GONNA ASK THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES QUESTION BECAUSE YOU
PROBABLY JUST GIVE US A
FRUSTRATING ANSWER I DON'T.
WANT TO GO DOWN THAT ROAD THIS
MORNING. BUT I THINK IT'S
NONSENSE THAT THE BUYING POWER
FOR THE RIVERSIDE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS THE SAME FOR THE
RIVERSIDE COMMUNICABLE
DISTRICT. THE COST OF UTILITIES
AND LABOR. AND EVERYTHING ELSE
IS THE SAME AND RIVERSIDE. SAN
JOSE SACRAMENTO LONG BEACH AND
THEN NORTH LA SO IT'S TO JUST
TO HAVE THIS DIFFERENTIAL
THING. IS JUST TOTALLY UNFAIR
AND JUST KIND OF CLUELESS TO
WHAT THE REALITY IS- OBVIOUSLY
I THINK THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES TO PUT TOGETHER A
BUDGET. AND MAYBE OR JUST
PENCILING THIS NUMBER I THERE
TO EXPECT BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
WE COULD AFFORD. BUT DID TO BUT
TO SAY THAT IT'S THE FAIR
FORMULA BASED UPON A
CALCULATION. DOESN'T MEAN ANY
SENSE BECAUSE OTHERWISE YOU
WOULDN'T HAVE THAT HIGHER COLA
FOR OTHER. INDIVIDUALS IN THE
EDUCATION WORLD AS WELL- SO
CERTAINLY THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE HELP WITH INCREASE REVENUES
WITH THEM NAY REVISE THAT YOU
KNOW WE'RE LOOKING FOR SEEING
HOW THE ECONOMY IS MOVING ALONG
THAT IT. AT OF IMPRESSIVE CLIP
SO. CERTAINLY THERE THAT COULD
CHANGE WITH NEW RABBITS COMMAND
AFTER THEY PULL TAX RECEIPTS
AND GET THE MAY REVISE BUT
SOMETHING THAT WE MADE WE MAY
LOOK AT TO REGARDLESS AS FAR AS
HOW MUCH MONEY WE HAVE. IN IN
PROP NINETY EIGHT SO THAT'S
SAYS THAT AN INEQUITY. AND THEN
AND THEN TYING IT TO THESE
OTHER PIECES FOR- ONLINE I'M
NOT SURE THAT THE WISDOM OF
THAT AS THE L. A. L. SAT IT
JUST SEEMS THAT. IF YOU'RE
GONNA DO IT DO IT BUT WHITE
WHITE TIE IT TO SOME ARBITRARY
OTHER PIECE. ESPECIALLY WHEN
THERE'S SO MUCH
DIFFERENTIATION. ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. AS AS THE L. A. L.
NOTED SO. THAT THOSE ARE THE
COMMENTS AND KIND OF DIRECTION
THAT WILL HAVE- GOING FORWARD.
AS FAR AS THE ENROLLMENT YOU
KNOW THAT IS. A CONCERN FOR US
AND I THINK IT'S- IT'S- REALLY
INTERESTING BECAUSE USUALLY.
WHEN WE HAVE A RECESSION
THROUGHOUT HISTORY IN
CALIFORNIA THE COMMUNICABLE
JUST MORE PEOPLE GO TO SCHOOL
RIGHT. AND SO YOU KNOW THAT'S
NOT HAPPENING HERE ESPECIALLY.
WITH LOW WAGE WORKERS BEING THE
ONES WHO ARE HAMMERED THE MOST
DURING THIS PANDEMIC WE'VE SEEN
YOU KNOW LOW WAGE WORKERS WOMEN
PEOPLE OF COLOR THOSE ARE THAT.
WOMEN OF COLOR ESPECIALLY TO
LOOK AT THE ACROSS THE NATION
WHO IS BEING IMPACTED- YOU KNOW
THOSE ARE THE TYPE OF
INDIVIDUALS WE WANT TO GET YOU
KNOW GETTING MORE- EDUCATION
INVOLVED OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO HAVE MORE CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES THAT. THERE'S
OTHER NEEDS FOR THEM FINANCIAL
AID DEALING WITH THEIR FAMILIES
DEALING WITH THEIR OWN KIDS
TRYING TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL. SO
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE NEED
TO CERTAINLY MONITOR- WE- JUST
TRY TO STEP UP YESTERDAY WITH
THE MID YEAR BUDGET ACTION. BUT
WE KNOW IT'S NOT JUST COLIN
ROMAN THERE ARE SO MANY OTHER
PROGRAMS. IN AND ELEMENTS THAT
HELP STUDENTS SUCCEED AND SO
THAT'S KIND OF THAT KIND OF A
PRELUDE TO THE NEXT. ISSUE
NUMBER TWO IS ALL THESE OTHER
BASIC NEEDS TO THIS ISSUE WE
WILL HOLD OPEN NO ACTION HERE-
ON THIS ISSUE NUMBER ONE. FOR
BASS FUNDING ENROLLMENT AND
WITH THAT CAN WE HAVE A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- PRESENT
ON. ISSUE NUMBER TWO BASIC
NEEDS PROPOSALS. THE COURT. I
SAID THAT THE GOVERNMENT BUDGET
BIRTH ND FOREMOST THAT STUDENT
FOCUSED BUDGET. INSTRUCTION
RECOGNIZE THE CHALLENGES FACED
BY OUR STATE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENT AS A RESULT OF THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
GIVING RECESSION. EIGHT
CHALLENGES HAVE LED TO AN
ESTIMATED 8% DECLINE IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ENROLLMENT
FROM PAUL TWENTY NINETEEN TO
FALL TWENTY TWENTY. THIS BUDGET
IS DESIGNED TO HELP ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF STUDENTS. DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME INTO THAT AND
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
SIGNIFICANT FUNDS TO HELP
ADDRESS STUDENTS ABILITY TO
AFFORD COLLEGE. THE TYPICALLY
THE BUDGET INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION FOR EMERGENCY
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE GRANTS FOR
STUDENTS. OF WHICH ONE HUNDRED
MILLION WITH INCLUDING THE
IMMEDIATE ACTION PACKAGE. ONE
HUNDRED MILLION PROVIDED ON A
ONE TIME BASIS BUT AVAILABLE
OVER THREE YEARS. ADDRESS
STUDENT BASIC NEEDS INCLUDING
FOOD AND HOUSING. AND THIRTY
MILLION ONGOING FOR TARGETED
BASIC STUDENTS ARE FOR TARGETED
STUDENT BASIC NEEDS TO PROVIDE
MENTAL HEALTH AND DIGITAL
EQUITY WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE. THANK YOU L. L.
ADMINISTRATION'S FOCUS ON BASIC
NEEDS INCLUDING FOOD HOUSING
MENTAL HEALTH IS LAUDABLE BASIC
NEEDS WAS A PROBLEM BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC AND THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
IS HEARD ABOUT THIS THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS- THE PROBLEMS
EVEN GOTTEN WORSE SINCE THE
PANDEMIC BEGAN. TO DATE THE
STATE'S APPROACH TO ADDRESSING
BASIC NEEDS HAS BEEN RATHER
PIECEMEAL. A LOT OF ONE TIME
FUNDING AND LACK LACKING AN
OVERARCHING GOALS AND
STRATEGIES FOR WHAT WE WANT TO
ACHIEVE. AND HOW TO DO IT
ALTHOUGH THE GOVERNOR SHOULD BE
COMMENDED FOR THIS FOCUSES
APPROACH HOUSE OF ELEMENTS WE
THINK COULD BE IMPROVED UPON.
FOR EXAMPLE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET DOESN'T SPECIFY HOW TO
PROPOSE NEW PROGRAMS WOULD
INTERACT WITH EACH OTHER. APPLE
AS WELL AS HOW THEY'D INTERACT
WITH EXISTING PROGRAMS OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO
POTENTIALLY THE PROPOSAL COULD
CREATE MORE SILOS. ARE ALSO.
ANOTHER ELEMENT WE THINK COULD
BE IMPROVED IMPROVED UPON IS
THE GOVERNOR PROVIDE IT'S ONE
TIME FUNDS FOR A PURPOSE FOOD
PANTRY AND HOUSING ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS IT REALLY REQUIRES
SOME ONGOING FUNDING TO BE
SUSTAINABLE. ALTHOUGH THE
GOVERNOR'S APPROACH- THE
GOVERNOR'S APPROACH ALSO
PROVIDES FUNDS WITHOUT ANY
EXPECTATION OF LEVELS OF
SERVICE OR DESIRED OUTCOMES. SO
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER AN ALTERNATIVE
APPROACH BY CREATING A BASIC
NEEDS BLOCK GRANTS THE IDEA
HERE WOULD BE TO USE ALL OR A
PORTION OF THE PROPOSED MONEY
FOR MENTAL HEALTH TECHNOLOGY
FOOD AND HOUSING IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND INTEGRATE
THAT MONEY WITH THE EXISTING
ONGOING FUNDS FROM THE- RAPID
RE HOUSING PROGRAM THAT THAT
NINE MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
IT'S PROVIDED ALONG WITH THIS
APPROACH THE LEGISLATURE COULD
BE CLEAR ABOUT EXPECTATIONS
MINIMUM SERVICE LEVELS AND
DESIRED OUTCOMES. BUT THEN GIVE
FLEXIBILITY TO THE COLLEGE
DECIDE HOW TO STRUCTURE THEIR
PROGRAMS HOW TO USE THE FUNDING
FOR EXAMPLE DISTRICTS COULD
CHOOSE TO HIRE A BASIC NEEDS
COORDINATOR AT EACH CAMPUS AND
ESTABLISH A ONE STOP HUB JUST
AN EXAMPLE PROS THEY MIGHT WANT
TO TAKE. WITH THIS MONEY AND
THEN CREATE ALL OF THIS MONEY-
IN THE WAY THEY SEE FIT TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS
SHE COULD HAVE DISTRICTS REPORT
REGULARLY ON SERVICE LEVELS
SUCH AS APPOINTMENT WAIT TIMES
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS SERVE
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS ENROLLED
IN. THE FOOD STAMP PROGRAM
CALFRESH AND WHETHER STUDENTS
TO ACCESS THESE STUDENTS STATE
AND ROLLED. AND ENDED UP
GRADUATING. STILL THE EMERGENCY
FINANCIAL AID GRANTS WHICH IS
ALSO PART OF THIS ISSUE NUMBER
TWO THE LEGISLATURE AS YOU'VE
NOTED ARCHER MCCARTY IS TAKEN
AFTER EARLY ACTION ON PROVIDING
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. TO
STUDENTS. WITH REGARD TO THE
OTHER HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR STUDENT
AID WE WOULD NOTE THAT CONGRESS
AND THE BY THE MINISTRATION ARE
DISCUSSING A THIRD ROUND A
FEDERAL RELIEF FUNDS. FUNDING
LARGER THAN THE FIRST TWO
ROUNDS COMBINED WHICH WOULD
INCLUDE MONEY FOR EMERGENCY
FINANCIAL AID TO STUDENTS. SO
WE'LL HAVE TO TRACK WHAT
HAPPENS AT THE AT THE NATIONAL
LEVEL AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL BUT
ASSUMING THIS THIRD ROUND IS
APPROVED- WINTERS THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER TO
CONSIDER USING THE PROPOSED
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR OTHER PRIORITIES THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL NOT
FUND FOR EXAMPLE THE BILL
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
COULD BE RE PURPOSED- BY THE
LEGISLATURE FOR ADDITIONAL PAY
DOWNS OR TO HELP WITH PENSION
RELIEF. SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. ENGINE
AFTER MANY OF OUR STUDENTS
FINANCES ARE THE MAIN BARRIER
TO ACHIEVING THEIR EDUCATIONAL
GOALS FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE
FRAIL COOLEY ATTACHED TO
EDUCATION THE NEW ECONOMIC AND
SOCIAL CHALLENGES SUCH AS
pDAYCARE SHIFTING WORK SCHEDULE
AND AN ANTICIPATED EXPENSES
WERE THE LAST STRAW DESIGN
POSTER CLEARER THAN EVER OUR
STUDENTS DESPERATELY NEED.
EMERGENCY GRANT ACCESS WE THINK
THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR PUTTING STUDENT
NEEDS ARE IN THE IMMEDIATE
ACTION PACKAGE AND- INCLUDING
IT IN THE BUDGET CONSIDERATIONS
BEFORE YOU MANY COLLEGES HAVE
BEEN THE MOST AFFECTED STUDENT
POPULATION AND HIGHER AT NOW AS
A RESULT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
INVESTMENT MERGING SEA GRANT
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS THE MOST
PRESSING NEEDS AND ENSURE THE
HEALTH AND ECONOMIC CRISIS DOES
NOT PUT. THEIR EDUCATIONAL
DREAMS ON HOLD THESE ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS ARE ALSO KEY TO
STABILIZING ENROLLMENTS HOWEVER
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THESE FUNDS WILL BE DISTRIBUTED
BY FINANCIAL AID OFFICES THAT
HAVE SEEN REDUCTIONS FOR THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS INCLUDING A
THREE POINT SIX MILLION A
REDUCTION IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
WE URGE A BALANCED APPROACH
THAT SUPPORTS BOTH OUR STUDENTS
BUT ALSO THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT ENABLES THE DELIVERY. OF
THOSE SERVICES. AND AS WE
FURTHER DEVELOP A HOLISTIC
STUDENT CENTRIC APPROACH TO
BASIC NEEDS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
INTEGRATING HEALTH FRESH
OUTRAGE AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. WE BELIEVE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CAN BETTER LEVERAGE
AND FORTIFY PARTNERSHIPS WITH
COUNTIES SO THATTHE RESOURCES
ARE WIDELY UTILIZED AND
EFFECTIVE. AS SUCH AND AS A
RECOMMENDED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THE LEGISLATURE MAY
CONSIDER MENTAL HEALTH
INVESTMENTS FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES FROM POP PROP SIXTY
THREE AS A WAY TO NOTONLY
BUILD THE STATE'S EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH CREATES
STRONGER PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
COLLEGES AND COUNTIES. LASTLY
WE ASK THAT THE ASSEMBLY
CONSIDER APPROACHES TO BASIC
NEEDS BUT YOU ALSO LOOK AND
PURSUED LONG TERM SOLUTIONS BY
WAY OF CAL GRANT REFORM WHICH
WE NOTE THAT CHAIRMAN CARTY IN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA HAVE
BEEN LONG CHAMPIONS AND
ADVOCATES FOR. OF PROVIDING
LONG TERM CAL GRANT REFORM WILL
ENSURE THAT YOU COLLEGE
STUDENTS CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD AS A TOP PRIORITY AND
MY COLLEAGUES WILL GO INTO
GREATER DEPTH ON THIS MATTER IN
ISSUE FIVE. THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU- I'LL START WITH A
FEW QUESTIONS ON ON THESE
ISSUES SO CERTAINLY THIS IS A
TOPIC THAT HAS GARNERED
INCREASED ATTENTION IN SUPPORT
IN THE LEGISLATURE THE LAST FEW
YEARS WE REALIZE THAT IT'S NOT
JUST THE CAMPUS THAT THE THAT
THE FACULTY THAT TRADITIONAL.
ELEMENTS AS FAR AS STUDENT
SUCCESS THAT THAT REALLY MATTER
IT'S ESPECIALLY WITH THE
POPULATION WERE FACING I'S-
ALL THESE OTHER ISSUES WITH
FOOD INSECURITY AND- HOUSING
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THAT
THAT HAVE SO MUCH IMPACT ON.
STUDENT SUCCESS OF. THE FEW
THINGS I WANT TO JUST KIND OF.
TEASE OUT HERE. ONE WE DO KNOW
THE COMMUNICATORS ARE VERY VERY
DIVERSE MORE THAN A HUNDRED
CAMPUSES ACROSS CALIFORNIA OF
COURSE- ALL OF THESE CAMPUSES
HAVE IT REGARDLESS OF WHERE
THEY'RE AT HAD SOME STUDENTS
WHO FACE. THESE ISSUES AND-
NEED SUPPORT FOR SOMEBODY'S.
SOMEBODY'S AFTERWARDS SO. CAN
EITHER DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OR
THE CHANCE WITH OFFICER BOTH IT
MAY BE RESPOND TO WHAT THE L.
A. I WAS TALKING ABOUT AN INCH
INCH AS OPPOSED TO PICKING AND
CHOOSING WINNERS AND LOSERS
WHETHER IT'S ON GOING OR ONE
TIME AND- OF COURSE I THINK
THESE BASIC THESE ARE OUR
ONGOING ISSUES AND SO. IT'S
HARD TO GET GOING WITH THESE
EFFORTS WITH ONE TIME MONEY- IS
THERE MERIT TO THIS IDEA OF
THAT WE SHOULD THEY WE SHOULD
HAVE THESE KIND OF MANY
CATEGORICAL HERE BUT MORE BROAD
BLOCK GRANT FOR THE CALL JUST
TO FIGURE OUT WHERE THEY WANT
TO SPEND THEIR MONEY. SO LET'S
START WITH THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE ON THAT OKAY. THANK YOU
JIM MCCARTY- WE'VE DEFINITELY
SEEN THAT- AND AS CONSIDERED IN
THIS COMMITTEE WE'VE SEEN
GROWING ATTENTION AND GROWING
NEEDS AROUND BASIC AND SECURITY
OF FOOD HOUSING WE ALSO A
SENIOR COLLEGES TAKE ON VERY
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES TO
ADDRESSING BASIC NEEDS SO WE DO
THINK THERE IS MERIT IN
CONSIDERING HOW WE CREATE. AN
INTERSECTION BETWEEN ALL OF
THOSE EFFORTS SO THAT WE CAN
BUILD A COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT- WE
BELIEVE OUT HAS SOME
CONSIDERATION AND- WE THINK OUR
COLLEGES AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
OUR STUDENTS COULD BENEFIT FROM
SUCH AN APPROACH SO DO YOU OR
DON'T USE SUPPORT WITH THE L.
A- RECOMMENDS INCREASING AS
BLOCK GRANTS FOR THESE MONIES
AND OTHER MONIES OR SHOULD WE
HAVE THESE. MANY. CATEGORICAL
THREE EACH OF THESE. ALL I
THINK AS IN AND POLICY EFFORTS
WOULD WANT TO SEE THE DETAILS
ON HOW THIS IS CRAFTED BUT WE
ARE READY TO WORK WITH YOU AND
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
CRAFT AN APPROACH THAT- IS
COMPREHENSIVE IN NATURE THAT
INCLUDES. BOTH AN INTERSEX
INVOLVES AN EXISTING-
INVESTMENTS IN BASIC NEEDS BUT
ALSO SOME OF THE NEW ONES THAT
HAVE BEEN PROPOSED. ALSO I
WOULD ADD- DATA ALIGNMENT-
PARTICULARLY WITH COUNTIES AS
WE EMBARK ON CALFRESH EFFORTS
HAVING AND DATA SO THAT WE KNOW
WHETHER OUTREACH IS HELPING US
INCREASE CALFRESH ENROLLMENT
THAT THINK THEY'RE MANY
PROBLEMS. AND DETAILS THAT
COULD BE WORKED OUT IN A VERY
POWERFUL PROPOSAL. AT OKAY.
WHAT DEPARTMENT OF THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE HAVE AN
OPINION ON ON THE ILIO
RECOMMENDATION FOR. MORE OF A
BLOCK GRANT. FOR THESE. ALL
THOSE AND OTHERS THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE FUNDED IN THE
CAN YOU CALL JUST FOR BASIC
NEEDS. FOR I I'D SAY THAN
SIMILAR WHERE YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN
CONVERSATIONS REGARDING THAT
TEN AND HOW BEST TO MEET THAT
THE- BASIC NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS. OF OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS- AT AGAIN THE
ADMINISTRATION PARTY WAS REALLY
TO ADDRESS THE- SPECIFIC BASIC
NEEDS THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED
THAT. PARTICULAR HEADING FOR
STUDENTS SUCH AS YOU KNOW MEANT
TO HOLD. ELECTED HE COULDN'T
HOUSING- INTO RAPID ENGAGEMENT
AND CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW
BEST TO ADDRESS THOSE. YEAH
IT'S- AND AS FAR AS A MENTAL
HEALTH I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THAT THE GOVERNOR PUTTING AT
THE PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET BUT
LINKING THAT MENTAL HEALTH AND
TECHNOLOGY IT SEEMS KIND OF
RANDOM THINGS ARE BOTH.
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT WE SHOULD
FOCUS ON BOTH OF THOSE. I WILL
NOTE THAT AS FAR AS MENTAL
HEALTH THERE IS MONEY OF COURSE
HERE AND THERE IS ANOTHER
EFFORT THAT. THAT THAT I'M
WORKING ON AND OTHERS. TO LOOK
AT THE PROP SIXTY THREE FIND
AND THAT'S YOU KNOW THE
MILLIONAIRES TAX FOR. MENTAL
HEALTH WHICH THAT FIND IT YOU
KNOW IT'S CALIFORNIA'S LEADERS
ARE DOING QUITE WELL CALIFORNIA
MEANING YOUR DISTRICT RIGHT.
THEY- THAT FUND IS JUST
EXPLODING AND- WITH THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND BECAUSE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND I THINK
THAT'S A BIG PRIMARY THAT AND
WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO TESTIFY FOR THAT IN A
FEW SECONDS. BUT THE ONE THING
TOO I KNOW THAT I KNOW THAT
SOMEONE MEMBER BERMAN HAS AN
IDEA ON THIS IS THAT THESE
BASIC NEEDS CENTERS ARE SO KEY
AYE AYE AYE COUPLE YEARS AGO I
PUT MY IN THE BUDGET TO FIND
ONE HERE AT SACRAMENTO CITY
COLLEGE- KIND OF ANNOYED THAT I
GIVE TO ENOUGH MONEY IN DOLLARS
IT'S NOT DONE YET TWO YEARS
LATER SO CHANCES OFFICE MAKE
SURE. YOU CAN TALK TO OUR LOCAL
SERRET LOS RIOS TO GET ON IT
BUT THE ISSUE THOUGH IS THAT
STUDENTS THERE'S NOT DATE
SOMETIMES AS A MENU OF THINGS
THEY HAVE CHALLENGES WITH STUFF
THAT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
RAPID RE HOUSING LEADING UP TO
SIGN UP FOR CALFRESH OR HEALTH
CARE OR OTHER ISSUES AND SO.
HAVING SOMETHING THAT'S ONGOING
OR AFP THAT'S IN A KEY ON THE
CAMPUS. WHERE STUDENTS AN GO I
THINK IS THE KEY YOU KNOW WE
TALK ABOUT WE SPENT AN HOUR TWO
WEEKS AGO TALKING ABOUT CALPERS
SO BY DEFINITION. MOST OF THE
STUDENTS ARE VERY VERY LOW
INCOME AND CALFRESH IS SUPPOSED
TO BY DEFINITION. PROVIDE FOOD
FOR LOW INCOME PEOPLE BUT- IT'S
HARD TO LINK THOSE TWO THINGS
TOGETHER SO. HAVING THESE BASIC
NEEDS CENTERS ON. CAMPUS IS A
PLACE TO GO THAT ARE.
ADEQUATELY STAFF THAT HAVE
HOURS AVAILABLE OR- THAT YOU
HAVE PEOPLE YOU CAN CALL
ENTERED YOU HAVE AN APP OR WHAT
HAVE YOU SO. CAN STUDENTS CAN
ENGAGE. I THINK IS A IS IT IS
AN IDEA THAT WE SHOULD FOCUS ON
BECAUSE- IT'S BRIDGING THIS FOR
SERVICES IN THE STUDENTS WHICH
IS THE KEY AND OTHERWISE IF YOU
JUST HAVE THESE. ON OVER HERE
OVER HERE AND HERE AND YOU
DON'T CONNECT. IT'S NOT ALWAYS
GOING TO WORK- THOSE ARE MY
KIND OF MY THOUGHT THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE LOOKING AT AS WE CLOSE
OUT THIS YEAR'S THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET SO. QUESTIONS COMMENTS
BY MEMBERS ON THIS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IT. JUST WANT TO
ABSOLUTELY WORTH MY DREAM IT
WITH YOU ON THAT I THINK THAT
THESE BASIC NEED BLOCK GRANTS.
ARE ACTUALLY A VERY GOOD IDEA
YEAH AND- PROVIDING THE- WHAT
THE DISTRICTS NEED- TO MAKE THE
DECISIONS BASED ON THE NEEDS OF
THEIR STUDENTS- I LIKE THE IDEA
OF YOUR BASIC NEEDS CENTERS AND
I HOPE THAT. THE FUNDING CAN BE
PROVIDED ALSO FOR SAMPOERNA
DINO VALLEY COLLEGE AND SOME OF
OUR OTHER COMMUNITY COLLEGES- I
THINK THAT THE IDEA IS GREAT I
THINK THAT WITH THE BASIC
NEEDS. BLOCK GRANTS HAVING
STATE OBJECTIVES AND REPORTING-
ON THE OBJECTIVES WOULD BE
IMPORTANT SO IN THE END WE GET
TO WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSING. BUT WE ALLOW IT TO
BE DONE AT THE DISTRICT LEVEL
BECAUSE THEY WILL BE IN A
BETTER POSITION TO DETERMINE.
WHAT THE NEEDS ARE AND HOW IT
SHOULD BE DIVIDED I AGREE WITH
YOU WITH THE CHAIR THAT PUTTING
MENTAL HEALTH AND TECHNOLOGY
AND ONE GROUP. JUST DIDN'T MAKE
ANY SENSE BUT- HAVING A BLOCK
GRANT I THINK IT'S JUST A GREAT
IDEA. SEVEN REVISED THAT
ESTIMATE TO MEDINA- I CONCUR
WITH MY COLLEAGUES THAT I THINK
THAT THE BLOCK GRANT APPROACH
IS- IS REALLY WHAT'S BEST FOR
OUR DISTRICTS ARE HOME
DISTRICTS AND GIVING THEM THE
FLEXIBILITY JUST TO CLARIFY
THOUGH SO BOTH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ARE OPEN
TO. THIS TYPE OF MODEL FUNDING.
WAS THAT EVER I DON'T HAVE THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE- YET WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN
SUCH A CONVERSATION AGAIN TO
LOOK AT- IN AN INNOVATIVE
APPROACH TO BASIC NEEDS. WE
KNOW IT'S AN- ON. GOING EFFORT
ON TO ADDRESS THIS IN THE
HOUSE- OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
MADE A LOT OF PROGRESS AND
LEARNED A LOT SO WE WANT TO.
INCLUDE SOME OF THE EVIDENCE.
AND PRACTICES THAT WE LEARN
FROM FROM OUR CAMPUSES. AS THIS
IS CRAFTED. DEPARTMENT AND TELL
THEM THAT ARE THAT ARE. AND-
YEAH I THINK WE'RE WE'RE IN THE
SAME POSITION WHAT WERE WERE
HAPPY NOW CONVERSATIONS THAT
THAT THE THING THAT STRUCK FOR
THE MIGRATION PROBLEM. GREAT
AND- TO THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
THE CORONA VIRUS RESPONSE AND
RELIEF SUPPLEMENTAL
APPROPRIATIONS ACTOR I GUESS
SURSA- REQUIRES AT LEAST THE
SAME AMOUNT OF STUDENT AID AS
THE AMOUNT ALLOCATED UNDER THE
CARES ACT SO. IS DOES THE
COMMUNITY CALLED THE COMMITTEE
COLLEGES PLAN TO USE ANY OF THE
BILLION DOLLARS PROVIDED AS A
FLEXIBLE INSTITUTIONAL AID FOR
ADDITIONAL STUDENT AID OR TO
SUPPORT OTHER BASIC NEEDS. IT
AT THE WHEN THEY IS THE SECOND
SENSUALLY SECOND STIMULUS FOR
COOPER TIRE RACK WAS PROVIDED
ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS THAT WE
DID WITHIN THE TEAMSTERS OFFICE
IS ENCOURAGING COLLEGES TO
SPEND MORE THAN THE MINIMUM ON
EMERGENCY NEEDS SO AS YOU KNOW
THE MINIMUM WAS AROUND THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. SO WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WILL HAPPEN OUR COLLEGES
ARE YOU KNOW SEEING THOSE
RESOURCES COME TO- BE
ACCESSIBLE TO HAPPEN THE LAST
FEW MONTHS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
FOLLOW UP WITH THEM NO DIRECT
REPORTING WAS REQUIRED OF THIS
FEDERAL BILLS SO WHEN WE SEEK
OUT INFORMATION WE ARE DOING
SO- DO SURVEYS TO HER CAMPUSES
TO GET A SENSE OF NOT ONLY WHO
THEY'RE SERVING BUT ALSO- HUMAN
COURAGE THAT THEY ARE USING
MORE THAN THE MINIMUM. I WILL
ADD THAT ON THROUGH EFFORTS
OVER THIS SPRING AND SUMMER
WE'VE ALSO CLARIFIED THAT THESE
DOLLARS CAN BE USED FOR
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AND
OTHERS THAT MAY HAVE BEEN LEFT
OUT ZACKS LOSER AREAS. THAT WE
EMPHASIZED. THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU MR MEDINA THE GUY
JUST ONE OF A AGREE WITH OUR
WITH OUR CHAIR AND POINT OUT
THAT THE IDEA OF A LOCAL BASIC
NEEDS CENTERED ON EACH OF THE
CAMPUSES ARE- COLLEGES MAKES
SENSE AND I WOULD JUST ADD THAT
WHAT WE SAW AT THE BEGINNING OF
PANDEMIC WHEN PHILANTHROPIC
GROUPS I GOT TOGETHER TO REACT
TO THE EMERGENCY NEED OF
STUDENTS THAT THAT MONEY WAS%
GONE THAT MONEY WAS GONE FOR
BASIC NEEDS WITHIN HOURS- AND
LARGE SUM OF MONEY. A STATE
WIDE AND- THE DEMAND FOR THAT
AID WAS IMMEDIATE AND
OVERWHELMING SO WANT TO SUPPORT
THE IDEA OF- BASIC NEEDS ON
CENTERS ON CAMPUS. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL HOLD THIS THIS
ISSUE OPEN- GOING TO ISSUE
NUMBER THREE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROPOSALS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AGAIN
AND OUR DEPARTMENT WITH THE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
DIMINISHING CONTINUES THAT
COMMITMENT TO WORK BASED
LEARNING AND HELPING STUDENTS
ATTAIN. AIMED OR RETAIN
EMPLOYMENT AFTER FINISHING
THEIR PROGRAM. THIS COMMITMENT
HAS BECOME EVEN MORE IMPERATIVE
AND THE COCA NINETEEN PANDEMIC
THE FACT THAT EVERY SECTOR OF
THE STATE'S ECONOMY. AND ITS
CONTRACTORS HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT.
THAT AND THE BUDGET INCLUDES
TWENTY MILLION ONETIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND TO EXPAND WORK
BASED LEARNING MODEL AND
FIFTEEN MILLION ONGOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND TO AUGMENT THE
CALIFORNIA APPRENTICESHIP
INITIATIVE. WITH THAT I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY.
THANK YOU L. L. THANK YOU ALL
ALL TALK ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
APPRENTICESHIP INITIATIVE
PERSONAL WORK BASED FINANCING
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF CONCERNS
WITH EXPANDING FUNDING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA APPRENTICESHIP
INITIATIVE. LOOKING AT THE MOST
RECENT ROUND OF GRANT FUNDING
THAT WENT OUT GRANT AWARDS BY
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE DEMAND
AMONG ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS
FORTIES GRANT APPEARS TO BE
INSUFFICIENT TO FOLLOW THE FULL
FLIGHT EVEN THOUGH. CURRENT
LEVEL OF BROWN'S OF FUNDING. SO
THE CHANCES OFFICE IS PUTTING
OUT THESE REQUESTS FOR
PROPOSALS TO THE FIELD AND
AGAIN BASED ON THE RECENT ROUND
DIDN'T. GET ENOUGH INTEREST
AMONG ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS TO
AWARD ALL THOSE MONEY SO GIVEN
THAT WE'RE NOT SEEN
JUSTIFICATION FOR JUMPED
DOUBLING THE SIZE OF THE
PROGRAM. A SECOND- CONCERN OF
OURS IS THE LEGISLATURE STARTED
FUNDING THE CALIFORNIA
APPRENTICESHIP INITIATIVE IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN SIXTEEN. YET THE
LEGISLATURE STILL LACKS DATA ON
WHETHER APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
THAT WERE FUNDED WITH THESE
PRIOR YEAR MONIES ARE BEING
SUSTAINED. AFTER BIRTH AFTER
THE GRANT FUNDING ENDS UP WE DO
UNDERSTAND THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE IN THE FOUNDATION FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON A STUDY TO
LOOK INTO THAT. SO WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE REJECT THIS
PROPOSAL OF THE GOVERNOR'S AND
REPURPOSE FOR HIGHER PRIORITIES
SUCH AS I'D PUT TOWARD A
LARGER- APPORTIONMENT
AUGMENTATION OR PAY DOWN ORE
DEFERRALS. AS REGARDS TO THE
WORK BASED LEARNING- PROPOSAL
THAT DEPARTMENT FINANCE JUST
MENTIONED WE WOULD HELP THE
WORK BASED LEARNING IS ALREADY
A FOCUS OF THE STRONG WORK
FORCE PROGRAM WHICH THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDES TWO
HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR ANNUALLY- ALSO
WORKING LEARNING IS A COMPONENT
OF THE STATE FUNDED GUIDED
PATHWAYS INITIATIVE AS WELL AS
REGULAR APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
OF THE LEGISLATURE FUNCTIONS
WELL SO. WE'RE NOT. TELL US
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHY A NEW
SEPARATE INITIATIVE ON WORK
BASED LEARNING IS NEEDED WE
RECOMMEND- LEGISLATURE REJECT
THIS PROPOSAL REPURPOSE THE
FUNDS FOR HIGHER PRIORITIES
SUCH AS PAIN DOWN ADDITIONAL
DEFERRALS THANK YOU. OKAY THE
TRANSFERS ARE THIS. THE COMPANY
CAN KNOCK ME COLLEGE SYSTEM AS
YOU KNOW HAS PROVEN- TO BE ONE
OF THE STATE'S FIGHT AGAINST
COVER NINETEEN AS THE LARGEST
PROVIDER OF WORKFORCE TRAINING
MOST EXPANSIVE HIGHER AND
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA OUR
STUDENTS OUR SYSTEM PRESENTS
ONE OF THE STATE'S PRIMARY PATH
BACK TO PROSPERITY AND A CHANCE
FOR ECONOMIC MOBILITY FOR ALL.
THE GOVERNOR IS PUTTING AN
EMPHASIS ON WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND AS YOU KNOW
COMING COLLEGES STAND READY TO
PUT CALIFORNIANS BACK TO WORK
CAN ASK SUCH AN INVESTMENT IN
WORKFORCE WE BELIEVE IT'S
PRUDENT. NOTABLE APPROACH- AS
THEIR WORK BASED LEARNING AND
THOUGH THIS IS AN AREA THAT- IS
USED WE BELIEVE THAT GIVEN THE
ECONOMIC NEEDS AND OUR NEEDS TO
PUT INDIVIDUALS BACK TO WORK
THIS IS AN INNOVATIVE APPROACH
THAT CAN BE EXPANDED WORK BASED
LEARNING- AS YOU KNOW PROVIDES
EXPANDED OPPORTUNITIES BEYOND
THE CLASSROOM TO ACCELERATE
ADVANCEMENT ALONG CAREER
PATHWAYS. THE PURCHASE AGES
INDIVIDUALS AT EIGHT WORK TO
GAINES SKILLS IN CONJUNCTION
WITH RELATED CLASSROOM AND LAB
INSTRUCTION IN A PARTICULAR
INDUSTRY OR NOT AN OCCUPATION
AND OUR INDUSTRIES ARE CHANGING
THESE PROGRAMS CAN PUT
INDIVIDUALS READY TO WORK- I'LL
ADD THAT A STUDY BY THE SOCIAL
POLICY RESEARCH ASSOCIATES
ANALYZING THE IMPLEMENTATION-
AND SUCCESSES OF THE CALIFORNIA
APPRENTICESHIP INITIATIVE. IS
ANTICIPATED FOR MARCH OR APRIL
OF THIS YEAR. WITH THAT HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY
THANK YOU QUESTION ON THIS WORK
OF FOR. YES WOMEN REALLY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I DEFINITELY
APPRECIATE THE EMPHASIS ON
APPRENTICESHIPS AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IF WE ARE TRULY TO
BUILD OUR WAY OUT OF THIS
KOVILAKAM COVERED RECESSION WE
TRULY NEED THE WORK FORCE AND
THE ABILITY TO MEET THE DEMAND
FOR GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
ENERGY FOR TRANSPORTATION AND
OF COURSE OUR HOUSING NEEDS THE
VERY VERY DIRE NEED THAT WE
HAVE TO HAVE A SKILLED
WORKFORCE I BUT I DO SHARE THE
CONCERNS ABOUT. MAKING SURE
WERE APPROVED INVESTING IN WHAT
DOES WORK FOR EXAMPLE IN EVEN
IN MY DISTRICT IN SILICON
VALLEY WE HAVE ONLY ONE CTE
PROGRAM AT THE AT THE SECONDARY
SCHOOL WHILE. BACK AT THE HIGH
SCHOOL LEVEL. I MIX UP MY
TERMINOLOGIES WITH BRITISH
EDUCATION LATER. IN THE DAY IN
THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL AND THAT
IS AND THAT IS THE METRO ED AND
THEY ARE FUNDED IN A WEIRD
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND THEY LIKELY IF
THEY DON'T RECEIVE FUNDING THIS
YEAR WILL NEVER COME BACK. AND
THEY HAVE A STRONG TRACK PROVEN
TRACK RECORD OF GETTING. KIDS
WHO OTHERWISE MIGHT BE LOST IN
THEIR PATH DIFFICULT WHAT JOB
OF DOING THE NEED AND GIVE THEM
THE SKILLS THAT THEY NEED. I
DEFINITELY THINK THAT WE SHOULD
BE INVESTING IN. IN PROGRAMS
THAT WORK LIKE THAT- SO THAT'S
WHY IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO BE
FINDING A CITY WHERE IT WORKS
AND I DO THINK. LOOKING FORWARD
INTO THE FUTURE WE HAVE TO
EXPLORE ALTERNATIVES BECAUSE
I'D THINK OF MANY TIMES EVEN MY
DISTRICT WHERE I TALK TO PEOPLE
WHO. REGRET GOING TO OUR
WONDERFUL UC SYSTEM BECAUSE
THEY TOOK A WHOLE LIFETIME OF
DEBT. JUST TO GET A JOB THEY
ABSOLUTELY MISERABLE AND THEY
DON'T LIKE. AND THEY FIND THAT
PERHAPS WORKING WITH THEIR
HANDS WORKING THIS DIFFERENT
SKILL IS WHAT DAY. IS WITH A
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT SOMETHING
THAT WE AS EMBERS HERE ABOUT
TO WIN THE FOR WHEN PEOPLE
NAVIGATE ESPECIALLY YOUNG
PEOPLE NAVIGATE WHAT. JOB
OPPORTUNITIES I WANT TO DO. SO
I JUST WANT TO REITERATE THAT
HOW IMPORTANT IS OBVIOUSLY TO
INVEST INVESTING IN A WORK
FORCE OF FUTURE AND DEVELOPMENT
FOR IT. BUT ALSO BE WORKING ON
ISSUES OR WORKING PROGRAMS
THAT. ARE SMART INVESTMENTS FOR
THE ONE TIME MONIES THAT WE
HAVE. THANK YOU. SOME REVISED
THAT IS. CANYON MINISTRATION
SPEAK TO WHETHER OR NOT THE TWO
HUNDRED ANDFIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR PLACE FULL A HOLDER FOR
WORK FORCE PROPOSALS AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS EXPECTED
TO INCLUDE FUNDING FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND ARE THE
DETAILS OF THE WORK FORCE
PROPOSAL EXPECTED TO BE
PROVIDED TO THE LEGISLATURE
BEFORE THAT MAYBE VICE. I DON'T
BACK DOWN FROM THE FINANCE AND
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE ANY
SPECIFIC IN TERMS OF AN
UNFORTUNATE IN TERMS OF TO THE
TIMELINE FOR RELEASING MORE
DETAILS REGARDING THAT
PROPOSAL- BUT YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOUR
STAFF ONE TWENTY THERE ARE
DETAILS OF THE PUBLISHER. SO
THE CIVIL RIGHT NOW WE DON'T
KNOW IF THERE'S AN EXPECTATION
THAT DETAILS WILL BE. PROVIDED
BEFORE THE MAY MAY REVISE THAT
IS THAT CORRECT. THAT THAT THAT
THAT'S CORRECT AND HAVE BEEN
ADDED TO THE TO THE
EXPECTATION. OF ONE BUT THEY'LL
BE AVAILABLE INFORMATION. THANK
YOU I'M ALTHOUGH THOUGH THERE
IS AN IT APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMME SECTOR. THE MOVE
MATERIALS PROVIDED BY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES DON'T APPEAR TO
REFLECT AND I. T. PRE.
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM- GIVEN
THE GOAL OF INCREASING FEMALES
AND OTHER UNDER REPRESENTED
POPULATIONS AND APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS- AS WELL SUPPORTING.
APPRENTICESHIP IN HIGH GROWTH
INDUSTRY SECTORS IT SEEMS THAT
AND I. T. PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM- SECTOR WOULD MAKE
SENSE CAN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CONTRACTORS OFFICE.
AND CONFIRM WHETHER THERE IS A
I. T. PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM SECTOR AND IF SO HOW RE
REACHING OUT TO SOME OF OUR-
GLOBAL POPULATIONS. ARE WOMEN
AND UNDER REPRESENTED
POPULATIONS. THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
MORE DETAILS- IN WRITING TO YOU
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
SAID THAT- I CAN CONFIRM WHERE
WE HAVE SUCH PROGRAMS. AND OUR
EFFORTS TO ENGAGE OPPOSE
TRADITIONAL- POPULATIONS THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN BARKED IN THESE
INDUSTRIES- ESPECIALLY AS YOU
MENTIONED ARE WOMEN AND WOMEN
OF COLOR SO. WE DID IT AGAIN
PROVIDE SOMETHING IN WRITING-
SHORTLY AFTER THIS HEARING.
THANK YOU. OKAY FURTHER QUEST
OF THIS ITEM SEEING NONE. WE
WILL HOLD THIS THIS ISSUE- OPEN.
OKAY ISSUE NUMBER FOUR THIS IS
KIND OF A HODGEPODGE OF OTHER
PROPOSALS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
TWENTY ONE TWENTY BUDGET AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WILL
PRESENTS. THANK YOU THE YEAH
BEFORE THE FOURTH AT A MALL GO
OVER SOME OF THE OTHER PROPOSED
SO THINK THAT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THAT I'VE NOT ALREADY PASSED-
THESE ADDITIONAL BUTTON SHOULD
HELP COLLEGES TO BETTER MEET
THE NEEDS OF THEIR STUDENTS.
EVEN AFTER THEIR MARCH THE
PANDEMIC. FIRST ALTHOUGH THE
ADMINISTRATION EXPECTS AN
EVENTUAL RETURN TO PRIMARILY IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION I COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. DEPEND IF IT HAS BEEN
A CLEAR THAT ONLINE EDUCATION
IS POSSIBLE. ADMINISTRATION
AUDITED ONLINE EDUCATION AS AN
EFFECTIVE METHOD OF INCREASING
ACCESS TO THE COLLEGES.
PARTICULARLY WITH RESPECT TO
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS. THE
POINT SIX BILLION SUPPORT THE
CONTINUITY OF EDUCATION AND
QUALITY DISTANCE LEARNING
INCLUDING ACCESS TO ONLINE
TUTORING ONLINE COUNSELING AND
ALL NIGHT DIDN'T SUPPORT
SERVICES SUCH AS MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. THE THERE IS A
VEHICLE IDENTIFIED BY THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AS THEY
LEARN THE CURRENT ENVIRONMENT.
THE INVESTMENT IS PROVIDED ON
AN ONGOING BASIS NOW BECAUSE
THE NEEDS OF CURRENT AND FUTURE
ONLINE STUDENTS. THE GOVERNMENT
BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES TWO
PROPOSALS DESIGNED TO INCREASE
THE AFFORDABILITY OF
INSTRUCTION MATERIALS. THAT
HELP REDUCE THE COST OF
ATTENDANCE FOR STATE. THE
PROPOSALS ARE FIFTEEN MILLION
AND ONE TIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING WHICH IS PROPOSED
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF YOUR
ATTACKS ACOSTA GREASE. WHICH IS
NOT PROVIDED- FUNDING IN THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN BUDGET ACT-
INTENT BUT TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION IN ONETIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING. IS
PROPOSED FOR INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS FOR TWO ONE MOMENT
STOOD. ADDITIONALLY THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES TWO
TWENTY MILLION ONE TIME FOR
CULTURALLY COMPETENT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
FACULTY THAT LEVERAGES MODERN
TECHNOLOGY. EIGHT MILLION TWO-
EIGHT MILLION ONGOING TO
ADDRESS ADMINISTRATIVE COST
INCREASES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR EDUCATION
NETWORK INITIATIVES IN
CALIFORNIA- BETTER IN THE
SCENIC. AND SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND ONE TIME TO IMPLEMENT
THE PROVISIONS EIGHTY FOURTEEN
SIXTY. THAT'S THAT THE WHITE
ANTI RACISM INITIATIVE. FIVE
THIS BUDGET PROVIDE THE COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT AT SEVERAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS INCLUDING THE MANDATE
BLOCK GRANTS THE TABLE STUDENTS
PROGRAM PROGRAMS AND SERVICES.
OUR STUDENTS SERVICES EXTENDED
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES CAMPUS CHILD CARE TAX
BAILOUT AND APPRENTICESHIP.
WE'VE GOT THE LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS TOTAL ROUGHLY SIX
POINT ONE BILLION AND ONGOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING AND- WITHOUT A THAT WE
HAVE AN ANSWER QUESTIONS YOU
HAVE ABOUT THE. THANK YOU
CABALLERO. WHERE IS YOUR FOR
INCLUDES SEVEN PROPOSALS FOR
THE SECOND TIME WELL THIS TYPE
ON THE FIRST TWO THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
INTRODUCED THE TEN POINT SIX
MILLION ONGOING FOR ONLINE
TOOLS AND FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME FOR ZERO
TEXTBOOK COST DEGREE GRANTS.
WITH REGARDING WITH REGARD TO
PROVIDING AN ONGOING
AUGMENTATION FROM ONLINE TOOLS
WE WOULD NOTE THAT INCREASE
COSTA COLLEGES ARE THE RESULT
OF THE COLLEGES MOVING THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THEIR INSTRUCTION
ONLINE SINCE THE PANDEMIC SO
IT'S UNCLEAR HOW LONG. ONLINE
USAGE RATES WILL REMAIN AT
THESE ELEVATED LEVELS AT THE
SAME TIME COLLEGES HAVE
SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL RELIEF
FUNDS THEY CAN USE TO COVER
THESE EXTRA BURDEN. OF SLATED
TO MORE ONLINE USAGE MORE USE
OF THE ONLINE TOOLS AND AS I
MENTIONED IN ISSUES SHOULD
APPROVAL IT'S POSSIBLE THE
COLLEGES WILL HAVE EVEN MORE
FEDERAL RELIEF. FUNDS IF THE
GOVERNMENT APPROVES A THIRD
ROUND. OF FEDERAL MONEY SO
GIVEN THAT OUT YOUR COSTS FOR
ALL. ALL RIGHT TIME BETTER WILL
BE FINE REMAIN AVAILABLE FOR
COLLEGES TO COVER EXTRAORDINARY
COSTS RELATED TO MOVING SO MUCH
OF THEIR- SERVICES ONLINE. IT
WOULD BE PREMATURE TO PROVIDE
AN ONGOING AUGMENTATION SO WE
WOULD RECKON RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THIS
PROPOSAL AND CONSIDER RE
PURPOSING THE MONEY FOR OTHER
PRIORITIES SUCH AS AUGMENTED
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT OR
PAYING DOWN MORE DEFERRALS. THE
LEGISLATURE COULD REVISIT THE
FUNDING LEVEL FOR ONLINE TOOLS
NEXT YEAR. WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
HAS A BETTER SENSE OF WHAT
USAGE LEVELS ARE AT THE
COLLEGES AND WHAT THOSE COSTS
WILL BE GOING FORWARD. WITH
REGARD TO ZERO TEXTBOOK COST OF
THAT PROPOSAL. WE WOULD NOTE
THAT COURSE TEXTBOOK COSTS CAN
BE SIGNIFICANT SO CREATING ZERO
TEXTBOOK COST DEGREES CAN HAVE
REAL BENEFITS FOR STUDENTS. WE
WOULD NOTE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
STILL AWAITING AREPORT FROM
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ON THE
RESULTS IN THE IMPACT OF THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN STATE
FUNDED ZERO TEXT TEXT BOOK
COSTED SHOULD'VE. THAT WAS
SOMETHING LEGISLATURE FUNDED
AND SO INFORMATION FROM THAT
REPORT COULD INFORM THE
LEGISLATURE IN ITS DECISION ON
WHETHER OR NOT TO FIND A NEW
ROUND. OF GRANTS FORTY ZERO
TEXTBOOK COST AND THAT REPORT
ALSO COULD BE USEFUL IN HELPING
THE LEGISLATURE PERHAPS CRAFT A
NEW ROUND OF PROPOSALS THAT THE
NEW ROUND OF GRANTS THAT. KIND
OF LEARNS FROM- THE LESSONS OF
THE FIRST ROUND SO WE WOULD
WITHHOLD RECOMMENDED WE
RECOMMEND- THE LEGISLATURE HOLD
OFF FOR NOW- TAKING ACTION WE
RECOMMEND WITHHOLDING ALRIGHT
ADDITION PENDING RECEIPT OF THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE REPORT IT'S
A CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE INDICATES.
IS COMING SOON THANK YOU. OKAY
QUESTIONS PRESS. DUMPS MEETS
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES SEVERAL OTHER
INVESTMENTS THAT SUPPORTER
COMPREHENSIVE MISSION SO I'LL
PROVIDE OUR PERSPECTIVE ON
SEVERAL OF THOSE FIRST HELP
PRETTY CAN BE CALLED IS THAT AS
YOU KNOW ATTEND CAMPUSES ACROSS
A VERY DIVERSE SYSTEM IN 73% OF
OUR STUDENTS OUR STUDENTS OF
COLOR IMMIGRANTS ARE BOTH
SUPPORTING EFFORTS TO INCREASE
DIVERSITY AND CULTURAL
COMPETENCY ARE VITAL TO
ENSURING THAT STUDENTS CAN
IDENTIFY WITH FACULTY AND
STAFF. AND HELP THEM SUCCEED IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS REQUESTED THAT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE OFFICE
ESTABLISH A FACULTY AND STAFF
DIVERSITY EQUITY AND INCLUSION
TASK FORCE THE TASK FORCE
PRESENTED INSTEAD OF A STATE
WIDE RECOMMENDATIONS ON
STRUCTURAL CHANGES INCLUDING
POLICIES AND PRACTICES AND
TOOLS THAT WILL SUPPORT
DIVERSITY INITIATIVES THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL OF TWENTY
MILLION ONE TIME FOR FACULTY
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
RELATED TO ONLINE EDUCATION AND
CULTURAL CONTENT PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT ALIGNS WITH THESE
GOALS AND RECOGNIZES
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE THESE
PRACTICES IN THE CURRENT
LEARNING MODALITIES FOR
OFFERING IT'S AN IMPORTANT
FIRST STEP IN INVESTMENT IN
ADVANCING OUR DIVERSITY. EQUITY
AND INCLUSION EFFORTS. THE
GOVERNOR ALSO PROPOSE IN IN IN
ONLINE RESOURCES IN SPRING OF
TWENTY TWENTY IN ORDER TO
ENABLE THE SWIFT TRANSITION TO
DISTANCE AT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE HAD TO PURCHASE AN
INCREASE USAGE OF SEVERAL
LEARNING PLATFORMS ON BEHALF OF
COLLEGES. THIS FAST ACTING
APPROACH MADE IT POSSIBLE TO
TRANSITION EIGHT TWO POINT ONE
MILLION SYSTEM. AND A HUNDRED
AND SIXTEEN COLLEGES COMPLETELY
ONLINE IN A MATTER OF WEEKS
THE- THESE WERE UNEXPECTED
COSTS THAT CANNOT EASILY BE
ABSORBED INTO EXISTING COLLEGE.
COLLEGE BUDGETS ALREADY
STRAINED. AS PLANS FOR FALL
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ARE DEVELOPED
WE ANTICIPATE THAT A 100% FACE
TO FACE INSTRUCTION IS LIKELY
IS UNLIKELY DUE TO UNCERTAINTY
AROUND INOCULATION RATES AND TO
ENSURE THAT OUR STUDENTS
FACULTY OR STATE. COLLEGES
INSTEAD OF LOOKING AT HYBRID
OPTIONS TO USE A BLEND OF
TECHNOLOGY AND IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. SENT TO SUSTAIN
SUCH INSTRUCTIONS COLLEGE WILL
NEED A ROBUST ONLINE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PLATFORMS
INCLUDING TUTORING TOOLS TECH
SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHT EXTRA
STABILITY RESOURCES. THESE
INVESTMENTS WILL SUPPORT
DISTANCE EDUCATION ACCESS TO
STUDENTS WILL ALSO FOUND WITH
MODALITY ENDING TO THEIR BUSY
SCHEDULES WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED TEN
POINT SIX MILLION INVESTMENT IN
ONLINE ECOSYSTEM. I BELIEVE
THIS WILL HELP US SERVE EVERY
PART OF THE STATE. ALSO ALSO
RESPONDS TO A BUDGET REQUEST
THAT WAS CRAFTED IN
CONSULTATION WITH MANY OF OUR
SYSTEM STATE QUARTERS. ALL ADD
THAT BY PURCHASING THESE
PLATFORMS AS A SYSTEM COMMUNITY
COLLEGES LEVER LEVERAGE
ECONOMIES OF SCALE AND OBTAIN
SERVICES AT A SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE COSTS AND FURTHER
STATEWIDE APPROACH. PREVENTS
INCONSISTENCY ACROSS OUR
DISTRICTS AND AN EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY THAT
FURTHERS THE DIGITAL DIVIDE SO
AGAIN WE ASK YOU TO CONSIDER
SUPPORTING THIS OP PROPOSAL. TO
THE ISSUE OF ZERO TEXTBOOK COST
AGREED. AS HE NOTICED ACOSTA
HAS ARE FOR MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS HAVE BECOME AN
AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGES. OUR
PRELIMINARY ANALYSIS OF ZERO
TEXTBOOK COST WAYS EACH WILL BE
RELEASED IN MARCH INDICATES
THAT STUDENTS SAVED AN AVERAGE
OF SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
TRANSITIONING FROM OUR
DEPENDENCY ON TEXTBOOKS TO MORE
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES SUCH AS
OPEN EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES.
NOTICE HOW WE ARE CONSERVE PORT
THE AFFORDED OF. THAT IS A
INTEREST TO THIS. ALSO OUT. IN
THIS BUDGET. WITH THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE ACADEMIC
SENATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND WORKING
TO ENSURE THAT WE DEVELOP AND
BUILD. BUILDING ON OUR PRIOR
ONLY OUR INVESTMENTS WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS CAN BE A PRUDENT
AFFORDABILITY EFFORT. AND
FINALLY I WANT TO THANK- THE
ASSEMBLY IN PARTICULAR SOME
REMEMBER MCCARTY FIRST
PARTNERSHIP AS WE ELEVATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR JUSTICE
INVOLVED IN. INDIVIDUALS I
GATHER THE GENIUS THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES OF IS THAT WE PROVIDE
SECOND CHANCES ARE EFFORTS
THROUGH THE RISING SCHOLARS
PROGRAM WILL LINE TO OUR
STUDENTS IN ACHIEVEMENT AGENDA
AND ALLOW US TO SERVE THIS
IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA
POPULATION. THANK YOU AND HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY
THANK YOU QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WHENEVER REST MORE OF A COMMENT
I AM CONCERNED ABOUT IS SOME OF
THE FUNDING HAS BEEN PROVIDED
FOR SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS WHEN
WE HAVE GREAT NEEDS AND GREAT
PROGRAMS ALREADY I LIKE THE
MOTOR AND MASSA AND POINTED-
THESE ARE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ALREADY BEING USED AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT ARE
VERY SUCCESSFUL ESPECIALLY IN
HELPING OUR STUDENTS WITH THE
GREATEST NEED AND I THINK THAT
INVESTING MORE IN THOSE
PROGRAMS IS A MORE SOUND
INVESTMENT THAN. SOME OF WHAT
IS BEING OFFERED HERE SO MORE
OF A COMMENT THAN A QUESTION
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN YES. YES
COMMENTED WILL RECEIVE DIE I
WOULD NOTE TO I APPRECIATE THE
CHANCE WAS OFFICE TALKING
ABOUT. THE RISING SCHOLARS-
EFFORTS AT COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND LAST
YEAR AS WE REMEMBER WE HELP
FIND AT CSU PROJECT REBOUND
WHICH IS QUITE SUCCESSFUL
HELPING FORMERLY INCARCERATED
SO AS CALIFORNIA. TAKES A LOOK
AT OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEMS
AND WE'VE LOWERED SIGNIFICANTLY
ARE INCARCERATION COUNTS IT'S
UPON US TO HELP THE STUDENTS
SUCCEED WHEN THEY GO OUT INTO
SOCIETY. YOU THINK- THE THAT
THE EASIEST PLACE TO GO ON
HIGHER EDUCATION WOULD BE THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES MORE THAN UC
AND- CSU NOTHING WRONG WITH UC
AND CSU BUT JUST BARRIERS OF
ENTRY SO. IT'S KIND OF IRONIC
THAT THIS THAT WE'VE STEPPED UP
AND FUNDED PROGRAMS AT THE CSU.
AND UC BUT NOT AT OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SO THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE GOING TO PUT IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET IN THE ASSEMBLY
SIDE. SUPPORT FOR- IT
DISMISSIVE BECAUSE THEY KNOW
CABS ARE YOU DO IT WITH THESE
RISING SCHOLARS- PROGRAMS. AND
I WILL NOTE THAT THERE IS MERIT
TO- ZERO THAT TEXTBOOK COST
PROGRAMS AND AS A STAFF REPORT
NOTES WOULD CERTAINLY TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT IN THIS REPORT
COMING OUT- I DON'T I DON'T
HAVE ANY OTHER FOR FURTHER.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ON THESE
ITEMS I DON'T SEE ANY WHICH I
HAD TO MOVE THE AGENDA ALONG-
ISSUE NUMBER THE WHOLE THIS
ISSUE UP IN ISSUE NUMBER FIVE.
INSTITUTIONAL AID CAL GRANT
REFORM THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE TALK A LOT ABOUT THAT ARE
STILL EIGHT COMMISSION HEARING
COUPLE WEEKS AGO. AND THE
COMMUNICATIVE CERTAINLY HAVE A
BIG PIECE OF THIS AND SO. WE
HAVE THIS AGENDA AS TODAY AS
WELL. MORNING CHAIRED MEMBERS
I'M DAVID O'BRIEN VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR GOVERNOR
RELATIONS WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THE DIRE
NEED FOR FINANCIAL AID
PERFORMED BETTER SIR
CALIFORNIA. ALL STUDENTS IN
CRISIS THE BASIC NEEDS AND
SECURITY THAT YOU'RE PARTS SO
MUCH ABOUT- ALREADY AND IT IS
OUR ONLY GROWN WITH THE COMPANY
NINETEEN AND EVERITT AND
RECESSION. STOPPAGE PROVIDES AN
EXCELLENT OVERVIEW WITH MAJOR
STATE EIGHT PROGRAMS THAT
CURRENTLY SERVE OUR STUDENTS
SO- I WON'T GO THROUGH THOSE IN
DETAIL FOR YOU WILL NOTICE YOU
SKIN THAT AGENDA THE MAJORITY
OF OUR INSTITUTIONAL FINANCIAL
AID PROGRAMS. ADDRESS IN ROMAN
FEET OF THE RIGHT NUMBERS
TUITION OR TALK ABOUT TUITION
AT THE MOMENT. NEW CALL SYSTEM
IN FACT ABOUT HALF OF OUR
STUDENTS. BROCKLEY BY YEAR
DON'T PAY TUITION TO ATTEND A
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE THANKS IN
LARGE PART TO THE LEADERSHIP
AND COMMITMENT OF LEADERS SUCH
AS YOURSELF. WE SERVE OUR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA CALLED PROMISE GRANT%
THE WAIVER FORMALLY KNOWN AS
THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS ARE
BOUGHT THE WAY FOR. MANY OF OUR
COLLEGES AND DISTRICTS ALSO
UTILIZE FUNDING FROM CALIFORNIA
ALL ON THIS PROGRAM. CREATED IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN- AND CHAMPIONED
BY THE STATE ASSEMBLY TO WAIVE
FEES FOR ALL FIRST TIME FULL
TIME STUDENTS. HOWEVER AS THE
COMING RECENTLY APPARENT IN
RECENT YEARS THE LARGEST COST
OUR STUDENTS FACE TO ATTEND
COLLEGE PARTICULARLY IN HIGH
COST STATES LIKE CALIFORNIA IS
NOT TUITION BUT OTHER MORTGAGE
WORK. SUCH AS TEXTBOOKS
TRANSPORTATION MEDICAL COSTS.
AND HOUSING NONE OF THESE ARE
OPTIONAL STUDENTS DO NOT HAVE
THE CHOICE OF DEFERRING THEIR
RENTS NOT MAKING CAR PAYMENTS
OR CHOOSING NOT TO FEED THEIR
FAMILY JUST BECAUSE ARTS AND
INVOLVES. ACTUALLY I SHOULDN'T
I'M NOT SOMEONE UNFORTUNATELY
MANY PERSONS DO MAKE SOME OF
THOSE TOUGH CHOICES AROUND FOOD
AND HOUSING. AND. THAT'S WHY
WE'RE HERE TODAY. HE WHY CHAO.
MORE THAN JUNIOR JEWS CALLS.
MEET AN OLD. THAT THING AIDES
NUMBER THAN EVER. IS THAT OUR
CURRENT PROGRAMS NOT SURFACED
COVER. NON JEWISH AND- WHICH
HOLBROOKE OF THE- AS THE HEAD
OUT THE PREPARED A PROVIDE YOU
BROWN'S. YOU CHOW GRANT AWARD.
WHICH PROVIDES LOW STILL TO THE
SMALL STATE BEGINS THE OPS IS
NOT WITH US. HAS LOST SEVEN
FIVE PER OF ITS VALUE. YEARS
CURRENTLY PROVIDES JUST OVER
EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
SEMESTER LOCAL TIME STUDENT OR
ABOUT SIXTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER YEAR THAT'S SIMPLY NOT
ENOUGH. FOR STUDENTS TO REDUCE
THEIR WORK HOURS OR AVOID GOING
TO PREVENT THAT SO THEY CAN
FOCUS ON STUDIES. THE OTHER
INEQUITIES BUILT INTO THE
CURRENT HEALTHCARE PROGRAM IS
THE QUESTION AROUND WAS
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE STATE
STUDENT AID TO BEGIN WITH. THE
CURRENT PROGRAM IS AVAILABLE AS
AN ENTITLEMENT TO STUDENTS WHO
ATTEND COLLEGE IMMEDIATELY
AFTER HIGH SCHOOL WHICH
DISPROPORTIONATELY BENEFITS
STUDENTS ATTEND FOR YOUR-
CITIES. AND IS MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT TO RECEIVE HER
STUDENTS TO START THEIR COLLEGE
EDUCATION LATER IN LIFE.
STUDENTS WILL BEGIN COLLEGE
MORE THAN ONE YEAR AFTER THEY
GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL. OR WHO
TRANSFER FROM A COMMUNITY
CULTURE FOR UNIVERSITY AFTER
THEY TURNED EACH TWENTY EIGHT.
ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
ENTITLEMENT CAL GRANT BUT
INSTEAD WIND UP IN THIS LOTTERY
LIKE SYSTEM WHERE THERE ARE
JUST FORTY ONE THOUSAND
AVAILABLE COMPETITIVE HELP AND
WORDS. SERVING OVER THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ELIGIBLE
STUDENT FINANCIAL NEED. THESE
ARE OVERWHELMINGLY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS WOULD RUN MANY
WORKING PARENTS AND ADULT
LEARNERS. SO WE DO PPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
FEEDBACK ON THE PROGRAM
MODERNIZATION. THE PROPOSAL
THAT CALIFORNIA'S DIGNITY
COMMISSION IS PROPOSING. AND
THE LEGISLATION THAT- ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MCCARTY MEDINA ARE
CARRYING AND WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE. OUT A COMPREHENSIVE
ANALYSIS THE IMPACT FORCES MARC
STUDENTS WILL REQUIRE. MORE
TIME TO VALUATE THE OVERFLOW.
BUT I AM TO PROVIDE A FEW I
LOVE REACT. YOU LIMIT. THE
LIMIT O THE ARBOR RASH THAT.
THAT COULD NOT L. G. TO SOME
PARTS IS PROMISED. TELL GRANT
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE SHOULD NOT
BE A- AS A EXT TO STUDENTS OF
RECENTLY RIGHT HIGH SCHOOL OR
BELOW AGE. WE ALL KNOW THAT- A
STUDENTS WHO START THE HIGHER A
LITTLE LATER IN LIFE- WE USED
TO USE THIS TERM NONTRADITIONAL
STUDENTS TO DESCRIBE ARE
INCREASINGLY BECOMING THE NORM
HIGHER EDUCATION. SO ALL
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WITH
FINANCIAL NEED TO BE ABLE TO
PURSUE HIGHER EDUCATION AND
FINANCIAL AID TO SUPPORT THAT
SO WE STRONG SUPPORT THIS
PROVISION OF THE PROPOSAL.
WOULD YOU RECOGNIZE THE DIRE
FINANCIAL CIRCUMSTANCES THE
STATE IS PROBABLY FACING A
REALISTIC ABOUT YOU FUNDING
INVESTMENTS WE CANNOT STRESS
ENOUGH THAT OUR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS NEED MORE STUDENT AID
TO ATTENDANCE EXCEEDING OUR-
AWARD THAT LOST THREE QUARTERS
OF ITS VALUE AS I MENTIONED A
MOMENT AGO- IT CURRENTLY
PROVIDES ON AVERAGE IF YOU.
COPIED BY MONTHS OF ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY DOLLARS PER MONTH
SHOULD BE INCREASED NOT REDUCED
SO WE'RE OF COURSE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOU WITH THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION AND OUR
STUDENTS. ON LOOKING A
POTENTIAL SOURCE OF NEW REVENUE
IS NEEDED INVESTMENTS WE WOULD
NOT THE DISCUSSIONS AROUND US
SOURCES OF SPECIFIC FUNDING OR
SPECIAL FUNDS. NEED TO BE
APPROACH VERY CAREFULLY. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PLAY A LEADING
ROLE N THESE DISCUSS SOONER
RATHER THAN. SO THAT WE CAN
IDENTIFY THE BEST WAYS TO
SUPPORTING. MARCHED BUT I JUST
WANT TO CLOSE BY WE WANT AGAIN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS
THE CRISIS OF COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY BASIC NEEDS.
FACING OUR TWO MILLION
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS THAT WE CAN
WORK ON TOGETHER AND OF COURSE
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. OKAY
STERN MEDINA I COULDN'T AGREE
MORE WITH EVERYTHING THAT
YOU'VE SAID- IN MY THIRTEEN
YEARS AS A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TRUSTEE I SAW THAT THE BIGGEST
REASON WHY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS DIDN'T FINISH- FINISH
AT ALL OR FINISH SOONER WAS
BECAUSE LIFE GOT IN THE WAY.
ANOTHER WAY TO SAY THAT IS THAT
THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
HAVE THE NEED TO WORK. WHICH IS
NOT. REAL CONDUCIVE TO
FINISHING COLLEGE- AND SO I
THINK THAT THE CAL GRANT REFORM
THAT WE'RE DOING- IS WAY
OVERDUE. HAPPY TO BE DOING THAT
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
AND- WAS HAPPY TO INTRODUCE
FINANCIAL AID AWARENESS MONTH
ON THE FLOOR. THE LAST COUPLE
OF DAYS YES AND ALSO CENTER
LEYVA AS OUR OUR JOINT AUTHORS
AND AS WELL ON THAT SO. BOTH
HOUSES ARE ENGAGED WITH THIS
YEAH I JUST WANT TO NOTE ON
THIS- AS AS YOU SAID WE KNOW
THAT WE NEED MORE FINANCIAL AID
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES IT'S
INTERESTING YOU LOOK AT
STUDENTS. AT UC BERKELEY AND UC
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN
BERKELEY AND THE FINANCIAL AID
THE BERKELEY STUDENTS GET IS
WAY MORE THAN THAT THEN THE LOW
INCOME COMMUNICANTS DURING THE
LOOK AT HOW THE CAL GRANT THE
PELL GRANT. INSTITUTIONAL IS
LAYERED ON THE ODDS OF SUCCESS
ARE SO MUCH GREATER THAT FOR
THE UC STUDENT MESSIEST AND THE
COMMUNICATION WE KNOW MANY
TIMES NEEDS. MORE SUPPORT AND
THAT SO MANY OF THEM HAE OTHER
OBLIGATIONS AND FAMILY AND SO
FORTH AND SO- WE'RE WE'RE
COMMITTEE BECAUSE STUDENTS ARE
DOING VERY WELL I MEAN MISTER
O'DONNELL IS THE PRODUCT OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES I AM OUR
SPEAKER IS AND SO MANY OTHER
MEMBERS ARE I'M NOT SURE WHO.
WHO ALSO APPEARED- SO WE KNOW
THAT THEY DO- HELP STUDENTS
NAVIGATE BUT ESPECIALLY WITH
THIS KNOWLEDGE BASED ECONOMY WE
NEED TO DO. MUCH MORE WE KNOW
THAT THE QUESTION IS HOW DO WE
HOW DO WE FIND IT- LEGALIZING
SPORTS GAMING IN CALIFORNIA HAS
AN IDEA OF A ON GOING
PERMANENT. REVENUE SOURCE OF
THATEVER GOES TO THE BALLOT IN
I'M NOT SURE THE VIABILITY OF
THAT I'M CERTAINLY WE'RE ALWAYS
LOOKING GENERAL FUND BUT I KNOW
THERE IS ONE ISSUE THAT WOULD
THAT THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION- DAVID. AND I AND I
DON'T WANT TO GET YOU IN
TROUBLE BECAUSE YOU USED TO
WORK FOR THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION NOW YOU'RE IN THE
COMMUNICABLE JUST OF THE
COMMUNICABLE JUST PAY YOUR-
BILLS RIGHT NOW BUT THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION. CAME UP WITH AN
IDEA THAT WE COULD- RE ALLOCATE
SOME RESOURCES WITH DAN- OF THE
PROGRAM THAT WE CREATED A
COUPLE YEARS AGO WHICH HAS NICK
SUCCESS NOT TO SAY IT'S NOT AN
IMPORTANT. PROGRAM- MARC.
COMPLETION GRANTS YEAH WITH
THE- THE COMPLETION GRANT
PROGRAM WHICH WE HAD DUELING
PROPOSALS- I THINK IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WITH THE FORMER PART TIME DALY
ON ONCE WE MERGE THAT- AND
THERE IS AN IDEA TO USE SOME OF
THAT TO START SOME OF THIS
EFFORT TO FIND. THE CAL GRANT
TO AND WANTED THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO RESPOND- ON THAT
IDEA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR THAT IS- YOUR
CORRECT THAT- BERMAN TO WORK
FOR THE COMMUNITY THOUSAND
CHANCES LOVES NOW NOT THE-
STUDENT AID COMMISSION. AS IT
RELATES TO- REDIRECTING FUNDS
FOR MANY OF OUR EXISTING
PROGRAMS WERE OF COURSE HAPPY
TO ENGAGE IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS
AND DO. ANY ANALYSIS NECESSARY
ON WHAT IT WOULD TAKE WE'RE
HERE FOR OUR STUDENTS. WE ARE
HERE TO GET OUR STUDENTS THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED TO- NOT JUST
THE TEN BUT TO THRIVE. IN THE
CALIFORNIA. SYSTEM AND BEYOND
OUT WHATEVER COMES NEXT WHETHER
IT'S AN WORKFORCE OR
TRANSFERRING SOMEWHERE OF
COURSE HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN THOSE
DISCUSSIONS- I BELIEVE THAT YOU
KNOW INTERNALLY WILL WANT TO DO
SOME ANALYSIS ON THAT. AND THEN
OF COURSE WE'LL ONE OF THE-
CAREFUL ABOUT YOU KNOW MAKING
SURE WE DISCUSSED THAT PROPERLY
INTO. THROUGH OUR STAKEHOLDERS
BECAUSE THAT IS A PROGRAM IS
FUNDED BY FOX NINETY EIGHT.
WHICH IS OF COURSE VERY
COMPLEX. BUT CREATE THE
QUESTION MORE THAN HAPPY TO
LOOK AT IT- THE BALLOT OR OR
OTHER SOURCES- AND ULTIMATELY
WHAT HOPE. THAT WE CAN- AS YOU
ALLUDED TO THAT WE CAN DISCUSS.
NEW INVESTMENTS. BEYOND JUST
THE SORT OF THE- RESOURCES ARE
IN CAN OFFICE STOCK NOT
NECESSARILY SAID WE WANT TO
LOOK AT UP PROGRAMS THAT.
STUDENTS AND IN OTHERS. BECAUSE
WE WANT YOU KNOW YOU SEE AND
USED JUST. OF COURSE AS WELL SO-
REALLY- WE WERE AT- THE-
OVERALL OF FUN. IN STATE AID
HIM BECAUSE- IT IS WILDLY AND I
BELIEVE ALLOW SORT BACK NOTHING
THE- ALL WAS THAT. THERE ARE
RISKS. DOLLARS CAL GRANT GOING
TO ALL OTHER SEGMENTS COMBINED
FOR EVERY ONE DOLLAR THAT GOES
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
SO WHAT WE WANT TO LOOK AT AT
RECTIFYING THAT AND THAT WOULD
BE LONG TERM BUT YES WE'RE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN
DISCUSSIONS ANALYSIS. OF THE
OTHER PROGRAMS AND OTHER
SOURCES OF FUNDING I'M
INCLUDING THE STUDENT SUCCESS
WE SHOULD WRAP PROVIDED- IT YOU
KNOW IT IT NEEDS. PROGRAM GOALS
AND IS THAT A PROPERLY.
RESPECTFUL GOOD THAT'S A AT.
ANSWER BE OF WE'D LIKE TO WELL
ONE WE BY TO START THIS.
PROCESS AS THE LEAD TO.
OUTLINES ITS IT'S- IT'S ROBUST
AND IT'S VERY ASPIRATIONAL STAR
WE WANT TO GO WE SPENT AN HOUR
IF YOU. ARE MORE TALK ABOUT A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO BUT BUT THAT
STARTING IT WITH WHAT WE HAVE
WE THINK IS WOULD BE A WIN AS
WELL SO. TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
CAN DO THAT WITH. SYSTEM
RESOURCES AND MAYBE PUT A
LITTLE BIT- IT IN IN THE
GENERAL FUND IF WE CAN TWIST
APARTMENT FINANCES ARM ON THAT
SOMETHING THAT THAT- WE'D LIKE
TO DO. AS WELL- FURTHER
QUESTION SOMEONE MEMBER RACE
THANK YOU MR WELL I TO IN THE
PRODUCT OF A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
EDUCATION FROM STAMINA DINO
VALLEY COLLEGE SO I ABSOLUTELY
KNOW THE VALUE OF THIS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE EDUCATION ON
IN PEOPLE'S LIVES- I THINK THAT
IT'S BEEN. IT'S CLEAR FROM WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THAT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE
THE LARGEST POPULATION OF
STUDENTS YET RECEIVED THE
LOWERS CAL GRANT AWARD AMOUNTS
I AGREE THAT WE HAVE TO
MODERNIZE AND WE HAVE TO EXPAND
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS TO FIX
INEQUITIES AMONG COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND THEIR
PEERS AT THE YOU SEE THE CAL
STATE PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES. AND
I DO WANT TO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT A
COMMISSIONED WORKGROUP
WORKGROUP OF FOR STUDYING THIS
ISSUE AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH MY COLLEAGUES SO
THAT OUR STUDENTS GET THE
FINANCIAL HELP THEY NEED TO GO
TO COLLEGE FINISH COLLEGE AND
SUCCEED. SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OKAY NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
ON THIS COMMENTS THIS IS AN
ISSUE WE WILL BE WORKING ON AND
POTENTIALLY COME BACK- WITH THE
PROPOSAL LATER IN THE SPRING
ISSUE NUMBER SIX LAST ISSUE
BEFORE I GET TO PUBLIC COMMENTS
THIS IS CALIBRATED COLLEGE-
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT'S
INFORMATIONAL OVERSIGHT
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE- COMMITTEE
TO TAKE A LOOK AT TODAY- THIS
IS AS WE ARE AS WE WELL NOW
THIS IS BEEN AN INTERESTING
AND- HIGHLY DEBATED AND-
HONESTLY VERY CONTROVERSIAL-
PROPOSAL AND PROGRAM. THAT THAT
DID WAS IMPLEMENT THE LAST FEW
YEARS- REALLY AT THE URGING OF
THE PRIOR GOVERNOR PAT BROWN-
WE HAVE AN AUDIT COMING OUT IN
THE IN A FEW WEEKS. THERE'S
STILL A LOT OF UNDERLYING-
ISSUES AND QUESTIONS AND
CONCERNS AND- WE HAVE WITH US
TODAY. THE THAT CALIBRATE
COLLEGE WITH THE CHANCE TO
PRESENT TO US AN UPDATE ON OUR
CONTINUED STATE FUNDING
SUPPORT- LAST YEAR'S BUDGET DID
I REDUCE ONGOING SUPPORT BY
FIVE MILLION AND FORTY NINE
MILLION REDUCE FROM THERE ONE
TIME- HOLDOVER MONEY FROM THE
YEAR BEFORE WE DID ATTEMPT TO
ZERO THIS THIS PROGRAM OUT. I
STILL QUESTION WHETHER IT'S-
IT'S USEFUL FOR CALIFORNIANS
SWEET YOU HAVE ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED STUDENTS ENROLLED RIGHT
NOW- I KNOW THEY LOOK TO EXPAND
BUT- LOTS OF PROMISES LOTS OF
UNFULFILLED PROMISES- GALLAGHER
HIGH SPEED RAIL PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA. I'M NOT SURE- WHICH
ONE HAS MORE PROMISES IN WEST
DELIVERABLES TO DATE- THIS IS
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT THAT
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
MONITOR- YEAH I WILL NOTE TO
THAT AS WE'RE SEEING RIGHT HERE
WITH COVERED NINETEEN. THERE'S
MORE AND MORE ONLINE EDUCATION
ANYWAY SO IT BEGS THE QUESTION
DO WE HAVE THESE COMPETING
EFFORTS I KNOW THAT BY JUST
LOOKING TO EXPAND A LITTLE BIT
OF ONLINE PROGRAMS THROUGH OUR
THEIR HUNDRED THREE HUNDRED OR
SO. ON COMMUNICABLE DISEASES
THAT WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA AS A
WHOLE- BUT WITH THAT- ALL STOP
AND ALLOW THE THAT CALIBRATE
COLLEGE- PRESENTER. TO JOIN US
HERE THIS MORNING. HERE A GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JEANETTE HOW LOCKER MEN
AND- I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN YOU AT
TODAY. AND FOR THE CONTINUED
SUPPORT OF THE MISSION OF
CALVET COLLEGE TO INCREASE
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO OBTAIN DOGS.
THIS IS MY FIRST TIME BEFORE
THE SUBCOMMITTEE BUT AS SOME OF
YOU KNOW I AM A LIFELONG
ADVOCATE FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WITH MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE AT THE NATIONAL
LEVEL AND I BELIEVE DEEPLY IN
THIS MISSION. THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES APPOINTED ME AS THE
PERMANENT CEO OF CALVET COLLEGE
LAST JULY. AND I RECOGNIZE THE
CHALLENGES THAT WERE CREATED
UNDER THE PREVIOUS LEADERSHIP.
WE HEARD THE CONCERNS OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND WE HAVE
RESPONDED BY MAKING SEVERAL
NECESSARY CHANGES. MADE
SUBSTANTIVE IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
STUDENT EXPERIENCE WITH
STRENGTH THAT STRENGTHENED
CALPERS RELATIONSHIP THE SYSTEM
CONSTITUENTS. ARE TAKING
CONCRETE STEPS SUPPORT THE NEW
FACULTY OF CALIBRATE. I HAVE TO
SAY THIS IS AN EXCITING MOMENT
FOR HELP RIGHT WE ARE IN THE
MIDST OF FINALIZING OUR THREE
YEAR STRATEGIC VISION IN
COLLABORATION WITH OUR BOARD OF
TRUSTEES. AND WITH INPUT FROM
STATE STATEWIDE STAKEHOLDERS WE
ALSO WELCOME THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION ARTIFICIAL
FACULTY UNION. AND WE'RE
LAUNCHING NEW PATHWAYS TO
CONNECT OUR LEARNERS TO GROWING
INDUSTRIES. HOW FIRST BEGAN
SERVING STUDENTS. MONTHS AGO
JUST FIVE MONTHS BEFORE THE
GLOBAL PANDEMIC ATTENDED BOTH
EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE BUT
EVEN BEFORE THIS FOR THE EIGHT
MILLION ADULTS WITHOUT A
COLLEGE DEGREE FOR EFFECTIVELY
STRANDED WITHOUT FINANCIAL
STABILITY. FOR OPPORTUNITY FROM
ABILITY. MEANWHILE IT'S RICHARD
PREDICTING A CRISIS FOR
EMPLOYERS TO FACE A MILLION
UNFILLED JOBS IN FAST GROWING
INDUSTRIES BECAUSE WORKERS
LACKS THE NECESSARY SKILLS.
THEN COVERT NINETEEN TURNOUT
CRISIS INTO CATASTROPHE. THE
SAME PEOPLE WHO ARE ALREADY
MOST LIKELY TO BE STRUGGLING
WITH THE CHANGING ECONOMY HAVE
BORNE THE BRUNT OF THIS TOPIC.
AND THESE ARE WORKING MOTHERS
WITH CARE GIVING
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THE PEOPLE
THAT CALIFORNIA WAS BUILT TO
SERVE. INTERMISSION IS ONLY
GROWN MORE URGENT ESPECIALLY
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT OUR ADULT
LEARNERS ARE ALSO TEMPTING
TARGETS FOR PREDATORY FOR
PROFIT COLLEGES. ADDRESSING
THIS WITH A KEY FOCUS OF MY
WORK IN THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE
AND THE RESEARCH SHOWS US THAT
THE STUDENTS WHO ATTENDED FOR
PROFIT COLLEGES AFTER LOSING
THEIR JOB DURING THE LAST
RECESSION. ARE AN AVERAGE
FINANCIALLY WORSE OFF TODAY
THAN THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN IF
THEY HADN'T ATTENDED COLLEGE AT
ALL. A DECADE FROM NOW WE DON'T
WANNA BE FACING THAT SAME
REALITY WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
BEFORE US TODAY TO BUILD A MORE
EQUITABLE RECOVERY. SO
CALIBRATE WE LOOKED AT
COMMUNITIES HARDEST HIT BY THE
CAMP PANDEMIC AND KEPT A LASER
FOCUS ON THEIR NEEDS. I AM
PLEASED TO SAY THAT WE ARE
MAKING STEADY AND CONSISTENT
PROGRESS IN SUPPORT OF OUR
MISSION. OUR STUDENTS BUT THE
STATE'S TREMENDOUS RACIAL
DIVERSITY AND MORE THAN 90% ARE
ADULTS OVER THE AGE OF TWENTY
FIVE IN SHORT OR SURFING
EXACTLY THE POPULATION. THE
LEGISLATURE SOUGHT TO SERVE BUT
WILL CONTINUE TO PUSH OURSELVES
TO MEET THE STUDENTS WERE WHERE
THEY ARE. WE'VE DONE ANALYSIS
OF THE LABOR MARKET NEEDS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND THE
STATEWIDE INSTITUTION WERE ABLE
TO BE RESPONSIVE TO REGIONS OF
THE STATE WHERE NEED IS THE
GREATEST INCLUDING PLACES LIKE
INLAND EMPIRE AND CENTRAL
VALLEY. WE CURRENTLY HAVE THREE
PROGRAMS UNDERWAY AND IN APRIL
WE LAUNCHED A SERIES TO HELP
PEOPLE TRANSITION INTO NEW
TECHNOLOGY CAREERS. IN
COLLABORATION WITH REGIONAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
WORKFORCE. LOOKING AHEAD TO
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WE ARE
ONTRACK FOR FULL ACCREDITED.
AHEAD OF. THE KEY MILE. AT ALL
SET US UP FOR BOTH FASTER. AND
LONG TERM SYSTEM. BONTA
NETWORKING AND I SAW. WE AYE DE.
UP TO SELL SHARES. THAT ARE
FACING ADULT LEARNERS ACROSS
THE STATE. THIS INCLUDES
SUPPORTING TECHNOLOGY NEEDS
THAT RURAL SISTER COLLEGES WE
DID AT THE START OF THE
CONTENT. ADDRESSING EQUITY
ISSUES IN THE SYSTEM WIDE
ENROLLMENT APPLICATION. SHARING
ARE GROWING EXPERTISE IN
DESIGNING COMPETENCY BASED
EDUCATION. AND BUILDING
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COLLEGES LIKE
COMPTON COLLEGE BAKERSFIELD
COLLEGE IN MORE. DURING MY
CAREER IN EDUCATION I'VE SEEN
WHAT'S WORKED AND WHAT HASN'T
AND IT'S CLEAR THAT THIS MOMENT
REQUIRES A NEW APPROACH. WE
STILL CALVET SITS AT THE NEXUS
BETWEEN LABOR MARKET AND HIGHER
EDUCATION WHICH GIVES US THE
ABILITY TO BUILD PROGRAMS THAT
ARE RESPONSIVE TO AND
PREDICTIVE OF EMPLOYER NEEDS.
WE'VE GONE EVEN DEEPER TO
INTERVIEW WORKERS IN KEY ROLES
AND TO CONNECT THE DOTS TO
DESIGN PROGRAMS THAT ADDRESS
REAL CHALLENGES PEOPLE FACE AN
EMPLOYMENT MARKET. BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT IT MEANS TO US TO
BE STICKING FIRST AS AN
INSTITUTION KEEPING OUR
POPULATION AND THEIR UNIQUE
NEEDS AT THE FOREFRONT OF
EVERYTHING WE DO. OUR FACULTY
PRESIDENT SENATE PRESIDENT
MICHAEL STEWART ACTUALLY SHARE
STORY WITH ME THAT I KEEP TOP
OF MIND. MONICA IS A SINGLE
MOTHER OF THREE IS BORNAND
RAISED IN SACRAMENTO SHE HAS
THE PASSION TO FIX THINGS BUT
NO ACTUAL BACKGROUND IN
TECHNOLOGY J. TRUCKIN ONLINE
FOR PROFIT PROGRAM BUT WITHOUT
SUCCESS. TODAY MONICA THAN OUR
I. T. PROGRAM PURSUING MORE
STABLE FUTURE FOR HER FAMILY.
SHE SAID I QUOTE I THINK THIS
OFFERING IS ONE OF THE BEST
THINGS TO COME TO CALIFORNIANS
ESPECIALLY AT A TIME LIKE THIS.
I CAN'T WAIT TO GET MY HANDS ON
A CALIBRATE FEATURE. NOT CALVET
FUTURE FOR MONICA IS OUR NORTH
STAR WE ARE AND WE ARE READY TO
SUPPORT HER AND LEARNERS LIKE
HER ON THEIR JOURNEY. I THANK
YOU ONCE AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE THIS
UPDATE. AND I LOOK FOR TO
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS YOU.
OKAY START WITH MR MEDINA.
THANK YOU- I THANK OUR CHAIR-
IN THE INTRODUCTION HIT THE
NAIL- ON THE HEAD WITH WITH HIS
REMARKS I'M I'M SOMEWHAT.
ACTUALLY AMAZED THAT WE'RE
STILL HERE HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION- YOU'RE LOOKING HERE
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
BUDGET ACT- CREATED THIS
PROGRAM IT IS NOW SEVENTEEN
MONTHS IN OPERATION. AND I HAVE
NEVER SEEN. SO LITTLE DONE WITH
SO MUCH. I CANNOT BELIEVE. THAT
WHAT I HAVE IN FRONT OF ME HERE
THAT THE COLLEGE HAS ISSUED
THIRTY FIVE CREDENTIALS TO
TWENTY NINE INDIVIDUALS. IN
SEVENTEEN MONTHS AND THAT IS AT
AN INVESTMENT. OF I'M NOT SURE.
WHETHER IT'S THE SIXTY MILLION
ONE TIME IN A FIFTEEN MILLION
ONGOING. BUT IF AND I'M NOT A
MATH TEACHER SO I'M NOT SURE
WITH THAT PENCILS OUT TO DOLLAR
PER STUDENT YEAH I THINK IT'S
ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION IF YOU
LOOK AT THE ONE TIME AND IN
MULTI YEAR IS NOT GOING PER
STUDENT YEAH. AGAIN I'VE NEVER
SEEN SO LITTLE DONE WITH SO
MUCH YEAH WE COULD WRITE THEM
OF ALL THE CHECK AND CHANGE
THEIR LIVES AND- WHEN WE WERE.
FIRST BROUGHT THIS IDEA HERE.
TO THE ASSEMBLY- OF THAT THE
AMOUNT OF QUESTIONS THAT WE
HAD. THE SKEPTICISM THAT WE HAD
WAS TREMENDOUS. AND I COMING
FROM EDUCATION SAID WELL I'M
NOT SURE THIS IS REALLY GOING
TO WORK HOW ARE YOU WE GONNA
YOU KNOW TEACH THESE STUDENTS-
DISTANCE LEARNING. THESE SKILLS
THAT YOU PROMISE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO PROVIDE. BUT WE WERE
WE WERE TOLD NO DON'T WORRY YOU
KNOW THIS IS GOING TO BE HUGELY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM. THE
STUDENTS ARE THERE THE DEMAND
IS THERE WE'RE GOING TO WORK
WITH INDUSTRY WE'RE GONNA WORK
WITH THE UNIONS SEIU RIGHT
THERE ARE THESE. LARGE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS WHO WHO ARE NOT
BEING- THEIR EDUCATIONAL. NEEDS
ARE NOT BEING MET ANYWHERE- THE
STUDENTS ARE THERE HIGH DEMAND.
FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR
STUDENTS ENROLLED. THIRTY FIVE
CREDENTIALS TO TWENTY NINE
INDIVIDUALS. WITH A HUGE
INVESTMENT AND THEN. YOU KNOW
AND I AND I AM SAYING ALL THIS
THIS MAN AND WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO YOU YOU YOU ARE NEW
HERE YOU'RE THE NEW CEO BUT-
OUR AS- OUR CHAIR AS COMPARED
THIS. TO THE HIGH SPEED RAIL.
WE ARE HOLDING THE BAG FOR
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN'T AFFORD
I SAID AS MUCH ON THE FLOOR OF
THE ASSEMBLY. AT THE END OF
SESSION LAST YEAR I SAID THAT
THERE SHOULD BE- NO THE FUNDING
TO THIS PROGRAMME LAST YEAR I
SAID ON THE FLOOR THE ASSEMBLY
AT THE END OF SESSION-
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE NOT ALWAYS
LISTEN TO. AND WHEN IT COMES TO
EDUCATION AS SOMETIMES THINK
THE PRACTITIONERS OF EDUCATION
MENO MORE SOMETIMES THAN THE
POLICY MAKERS. OF RESPECTFULLY.
WE WERE VERY SKEPTICAL. HI I
HAVE ASKED FOR A- ADDED THE
AUDIT IS COMING I. PURPOSELY
ASKED THAT THE IDEA NOT HAPPEN
UNTIL WE KNEW WHAT WAS THE
BUDGET SITUATION FOR CALIBRATE
BECAUSE THERE WAS THE
POSSIBILITY THAT CAB RIGHT
WOULD NOT HAVE ANY FUNDING AND
THEREFORE THERE WITH THERE
WOULD BE NO NEED FOR AN ODD. I
WILL SHARE WITH WITH THE
COMMITTEE THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW- HAS INTRODUCED A BILL TO
DEFINE CAL BRIGHT- IN IN IN THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS IT IT'S A
BILL THAT WILL PROBABLY COME
THE HIGHER ED COMMITTEE. IT
WILL BE A BILL THAT I WILL
SUPPORT I CANNOT BELIEVE THAT
WE ARE STILL ASKING FOR
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. PER
STUDENT OUTREACH. MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FOR CAPITAL OUTLAY FOR
BUILDING. IT HASN'T WORKED. WE
WERE SKEPTICAL AT THE BEGINNING
IT HASN'T WORKED- THE MANY CAN
CERTAINLY BET BE PUT TO BETTER
USE I AM SOMEWHAT- EMBARRASSED-
MISS MEN AND THEN YOU HAVE TO
COME HERE TO DEFEND THE PROGRAM
THAT HAS WORKED. THANK YOU. THE
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER LEE. I
THANK YOU EXACT DIRECTOR FOR
JOINING US AND AS MY COLLEAGUE
ALLUDED TO YOU KNOW THIS
PROGRAM IS WAS CONCEIVED BEFORE
YOU CAME ON SO IT YOU ARE IN
THE UNENVIABLE POSITION TO
DEFEND UPON IT NO I WILL FOR
THE SAKE OF MY BELOVED HIGH
SPEED RAIL I WILL TO DEFEND IT
BECAUSE HIGH SPEED RAIL AT
LEAST IS FILLING A VOID A
UNIQUE NEED THAT DOES NOT EXIST
CURRENTLY. WOULD GIVE YOU THAT
NOW THEY ARE THERE BUT THE
ONLINE EDUCATION AS WE HAVE ALL
DISCOVER UNIVERSALLY HAN BE
DONE BY OTHER NEED OR CAN BE
FILLED BY OTHER INSTITUTIONS
AND EVEN WHEN I WAS A STAFFER I
REMEMBERED THE COR ARGUMENT
BEING. WHY IS THIS SOMETHING
THAT ARE CAN YOU COLLEGES COULD
NOT OFFER ON THEIR OWN RIGHT
NOW. WELL WE GOT THE ANSWER NOW
DURING THE PANDEMIC
UNFORTUNATELY IT IS SOMETHING
THEY CAN OFFER ON THEIR OWN.
AND THEY ARE DOING IT AND I AM
A FIRM BELIEVER THAT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
EFFECTIVE OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND THAT'S WHY FRANKLY A LOT OF
OUR- COMMUNITY RETURN TO THE
SCHOOLS WHEN THEY NEED
EDUCATION AND I DO FIRMLY
BELIEVE. THERE IS A PLACE FOR
REMOTE DISTANCE LEARNING OR
ONLINE EDUCATION FOR PEOPLE
THAT NEED IN THEIR LIVES I
THINK THERE IS THAT NEED. BUT I
AM ALSO SKEPTICAL THAT WE NEED
TO INVEST THE- HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. INTO
REPLICATING SOMETHING THAT WE
NOW ARE DEMONSTRATING TO EXIST
IN REAL LIFE- SO THAT'S WHY I.
REMAIN VERY SKEPTICAL OF IT AS
WELL. I AND I DO BELIEVE STILL
THAT. AS OUR EDUCATORS AND OUR
CHECKING ME COLLEGES HAD BEEN
EXPRESSING TO US SINCE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN. THAT
THEY CAN'T DO IT AND THEY ARE
DEMONSTRATING THAT YOU CAN DO
IT- BUT MY QUESTION. RIGHT NOW
TO EXACT DIRECTOR IS GIVEN ALL
WE KNOW ABOUT DISTANCE LEARNING
NOW. AND THAT ALL THE COMING
COLLEGES HAVE THIS. A POTENTIAL
TO DO REMOTE DISTANCE LEARNING.
ACTUALLY FUNNY ENOUGH USUALLY
IN OUR HEARINGS I ASK THE-
EDUCATION SEGMENTS WHEN ARE YOU
RETURNING TO IN PERSON I GUESS
IN THIS CASE THERE WILL. BE NO
QUESTION OF THAT SORT. BUT MY
QUESTION WOULD BE YOU KNOW
GIVEN ALL WE KNOW ABOUT
DISTANCE LEARNING NOW AND THE
REAL REALITY. THAT ALL COMING
COLLEGES CAN OFFER. THESE
PROGRAMS AND YOU ALLUDED TO
WORKING WITH OTHER COLLEGES AND
PARTNERSHIPS. WHAT UNIQUE NEED.
LIKE HIGH SPEED RAIL. CAN
CALIBRATE FILL IN THIS TIME OF
MODERN EDUCATION. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LATE AT IT IT'S
A WONDERFUL QUESTION AT CALVET
HAS THAT DISTINCTIVE MISSION
BECAUSE IT'S BUILT. FOR THE
CHALLENGES. NOT WORKING
LEARNERS ARE FACING TODAY AND
IT IS FUNDAMENTALLY DISTINCT
MODEL FROM WHAT WE SEE AND
CONVENTIONAL ONLINE EDUCATION
THAT IS GREAT WORK THAT MANY OF
OUR SYSTEM COLLEGES ARE DOING-
IN PARTICULAR AT HI I JUST WANT
TO SAY I DON'T CONSIDER OUR
COLLEGE TO BE SEPARATE AND
APART FROM THE SYSTEM. I
CONSIDER US TO BE A PART OF-
THAT. GROUP OF INSTITUTIONS
THAT ARE ALL STRIVING TO DO
THIS WORK- TO SERVICE
POPULATION OF LEARNERS BETTER
BUT WHAT WE'VE WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED FROM OUR RESEARCH AND
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED FROM PAST
RECESSIONARY PERIODS. AND WHAT
I'VE LEARNED OVER THE COURSE OF
MY CAREER IS WE HAVE TO FIND
NEW WAYS OF DOING IT EVEN AN
ONLINE NOT JUST ABOUT ONLINE
FOR THESE LEARNERS IT IS ALSO
ABOUT NOT HAVING A TURN BASED
PROGRAM THAT IS ON AN ACADEMIC
CALENDAR. ONE THAT IS FLEXIBLE
AND SELF PACED AS OUR PROGRAMS
ARE IN ONE THAT IS ABOUT
GETTING THEM NOT JUST THE
TECHNICAL SKILLS BUT THE
CONTEXTUAL SKILLS THAT THEY
NEED IN ORDER TO BE SUCCESSFUL
IN THE WORKPLACE. MOST OF WHAT
WE DO IN CONVENTIONAL EDUCATION
WHETHER IT'S DELIVERED ONLINE
OR WHETHER IT'S DELIVERED IN AN
IN PERSON SETTING IS HANNAH
HUSBAND OVER TIME TO ADDRESS
THE NEEDS OF A VERY TRADITIONAL
AGE POPULATION AND WHAT WE'RE
SEEKING TO DO HERE. IS TO
INTRODUCE A BEST IN CLASS
VERSION OF COMPETENCY BASED
EDUCATION THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WOULD LOVE TO SEE EXPANDED IN
THE SYSTEM AND I KNOW IT'S A
SHARED SYSTEM GOAL THAT WE
HAVE- BUT CREATING THE SPACE
FOR THAT ARE AND HE WORKED TO
OCCUR. IN WAYS THAT ALSO
BENEFIT REAL LEARNERS BUT ALSO
THEN CONNECTS TO- TO CONNECT TO
THIS BROADER WORK THAT THAT THE
SYSTEM IN MY SYSTEM COLLEAGUES
ARE DOING IS IMPORTANT. I JUST
ALSO WANTED TO SAY THAT YOU
HAVE HAD A NUMBER OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH COLLEAGUES
IN THE SYSTEM AND I AND I KNOW
THAT WERE IN THIS WORK TOGETHER
THEY SIMILARLY SEE THAT THREAT
COMING FROM THE FOR PROFIT
COLLEGE PROVIDERS. WE ARE
OPERATING IN A VACUUM THIS IS
THE EXACT POPULATION THAT WE
HAVE SEEN BEING TARGETED. WE
HAVEN'T HAD IN THE PUBLIC
SECTOR- FLEXIBLE OPTIONS
OPTIONS THAT SELF PAY ACTION
THAT CAN. THIS AND THE ON
PRESIDENT PRESSURE AND DEMAND.
THAT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THE
PROJECT. WHEN WITH CARE GETTING
WORSE. ARE FOR. SO ME IT'S NOT
OR THE A YES AND THE IMPORTANCE
OF DOING THIS WORK AS
ENVISIONED. THE STATUTE IN THAT
COLLABORATIVE PLAY IS A CORE
PART OF HOW WE ACCOMPLISH THAT
AND I'D LOVE FIFTY ONE CONCRETE
EXAMPLE OF. OF THIS THAT WITH
RESPECT TO THE SYSTEM WIDE
APPLICATION. WE MIGHT THINK
THAT ACTUALLY THE SYSTEM WIDE
APPLICATION HAS VERY LITTLE TO
DO. WITH WHAT HAPPENS IS ON THE
ENROLLMENT SIDE WHAT HAPPENS IN
TERMS OF STUDENT SUCCESS. BUT
ACTUALLY WHAT WE FOUND WAS
BECAUSE WE WERE UNIQUELY
COLLECTING DATA ON OUR LEARNERS
THAT WERE GOING THROUGH THE
APPLICATION PROCESS. THAT IT
HAD A DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT
ON AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS
AND ADULTS STUDENTS. WILL BE
THEN SUGGESTED KEY CHANGES THAT
CAN BENEFIT THE SYSTEM WIDE
APPLICATION FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES OF LEARNERS. AND
THOSE KINDS OF CHANGES ARE ONES
THAT BENEFIT PAIN POINTS THAT
THE SYSTEM SEES AS A WHOLE. AND
WITH EVERY THINK ABOUT HOW TO
SUPPORT ALL OF US TO REBOUND
ARE ENROLLMENTS AGAINST THIS
COMPETING. PRESSURE FROM FOR
PROFIT COLLEGES. THAT WE ACT
MORE AND MORE EMPHASIS. AND WE
WORK TO IN A WAY THAT IT. WHAT
EACH OF US IS DOING FIRST FOR
WHAT EACH OF US IS DOING. BUT
THAT'S SOME OF THE PROBLEMS NOT
A SINGLE INSTITUTION CAN SOLVE
ON THEIR OWN. BUT I THINK THAT
ON. THAT REALLY ADDRESSES THE
ISSUE IS THAT. THERE IS GREAT.
PROMISE HERE. BUT IT'S JUST NOT
BEING. MATERIALIZED IN AND YOU
WOULD THINK DURING. THE
PANDEMIC WHEN. OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THIS IS. IS THE GREATEST
THERE'D BE A BIG SUCCESS THAT'S
NOT AND- YOU KNOW WHEN THIS WAS
CREATED AND I KNOWS BEFORE YOUR
YOUR YOUR TIME THERE WAS
PROMISE THAT- SEIU AND- THEIR
MEMBERS HAVE GREAT INTEREST IN.
CAN CODING IN THE CAREER LADDER
AND THAT JUST FIZZLED OUT AND-
JUST THE PROMISED THESE PIECES
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AND I
CAN CURRENT I DON'T WANT TO
JUST MAKE THIS UNCOMFORTABLE
AND UGLY BUT THE TRUTH IS IT IS
WHAT IT IS. AND I KNOW YOUR
NEW- IN THIS POSITION AND SO
YOU KNOW I HAVE GREAT RESPECT
FOR YOUR WORK WITH THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AND- AND HIGHER
EDUCATION IN OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES- BUT TO KNOW THAT YOU
TAKE YOU THANKED US FOR THE
SUPPORT AND I'LL BE HONEST
THERE IS NO SUPPORT THERE IS
ONE. LAWMAKER WHO SUPPORTED
THIS AND THAT LAWMAKER DIDN'T
MAKE THIS SURVIVE. IT WAS THE
GOVERNOR AND THE PRIOR GOVERNOR
WHO FOREVER REASONS. HAVE THE
SHINY OBJECT IN THE CORNER
THINK THIS IS GONNA MATERIALIZE
BUT IT'S NOT SO THERE IS
NINETY. 8% DISAPPROVAL FROM THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THIS SO. YOU
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE I
KNOW THAT THERE'S AN AUDIT
COMING OUT. I'M NOT SURE HOW
IT'S GOING TO IMPROVE THE
STANDING BECAUSE THE FACTS ARE
ARE WHAT THEY WERE- I JUST WANT
TO ASK YOU JUST A FEW A FEW.
QUESTIONS- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I FIVE FIND REALLY
INTRIGUING IS THAT- CAL BRAT
CALIBRATE PLANS TO SPEND. UP
TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
PARTNERSHIPS WITH PLACE BASED
AGENCIES SUCH AS COMMUNITY
COLLEGES LIBRARIES. JOB
CENTERS- TO HELP FACILITATE IN
PERSON SUPPORT OF CALIBRATE
STUDENTS THAT DOESN'T THIS
NEGATE THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF CAL
THE CALIBRATE YOU KNOW. WHAT'S
THE POINT OF CALIBRATE. OF THIS
IN THE FIRST PLACE THAT THINK
THAT UNDERMINES THE WHOLE
EFFORT. I THINK WHEN THE STATUE
WAS FIRST CREATED IT ENVISIONED
OPPORTUNITY FOR COLLABORATIVE
PARTNERSHIPS TO OCCUR AT THAT
WERE BASED IN COMMUNITY AND-
THAT IS NOT ABOUT US SETTING UP
STOCK IN A THOUSAND DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
BUT IT'S REALLY AROUND. AND
ENSURING THAT WE ARE TECHNOLOGY
AND I AND OUR WORK PRESENTS AN
IMPORTANT CONNECTOR TO THIS
INSTITUTION AND A GOOD EXAMPLE
OF THIS IS ACTUALLY THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING IN COMPTON
COLLEGE RIGHT NOW. SO COMPTON
COLLEGES LEADERSHIP. RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE WAS A CHALLENGE THAT
THEY WERE EXPERIENCING WITH IN
PERSON SERVICES PRADA DEALT
BASIC EDUCATION AND ADULT BASIC
RULES AND THAT THEY WERE ABLE
TO ACTUALLY CONVERT THAT INTO
COLLEGE GOING INVOLVEMENTS AND
THEY SAW AND SEE. A ROLE FOR
CALIBRATE IN THE PROGRAMS THAT
WE HAVE IN ADDRESSING THE
LEARNER NEEDS IN THE WAY WE DO
WHICH IS NOT JUST THROUGH THE
SOUTHEAST MODELED BY OUR
FACULTY WORK ACROSS SILOS VERY
TYPICAL OF AN INSTITUTION TO
PROTECT PRESENT THE INTEGRATED
SUPPORT MODEL. FOR SERVICES AND
IN SUPPORT OF THAT ARE WRAPPED
AROUND A STUDENT ABOUT TO BRING
THAT TO CONTENT AS A WAY OF
HELPING. COMPTON'S EFFORTS TO
MATRICULATE STUDENTS FROM ADULT.
INTO THAT INTO COLLEGE
ENROLLMENTS AND IF WE THINK
ABOUT THE POPULATION WERE
TALKING OUT ABOUT AND IT'S NOT
SURPRISING THAT YOU MAY NOT
SELF IDENTIFY WITH AN
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY MANY OF
THEM IN THE- OUTRAGE IN THE
FOCUS GROUP WORK THAT WE'VE
DONE WITH PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS.
EXPERIENCE IN EDUCATIONAL
TRAUMA THEY'VE THEY'VE BEEN. IN
NEED OF SOMEBODY WHO CAN WHO
CAN PROGRAM TO ADD TO
SUPPORTING THEM TO UNDERSTAND
WE HAVE THE TALENT THE
POTENTIAL WHAT THEY BRING INTO-
INTO POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION IN
IN IN A WAY THAT RELATES TO
THEM AND SO. WE SEE AN
OPPORTUNITY WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THEM TO
INTRODUCE CALVET LEARNERS INTO
FUTURE PROGRAMS AT COMPTON
COLLEGE AS WELL. YEAH AND I DO
KNOW THE GOAL OF THIS AS AS MY
COLLEAGUE MR LEE SAID THERE IS
A NEED FOR MORE. EDUCATION IN
THIS NON ALL BASED ECONOMY. THE
OPTIONS OUT THERE FOR MEN YEARS
OUR YOU KNOW THE SCAM INSTITUTE.
OF THESE YOU KNOW FLY BY NOW
CALLED WHICH- REP. THANKS AND
SO WE GET THAT WE JUST ONE
DON'T WANT DISAPPOINT THEM
AGAIN NOR THE TAXPAYERS WITH
WITH WITH THAT I DON DONGLE OF
AN EFFORT HERE. AND SO THAT'S
ONE THING THAT THAT'S
FRUSTRATING FOR US AS YOU KNOW.
PRIOR WE LEARNED THAT THAT MOST
OF THE CALIBRATE STUDENTS WERE
STOCKED IN THE ORIENTATION
CLASS THESE STENCILS CLASS. AND
NOW YOU HAVE FIVE HUNDRED OR SO
STUDENTS. HOW MANY OF THOSE
STUDENTS HAVE COMPLETED THE
ORIENTATION. AND ARE MOVING
THROUGH THE REST OF THEIR
PROGRAM. ABSOLUTELY I'M HAPPY
TO GIVE YOU THE SPECIFIC
NUMBERS I DON'T HAVE. MY TEAM
FOLLOW UP WITH SOME OF THE
SPECIFICS WE'VE ACTUALLY- FADE
OUT THE ESSENTIALS PROGRAM AND
WE HELPED MIGRATE THE STUDENTS
FROM ESSENTIALS. INTO INTO
THEIR SKILLS COURSEWORK AND SO
WHAT WE RECOGNIZED WITH EXACTLY
WHAT YOU RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
WAS THE CHALLENGE THAT STUDENTS
ARE EXPERIENCING. IN THAT
INTRODUCTORY COURSE THAT THE
SEQUENCING OF THAT COURSE IS
THE DESIGN OF THAT PROGRAM
DIDN'T WORK SO IN A VERY SHORT
AMOUNT OF TIME IN A MATTER OF
MONTHS NOT A TWO YEAR
CURRICULUM DEVELOPMENT PROCESS
BUT A SHORTER. CLAPPED OUT WE
WERE ABLE TO NOT JUST IDENTIFY
THAT CONCERN BUT MAKE THE
CHANGES. ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS ARE GETTING BOTH THE
SOFT AN ESSENTIAL SKILLS THAT
THEY NEEDED BUT THAT IT WOULD
BE INTEGRATED WITH THEIR SKILLS
AT WORK THAT THEY WERE DOING
AND SO WHAT YOU'LL SEE. ALSO IN
PROGRAMS GOING FORWARD- IS NOT
AN ESSENTIALS COURSE BUT- OF
COURSE THAT. IN BEDS AND
CONSIDERS ALL OF THE TYPES OF
CONCEPTUAL SKILLS THAT SOMEONE
NEEDS TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN THE
WORKPLACE IN ADDITION TO. THAT
AN INTEGRATED WITH THE WAY
THEY'RE APPROACHING SKILLS WORK
THAT'S WHAT'S PRESENCE IN OUR
TRADITION TECHNOLOGY SERIES
SUPPORT JUST. SO MOVE ON TO IT
IF THE STUDENTS DO FINISH. AND
THE IS TO. A LINK TO A- THAT
THE LACK OF AGREEMENTS EMPLOY.
IS A IS A BIT CONCERNING I KNOW
THAT CAL BRIGHT HAS. FORTY FOUR
EMPLOYEES ONLY FIVE FULL TIME
FACULTY SO VERY TOP HEAVY WITH
ADMINISTRATOR SO. I ASSUME
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
IS LINK UP EMPLOYERS AND I'M
NOT SURE IF THAT'S WORKING. AND
THAT WE DON'T AND WE DON'T HAVE
ANY INFORMATION HAT THAT SAYS
THAT IT IS WITH WITH WITH
EMPLOYERS. IN ENTERING INTO
AGREEMENTS SO. SO WHAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF THIS COLLEGE AND
WHAT'S THE VALUE FOR YOUR
STUDENTS IF WE DON'T HAVE JOBS
WAITING FOR THEM. YES MY
PREDECESSOR DID A LUNCH THE
COLLEGE WITH- AN ASSUMPTION
THAT- WE WOULD WORK TO GET
INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYERS TO. ADD TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE COLLEGE
AFTER REPLACEMENT PERSPECTIVE.
AND WHAT HAPPENED WAS WITHIN
FIVE MONTHS AND WE FOUND
OURSELVES IN A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT EMPLOYMENT AT CITY
SCENARIO IN WHICH EMPLOYERS
THEMSELVES BUSINESSES
THEMSELVES ARE MAKING DIFFERENT
DECISIONS ABOUT HIRING. OUR
STRATEGY HAS HAD TO EVOLVE
WITHOUT FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGED
EMPLOYMENT MARKET- THAT WE FIND
OURSELVES IN AND SO WHILE WE
HAVE WE ARE ENGAGING. WITH WITH
EMPLOYERS SPECIFIC THEY WERE
PARTNERING WITH AN EMPLOYER ON
THE LAUNCH OF THIS NEW PROGRAM
THAT WE ARE DOING TO TRANSITION
INDIVIDUALS INTO TECHNOLOGY
CAREERS. WERE ALSO ENGAGING A
BROADER SET OF INPUTS FROM
EMPLOYERS INDUSTRY FROM
TECHNOLOGISTS AND ALSO FROM THE
LABOR MARKET DATA ITSELF THAT
ENSURES THAT THE SKILLS ARE
GETTING THE SKILLS THAT
STUDENTS ARE GETTING ARE
VALIDATED AND PREPARING THEM
FOR THE WORKFORCE SO. WHEN WE
WORKED WITH OUR EMPLOYER
PARTNERS IN THIS PARTICULAR
CONTEXT ON THIS NEW PROGRAM
PATHWAY AND THE TRANSITION'S
TECHNOLOGY PASSED AWAY- WE SOME
OF OUR STUDENTS FROM THAT WILL
TRACK INTO AN EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY OTHERS WILL
CONTINUE ON TO EARN A
CERTIFICATION. THAT WE KNOW IS
IN DEMAND WITH THE LABOR MARKET
THE REALLY NEEDING TO INVOLVE
OUR STRATEGY. BECAUSE WE ARE
DESIGNED TO BE MORE RESPONSIVE
ATTITUDE TO WHAT CHANGES WE'RE
SEEING IN THE LABOR MARKET AND
IT IS A TOUGH LABOR MARKET. FOR
OUR COMMUNITIES. CAN YOU GO
BACK TO IT TO RE YOU'RE AT THIS
YEAR FOR YOU TARA FIRST. RAW
RETENTION RATES AND COMPLETION
RATES. SURE SO AS YOU KNOW WE
ARE AT THERE'S A SEVEN YEAR
TIMELINE FOR START UP FOR THE
COLLEGE THAT WAS ENVISIONED
WE'VE MET ALL THOSE DEADLINES
AND ARE HEADING YOU KNOW I'M
TRACK AHEAD OF SCHEDULE AND KEY
MILESTONES LIKE ACCREDITATION-
ALL OF THOSE THINGS CONTRIBUTE
TO OUR PLANS FOR GROWTH WE ARE
IN THE PROCESS NOW. OF
FINALIZING WITH OUR BOARD OF
TRUSTEES A HREE YEAR STRATEGIC
VISION THAT'S DESIGNED TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE BUILDING THE
COLLEGE BUT ALSO SETTING A
COURSE FOR HIGH QUALITY GROWTH.
AND THROUGH THAT PLAN WE WILL
TAKE US FROM FIVE HUNDRED AND
ALL THIS THAT WE SEE THIS YEAR
TWO FIVE THOUSAND ENROLLMENTS
OVER A THREE YEAR PERIOD NUMBER
TRACKING AN ESTIMATED
COMPLETION DURING THAT PERIOD-
AROUND TWELVE HUNDRED. STUDENTS
AND- DEPENDING UPON. WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IN THE LATE LABOR
MARKET- YOU KNOW THAT. AT
EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES WELL WILL
CONTINUE TO TRACK AS WELL- WE
THINK THAT'S PARTICULARLY
SIGNIFICANT AND IMPORTANT
RELATIVE TO. YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT
WE KNOW IS OUT THERE IN TERMS
OF SOME OF THE LIMITED
BENCHMARKING DATA AT THAT CAN
GIVE US A SENSE OF- WHAT IT'S
WHAT IT MEANS TO KIND OF STEP
UP AND SCALE IN A WAY THAT'S
HIGH QUALITY IN A WAY THAT'S
NOT JUST CHASING ENROLLMENTS
BUT THAT'S FOCUSED. ON OUTCOMES
AT THE SAME TIME WE HAVE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF RESPECT
FOR THE FACT THAT WHAT WE NEED
TO HONOR IT'S NOT JUST OUR
EXPECTATIONS AROUND COMPLETIONS
BUT IN IN TERMS OF. BEING
CLOSELY ATTUNED TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO OUR LEARNERS
THEMSELVES THAT WHAT'S UNIQUE
ABOUT OUR MODEL IS THAT IT'S
NOT SPENT THE STATE IN A TERM
WITH THE SEMESTER- IF YOU HAVE
TWO WEEKS WHERE YOU HAVE TO
TAKE CARE OF A SICK CHILD OR
YOU HAVE TO. CARE FOR A IN
EARLY FAMILY MEMBER OR YOU
YOURSELF GET SICK THAT THAT
OPPORTUNITY AND THAT
FLEXIBILITY AT ALLOW SOMEBODY
TO MOVE IT THEIR SELF HE'S FAT
AND I AND OUR GOAL IS AND OUR
JOB IS. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE SUPPORTING THEM- TO FIND
GOAL THAT WE HELP THEM. AND
THEN LAW I SOME OF THEM MEMBERS
MASSIVE TO ASK I'M JUST LOOKING
FOR CONCRETE EVIDENCE THAT.
THIS WILL BE A SUCCESS FOR OUR
PARTICIPANTS AND AT CREDIBLE.
REASONS TO BELIEVE THAT THAT'S
GOING TO BE THE CASE IN THE
NEAR FUTURE- BECAUSE- TO US SO
FAR IT'S IT YOU HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO DEVELOP PROGRAMS A REAL
VALUE. WITH COMPLETION RATES
AND JOB PLACEMENT RATES. AND
THE TARGET HERE LOW WAGE
WORKERS PEOPLE OF COLOR. AND
CONCERNED THAT IF IT IF WE FAIL
THEN THEY'LL JUST WORSENED. OUR
OUR RACIAL INEQUITIES IN INCOME
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. CALIBRATES
HAVING THAT IS UNACCREDITED AND
HAVING A HARD TIME CONVINCING
STUDENTS TO ENROLL. SO AGAIN.
WHERE IS THE CONCRETE EVIDENCE.
THAT THIS WILL LEAD TO SUCCESS
FOR PARTICIPANTS. YES WE HAVE
BEEN VERY THOUGHTFUL OF
TRANSLATING THE LEARNINGS THAT
WE HAD FROM THE EARLY PROGRAM
PATHWAYS INTO THE INTO THE
POSITIVE CHANGES THAT WILL
CHANGE THE TRAJECTORY FOR OUR
STUDENTS OUT WE ARE ALSO AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT YOU
RAISE THE ISSUE OF A CONVICTION
HAVING SPENT SO MUCH TIME ON
THE FEDERAL SIDE. YOU KNOW
AROUND ACCOUNTABILITY AND
FOCUSED ON QUALITY ASSURANCE AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND WHAT
INSTITUTIONS ARE DOING THERE I
TAKE THAT VERY SERIOUSLY
ACCREDITATION IS A PROCESS THAT
WE ARE GOING THROUGH RIGHT NOW
WE ARE ACTUALLY AHEAD OF
SCHEDULE IN TERMS OF SUBMITTING
OUR APPLICATION AND MOVING
THROUGH THE PROCESS TO GET
ACCREDITED- AS WELL AS- WELL
CONCURRENT PROCESS BY WHICH WE
WILL. SEEK APPROVAL FOR
PARTICIPATION IN THE FEDERAL
STUDENT AID PROGRAMS WHICH ARE
REALLY ALSO UNLOCK RESOURCES
AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR
STUDENTS WHO CAN USE THAT
SUPPORT AND THAT RELIEF TO
REALLY ENGAGE IN THIS
OPPORTUNITY- SO I THINK THERE
IS A LOT THAT WE HAVE DONE FOR
THE STATE OF DEVELOPMENT THAT
WERE IN AGAIN GOING BACK TO
THAT SEVEN YEAR TIME WINDOW.
BUT IF YOU'RE ASKING ME IF I'M
SATISFIED TODAY WITH THE
PROGRESS THAT WE MADE I'M THE
KIND OF PERSON WHO GETS THE
FOOT ON THE ACCELERATOR SO I
HATE THAT I ABSOLUTELY- SEE THE
INTENSE VALUE OF SCALING THIS
UP IN A HIGH QUALITY WAY AND TO
DO IT RESPONSIBLY AS GOOD
STEWARDS OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS AT
THE SAME TIME I UNDERSTAND.
THAT IT TAKES TIME TO BUILD
HIGH QUALITY THINGS AND THE WAY
THAT WE APPROACH THE WORK HAS A
LASTING IMPACT ON THE
EFFECTIVENESS AT SCALE AND SO
WE DON'T I I'VE TAKEN ALL THE
LESSONS THAT I'VE LEARNED FROM
WEARING MY REGULATORY HAT THAT
THE FOR PROFIT COLLEGE INDUSTRY
AND TO REALLY UNDERSTAND THAT
WHAT WE NEED TO BE DOING HERE.
IS AGAIN IN THE BILL REFINING
AND FOCUSING ON WHAT WORKS FOR
THE COMMUNITIES WE NEED TO
SERVE WHAT FLEXIBILITY AS WE
NEED FOR SERVICES WE DO WE DO
THAT AT A MUCH FASTER CLIP THAN
CONVENTIONAL EDUCATION DOES AND
THAT'S PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THE MORE WE LEARN THE
MORE WE SHARE OUT WITH OUR
SISTER INSTITUTIONS THE MORE WE
COLLABORATE THE MORE WE ARRIVE
AT THE SHARED SOLUTIONS AND THE
IMPACT. OF WHAT WE HAVE IT'S
NOT JUST ABOUT THE ALWAYS IN
OUR INSTANT. BUT IT IS ABOUT
THE FOR. AND KATHLEEN. WE CAN
THIS OF COMMUTER COLLEGES AND
ASSIST. TO BETTER SERVE THE
SAKE. I YOU KNOW I FORWARD TO
DAY WHERE I CAN. TO SET BEFORE
YOU AND- AND CONTINUE TO SHOW.
OUR I KNOW THAT. MY STAFF IS
LISTENING IN. AND THERE SOME
SIMILAR FACES THE STAFF NOW I'M
VERY LUCKY TO HAVE JENNIFER.
JEFF BELL AND JENNIFER JOHNSON.
WHO HAS. NOW COMMITMENT GOING
FORWARD TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
ARE UP TO DATE ON THE PROGRESS
THAT WE'RE MAKING. AND ALSO TO
SHARE ENGAGE WITH YOU. ON THE
ON THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING
FORWARD. GOING FORWARD AND TO
THAT WE UNDERSTAND HOW IT IS
ALSO IN TUNE WITH YOUR NEEDS
AND- TO INCLUDE DIFFERENT
DISTRICTS. OKAY THANK YOU
THAT'S ALL FOR ME RIGHT NOW.
SOME I THINK LISTENING THE
QUESTIONS IN THE COMMENTS
REMINDS ME THAT THIS IS EXACTLY
WHY OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
NOT GETTING THE FUNDING THEY
DESERVE. THEY ARE RESPECTED AND
THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE NOT
RECOGNIZED FOR THE GREAT WORK
THEY'RE DOING OUR COMMUNITY.
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES I THINK IN THE
ANSWERS- OF WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
IS ONE OF THE QUESTIONS WAS
WHAT MAKES YOU SO UNIQUE.
EVERYTHING THAT I HEARD. WAS
SOMETHING THAT IS OFFERED IN
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
EVERYTHING. THERE IS NOTHING
THAT I HAVE HEARD SO FAR THAT
MAKES CAL BRIGHT UNIQUE. WHAT
WE HAVE LIMITED RESOURCES THIS
IS WHAT THE WHOLE ARGUMENT IS
ABOUT EVERY BUDGET HEARING AND
GET WITH OUR LIMITED RESOURCES
WE'RE TAKING THAT MONEY THAT
COULD BE ADDED ON TO OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THAT ARE
ALREADY PROVIDING ALL THESE
CLASSES ONLINE. THE WORK THAT
IS BEING DONE IS DUPLICATIVE.
THE MORE WE GIVE TO. CALIBRATE
THE LAST FUNDING THERE IS FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND IN TURN
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
I WOULD LISTEN TO THE COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
RIVERSIDE AND I AGREE WITH
EVERY SINGLE COMMENT HE MADE.
ONE OF THE THINGS HE SAID IS
THAT WE'RE LISTENING FOR WE'RE
NOT GIVING THE FULL VALUE TO
OUR PRACTITIONERS AS WE SHOULD
COMPARE TO OUR POLICYMAKERS WE
HAVE SOMEONE WHO IS A
PRACTITIONER AND IS A POLICY
MAKER NOT ONLY WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM FROM. FROM
RIVERSIDE BUT ALL OTHER
COLLEAGUES. THERE ARE
PRACTITIONERS AND POLICYMAKERS
AND THE CHAIR HAS SAID THAT 99%
OR 98% WHATEVER NUMBER YOU USE
MISTER CHAIR. DO NOT SUPPORT
THIS I AM ONE OF THOSE THE
CONCEPT MAY SOUND WONDERFUL BUT
IT'S ALREADY BEING PROVIDED
WHAT WE ARE DOING WITH CAL
BRIGHT IS TAKING MONEY AWAY
THAT COULD GO TO OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO HELP THEM PROVIDE
MORE SERVICES. TO THE VERY
STUDENTS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT NEED THIS HELP. OKAY SEVEN
MEMBER LETTUCE THE- THANK YOU
SO LET'S TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE SUCCESSES THAT YOU
HAVE- IN THE TWENTY NINE-
STUDENTS THAT HAVE COMPLETED
PROGRAMS WERE OF THE TWENTY
NINE STUDENTS HOW MANY OF THEM
WERE ABLE TO BE PLACED OR-
PROMOTED WITHIN THEIR FIELD.
FOR JOBS SO FAR WE HAVE A PLACE
YES SO FAR WE HAVE PLACED OUT
ONE STUDENT AT IN A TRACK
PLACEMENT AND WE'RE CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH THE OTHER STUDENTS
ARE COMPLETING PROGRAMS. IN
THEIR JOB MARKETS THE BIRCH
GOING FORWARD. WE PLAN ON AT
THAT THE LAUNCH OF NEW PROGRAMS
ALSO WILL THINK ABOUT THIS FROM
THE PERSPECTIVE OF. WHAT
STUDENTS ARE NAVIGATING THEIR
CAREER FROM DAY ONE SO THAT THE
CHOICES THAT WE ALSO MADE FOR
NEW PROGRAMS. THAT REFLECT THE
THAT THE CHORE ECONOMICALLY
DISPLACED RIGHT NOW THOSE YOUR
FAMILY RETAIL WORK AND
HOSPITALITY OTHER AREAS OF
CUSTOMER SERVICE AND THINKING
ABOUT HOW THE SKILLS THAT THEY
HAVE CAN TRANSLATE INTO- THAT
THE- THAT THE TECHNOLOGY FIELD
AND SPACE. AT TO PROVIDE THEM
TO INTO THE PLACES WHERE
THERE'S EVEN MORE JOB
OPPORTUNITIES. AND IS THERE A
PLAN TO REGULARLY. COLLECT DATA
AND REPORT ON THIS. YES SO- WE
ARE AB GOING TO BE COLLECTING
DATA ON JOB PLACEMENT AND WAGE
GAINS AND WHAT WE'RE ALSO
RECOGNIZING AS WE HEAR MORE AND
STUDY MORE ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE EMPLOYMENT
MARKET TO THIS POPULATION IN.
THESE COMMUNITIES OF WORKERS IS
THAT WE NEED BETTER DATA
COLLECTION AND MORE DATA
COLLECTION AROUND THE DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCES THEY HAVE IN THE
LABOR MARKET SO WHAT I MEAN BY
THAT IS. THAT WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT HEALTHCARE WE ARE
ALSO THINKING ABOUT WHAT IS
REQUIRED FOR INDIVIDUALS TO
KEEP THE JOB THAT THEY HAVE BUT
TO HAVE THE NECESSARY SKILLS.
THAT'S BASED ON THE WAY THAT
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY ISN'T
CHANGING OUR CONVERSATIONS
ACTUALLY WITH AND SEE IF YOU
HAVE BEEN VERY INSTRUCTIVE VERY
INFORMATIVE IN HELPING US TO
DESIGN A PATHWAY THAT. MEETS
THE NEEDS OF THEIR WORKFORCE
AND THEIR FRONT LINE WORKERS
AND WE IT ALSO SOMETIMES. AS I
MENTIONED IN THIS CASE OF THE
NEW PROGRAMS THAT WERE
LAUNCHING MOVING PEOPLE FROM AN
INDUSTRY THAT IS AN ANTICLINE
INDUSTRY INTO AN INDUSTRY OUT
OF. OUR GROWTH AND OPPORTUNITY
AND CAREER EXPANSION FOR THEM
SOMETIMES IT IS GOING FROM AN
HOURLY JOB TO A BENEFITTED JOB.
THOSE ARE THE GUYS THAT I CUT
OUTCOMES NEED TO BE TRACKING
CODE GOING FORWARD AND WE HAVE
EVERY INTENTION OF. DOING SO-
IN THE FUTURE. I'M ONE
PLACEMENT IS VERY CONCERNING
WITH THE COST OF THIS PROGRAM-
AND- IT RAISES FRANKLY RED
FLAGS FOR ME- ARE. N. THE
QUESTION. IS ARE THE PROGRAMS.
ARE THE R. D. THE PROGRAM THAT
EXIST OR THE- THE- ARE THEY
WHAT WE NEED. I'M YOU'RE A IT
YOU BE TO THREE NEW PATH. BUT
FOR. SO HOW'S IS THAT STILL ON
TRACK WHAT ARE THEY AND HOW DO
WE KNOW THAT. THEY'RE GONNA
PRODUCE SIGNIFICANT OUTCOMES
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT SEEING THOSE
OUTCOMES NOW. YES I CAN TELL
YOU I'M NOT SATISFIED OBVIOUSLY
WITH- WITH THE NUMBERS SIGNED
AT. STUDENT LABOR MARKET
OUTCOMES I AM ALSO VERY
EMPATHETIC TO THE REALITIES
THAT INDIVIDUALS ARE FACING RAP
OF THE REALITIES OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE HIRING MARKET
AND SO- WHEN IT REQUIRES FOLKS
TO. TAKE TIME TO PROGRESS WEEK
WITH KNOWLEDGE THAT WHEN IT
WHEN THAT JOB SEARCH EFFORT
IT'S HARDER BECAUSE THE LABOR
MARKET CONDITIONS HAVE MADE IT
SO. THAT WE ARE ALSO THERE FOR
THEM GOING FORWARD WE ARE ON
TRACK TO MEET OUR STATUTORY.
COMMITMENT TO THREE NEW PROGRAM
PATHWAYS THE FIRST AS I
MENTIONED THAT WAS APPROVED BY
OUR BOARD WITH THIS TRADITION
TO TECHNOLOGY PATHWAY. THAT'S A
PATHWAY THAT LEADS TO AN
INDUSTRY RECOGNIZED
CERTIFICATION IN WHAT'S CALLED
CUSTOMER RELATIONS MANAGEMENT
SO IT'S THE ACTUAL SET OF
TECHNOLOGIES THAT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY TRANSFORMING. THE
WAY THAT INDIVIDUALS- THE END
BUSINESSES MAINTAIN CUSTOMER
RELATIONS AS WELL AS- WELL AS
ENGAGE IN SALES AND SO- OUR
PROGRAMS ARE DESIGNED TO MEET.
AT THE GROWING CHANGING
BUSINESS DECISIONS THAT
EMPLOYERS ARE- THAT BUSINESS
SERVICES FOR MAKING THAT ARE
CHANGING SOME OF THEIR SKILLS
NEEDS- SO FOCUSING ON THOSE AND
FOCUSING ON TRANSITION FOLKS
ARE CURRENTLY DISPLACED INTO
THOSE. ROLES ARE A KEY PART OF
THAT WE ARE ALSO AS I MENTIONED
IN DISCUSSIONS AROUND- WORK
THAT WE ARE DOING IN THE
HEALTHCARESPACE AT WORK IN THE
HEALTH CARE SPACE. IS MEANT TO
DRIVE IN UNDERSTAND UPSKILLING
STRATEGY THAT IS RELATED TO
SOME OF THE- CHALLENGES THAT-FRONTLINE HEALTH CARE WORKERS
ARE FACING. IN THE IN THE IN
THE CRISIS THAT WE'RE FACING IN
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY AND THAT
HAS BEEN VERY MUCH ABOUT.
LEARNING AND UNDERSTANDING FROM
THE WORK AT S. C. A. U. U. H.
W. OTHER TRAINING PARTNER FOR
TOUR AND OTHERS HAVE DONE. TO
REALLY ACT DOCUMENT IN THE
MARKET WHAT SKILLS ARE NEEDED
AND SO OUR PROGRAMS WILL B
ALIGNED TO THAT AND THEY'LL BE
IN. IN THE CALIBRATE WAY. WITH
AN INTEGRATED SET OF. THAT AND
THAT SUPPORT. AT THAT. FOR THE
FOR THE WORKERS AND THIRTY.
THAT RACK. AT PLANNING ON
WATCHING PRO AND IS RELATED TO
ADVANCE. SEVEN MANUFACTURING
NEEDS BEEN FOR TRYST A RESPONSE
GRANT FROM THE- THAT'S MOVING
THE OFFICE OF. THE GOVERNOR.
PLAN AND RESEARCH OFFICE THAT
IS FOCUSED ON. WORKING WITH
TEN. AND ADVANCE ANY.
SPECIFICALLY THE DEFENSE SPACE
WHO ARE LOOKING TO UNDERSTAND-
HOW BEST TO APPLY WORK BASED
LEARNING INTO- AND THOSE
EXPERIENCES HANDS ON
EXPERIENCES INTO- INTO TRAINING
PATHWAYS IN A WAY THAT ALSO
CHANGES THE WAY THAT WE DO.
EMPLOYER ENGAGEMENT WITH AN
INDUSTRY LIKE THAT AND THAT
WILL LEAD TO BOTH ONE PATHWAY
BUT ALSO. LIKELY A SERIES OF
PATHWAYS AND- IN THAT FIELD SO
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ON TRACK TO
DO FOR THE SUMMER- AND THE
APPROACH THAT WE'RE TAKING
WHICH I'M EXCITED TO SHARE MORE
WITH YOU ABOUT- HALF MY STAFF.
AND SHARE WITH YOUR STAFF MARK
IS ALSO ABOUT UNDERSTANDING
WHEN WE MAKE DECISIONS TO MAKE
PATHWAYS THERE NOT ONE OFF.
THEY ARE VERY MUCH FOCUSED ON
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITHIN AN
INSTANT INDUSTRY AND WHAT'S
HAPPENING ACROSS INDUSTRIES AND
SO WHICH I CONTINUE TO SEE FROM
US GOING FORWARD. IS REFLECTED
IN THAT DEEP UNDERSTANDING THAT
EVEN NOW SAYS. THAT IN THE
ABSTRACT BUT WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT WHERE OPPORTUNITIES ARE
**** IT. SUITED FOR SOME OF THE
LEARNER POPULATIONS THAT WERE
TALKING ABOUT. THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING ALSO THAT WE WANNA
HANG ONTO INTO JUST OURSELVES
THIS IS ALSO SOMETHING THAT'S
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR. OTHER
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN WORKING IN THIS
RAIN MOVING IN THAT DIRECTION
OF COMPETENCY BASED EDUCATION.
AND WE WHAT WE WANT TO BE EATEN
WE RESPECTFUL DUPLICATION BUT
WE ALSO WANT TO BE STRONG
PARTNERS FOR COLLEAGUES IN THE
SYSTEM. AB WHO WANT TO ENGAGE
IN THIS WORK. AND IMPLEMENT A
DIFFERENCE. AND OF A-
ACCREDITED- IMPACTS STUDENTS A
BILL APPLY TO APPLY PROGRAM- SO
IS CAL RIGHT SAW. TO APPLY FOR
CREDITORS BY FIRST. AND HOW
LONG WILL THE PRICE. YES I
THINK IT THE QUESTION HE- WE
ARE ON TRACK AND THAT THE
STATUTE HASN'T NEEDING TO
REACH- ACCOMMODATION HAVING
SECURED ACCREDITATION BY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. WE ARE ACTUALLY MOVING
ADEQUATE MUCH FASTER THAN THAT
AND ME ARE SUBMITTING OUR
APPLICATION AND NEXT MONTH AT
THAT APPLICATION YEAH WE WILL
YOU KNOW IT'S OUT OF OUR HANDS
THERE'S A CONDITION PROCESS
ACOSTA REVEALED- WE NEED
ESTIMATE. AT THAT WILL BE DONE
AT OF. AND WE'RE DOING IT FOR
ALSO CONCUR. LOOKING OUR- TO
APPROVED FOR CALIFORNIA.
WITHOUT BORING WITH A OF THE-
YOU KNOW HUNDREDS OF PAGES OF
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS FOR
FEDERAL STUDENT AID. WHICH IS
THAT THE CAREER HAZARD FOR ME
HAVING THAT BEEN THE FOCUS OF
MY BACKGROUND BUT- WE ARE
CURRENTLY BEING EVALUATED FOR
THAT AND IMPORTANCE OF THAT IS
NOT. BECAUSE IT NECESSARILY
JUST CRIED REVENUE TO THE CALLS
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY YEAH IT'S
THE MISSING SUPPORT THAT THAT
MORE OF OUR STUDENTS NEED. AT
IN ORDER TO REALLY BE ABLE TO
TAKE AND HAVE SOME BREATHING
ROOM IN ORDER TO. FIND THIS THE
BEST THE SPACE TO BE ABLE TO
STUDY PARTICULARLY UNDER THE
CONDITIONS THAT WE FIND
OURSELVES AND THAT'S ENDEMIC
IT'S JUST. IT'S WHAT'S HAPPENED
TO OUR LEARNERS. INTEREST
SOMEONE PRESIDENT. SO THEN
WOULD YOU SAY THAT'S IN FIVE. A
PROGRAM I'M HAVING. NOT HAVING.
TO STATE AND FEDERAL. AID
PROGRAMS HAS NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED YOUR- ENROLLMENT
EFFORTS. I THINK THE PANDEMIC
IS AND HAS BEEN HAD A HUGE
IMPACT ON OUR LEARNERS- YOU
KNOW I THINK THERE'S LOTS OF
WAYS TO RECRUIT STUDENTS INTO
COLLEGE WE'VE BEEN FOCUSED ON.
MAINTAINING THAT EXTREME OF
FIVE HUNDRED AND MOMENTS- AS WE
HAVE REFINED ASPECTS OF THIS
HEARING TESTED MADE TO THE
NECESSARY CHANGES THAT I TALKED
ABOUT. NOT GOING FORWARD WE'RE
ACTUALLY WELL POSITIONED TO
GROW THOSE ENROLLMENTS AS I
MENTIONED OUR PLAN TO GROW FROM
FIVE TO FIVE HUNDRED IS MUCH
MORE ABOUT. OUR ARE STACKING ON
NEW PROGRAMS ARE AND REACHING A
LEVEL OF DEVELOPMENT IN THE
COLLEGE AND INCREASED CAPACITY
AT WITH THE CURRENT BUDGET
APPLICATION THAT WE HAVE- TO BE
ABLE TO- TO BE ABLE TO SERVE
MORE STUDENTS AND TO BE ABLE TO
DO IT IN A WAY AT. THAT IS
FOCUSED ON THE QUALITY FRONT
AND CENTER AND IS FOCUSED ON
AND THESE ARE POPULATIONS AND-
THANK YOU. IT OKAY. OKAY YEAH
OVERLOOKING THE LAKE OVER THE
NEXT YEAR THAT'S TRUE GALLAGHER
HAVE THERE FOR A SEC. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD DID YOU WANT TO
ENGAGE ON THAT COVERAGE YEAH.
OTHER VOTER RAT WE'RE JUST
WRAPPING UP HERE PERFECT
APOLOGIZE FOR MISSING YOUR
PRESENTATION OF AYE REPEAT
ANYTHING I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT-
I KNOW YOU HEARD FROM THE OTHER
MEMBERS REALLY- JUST CONCERNING
YOUR ENROLLMENT SO CAN YOU JUST
GIVE ME A SENSE OF- WHERE
YOU'RE A ROMAN IS NOW. YES
WE'VE MAINTAINED A STEADY
STREAM OF FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS
IN THE COLLEGE- WE'VE AWARDED
THIRTY FIVE CERTIFICATES HAVE
WE ARE ALSO. A FINALIZING WITH
OUR BOARD OF TRUSTEES EIGHT
AND- CERTIFICATION OVER THE
NEXT THREE YEARS THAT WILL TAKE
ON ROMANCE FROM FIVE HUNDRED TO
FIVE THOUSAND AND WILL GROW OUR
PROGRAMS WITH A FOCUS ON
QUALITY AND WITH A FOCUS TO
MEETING KEY ORGANIZATIONAL
MILESTONES THAT WILL NEED. IN
ORDER TO BUILD THE APACITY OF
THE CULTURE CERTAINLY MORE
STUDENTS SO WE ARE- WE ARE
MAKING STEADY AT AROUND FIVE
HUNDRED MOMENTS BUT- I AM. YEAH
I AM AS I MENTIONED TO. THE
REST OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE I'M
NOT SATISFIED THAT THESE
NUMBERS WE ARE. CONTINUING TO
HIT THINK SALARY DURING
CONTINUING TO MOVE OUR WORK
FORWARD IN WAYS THAT ARE
MEANINGFUL THAT INCLUDES. THE
LAUNCH OF NEW PROGRAMS THIS
SPRING ARE THE FIRST OF WHICH
HAS BEEN APPROVED BY THE BOARD
WHICH IS VERY MUCH GEARED
TOWARDS. HELPING INDIVIDUALS
TRANSITION INTO NEW CAREERS IN
TECHNOLOGY PARTICULARLY FOCUSED
ON DISCONNECTED WORKERS WHO ARE
IN RETAIL WERE IN HOSPITALITY
WHO IN AREAS OF THE ECONOMY
WITH. GREATER UNCERTAINTY AND
RECOVERY AND SO OUR EFFORTS ARE
VERY MUCH ABOUT SEEING HOW THEY
CAN USE THE SKILLS THAT THEY
HAVE. WITH NEW CONTACTED WITH
SOME TECHNICAL SKILLS TO
TRANSITION INTO. INSTANT
CONTINUAL INDUSTRIES AND
OCCUPATIONS THAT USE THAT
TECHNOLOGIES LIKE CUSTOMER
RELATIONSHIP MANAGEMENT AND- IN
IN THE COURSE OF. OF WORK BEING
DONE BY THE FIVE YOU TO- WOULD
YOU SAY THERE THEY'RE ACTIVE TO
ARE THE JUST STUDENTS WHO
ENROLL. BUT I THINK THE PRETTY
GOOD SENSE OF THE FOR HUNDRED-
YOU KNOW. ARE THEY ACT WORKING
TOWARD THEIR SIR. OR THE GYM ON
THE ON THE- LAST. YES AT NO
THEIR THERE ACTIVE- AND IT'S A
MESS I THINK. WHAT'S IMPORTANT
FOR ABOUT THESE PRO. IS THAT
THE ARE SELF PROGRAMS SO
STUDENTS ACTION. NO DON'T BE ON
A TWO BASIS YEAH SET THE GOALS
THAT THEY HAVE AND THAT
FLEXIBILITY IS IMPORTANT FOR
THIS POPULATION HAS BEEN TALKED
ABOUT BEFORE. LARGELY BECAUSE
THIS IS THE TIME IN WHICH THEY
NEED SOME FLEXIBILITY OFTEN
THOSE FLEXIBILITIES TAKE THE
FORM OF. NOT NEEDING TO STEP
AWAY FOR A COUPLE WEEKS BECAUSE
THERE IS A FAMILY MEMBER TOLD
HER THAT HER FAMILY THAT SIX.
WHEN THEY HAVE CHILDCARE
RESPONSIBILITIES FURTHER
DOUBLING UP AS A TEACHER AT
HOME- IF WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF
THE STORIES MEET AND SURVEYS
OUR STUDENTS. AND ADD DURING
THE PANDEMIC TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THE MAJORITY OF THEM WERE
AFFECTED BY THAT THE PANDEMIC
AND REALLY ADVERSE WAYS IN WAYS
THAT- INCLUDED THINGS LIKE THEY
HAD. EXPERIENCED JOB LOSS OR
FOR LOW OR FAT LOSS OF INCOME
IN HOURS A COMBINATION OF
THINGS THAT HAS MADE IT
SOMETIMES DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
HAVE EDUCATION BE TOP OF MIND.
SO WHAT WE'RE FOCUSED ON WITH
THAT FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS IS.
CONTINUALLY TRYING TO SANCTION
THEM CROWDING THEM ALONG ME
COURAGE AND THEN I HAVE IT A
TREMENDOUS. FIVE INSTRUCTIONAL
FACULTY BUT ALSO THREE FULL
TIME FACULTY IN THE COUNSELING
SPACE THAT REALLY DON'T WORK IN
A SILENT WAY IS WE TYPICALLY
SEE COLORS WORK TOGETHER. AND
AS IN TEAMS AROUND THESE
LEARNERS AND THAT'S THAT YOU
KNOW THAT'S AN INNOVATION IN
THE MODEL THAT- THAT WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED IN THE FALL. AND
THEN AS AT A TIME WHEN THE REST
OF THE SYSTEM TO COMMUNICATE
SYSTEM THEIR ROMAN IS GOING
DOWN. WHAT'S YOUR PLAN ON
GETTING ENROLLMENT. GOING FROM
FIVE HUNDRED TO FIVE THOUSAND.
ABSOLUTELY I THINK WHAT IS
IMPORTANT IT UNDER IS THAT THE
ARE NEW. OF AND I AM. AND BUT-
MIGHT BE MEMBERS MIGHT BE TIRED
OF HEARING SAY IT- YEAH I
EXPERIENCED TERRORISTS AND THEN
OUR- WHAT HAPPENED ON THE- FOR.
WHEN WHEN WE SEE THINGS IN A
DECLINE IN A ROW TO PLACE
BECAUSE THERE FOR PA COLLEGE.
THAT ARE. THE SAME POP. SO IF
YOU AT THE FOLLOWING MOMENT
DATE WOULD HAVE NASH YOU SEE IT.
OUR PRODUCT. FOR PROFIT. ARE IN
MOMENTS ARE INCREASING WHILE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND- AND-
RAMIS ARE DECREASING AND SO WE
VERY MUCH OF THE DEAL ARE PART.
OF A TRYING TO FIND NEW AND
BETTER AND FLEXIBLE MODELS TO
SERVE THIS POPULATION. BEING OF
SERVICE TO THE BROADER WORK OF
MY COLLEAGUES IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM. AND INCLUDING.
I APOLOGIZE WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT
WHAT'S WHAT IS A DISH TO. THE
OF PROFIT ARE HAVING MUCH
SUCCESS AT THE EXPENSE OF THE
COMMUNICATIVE. WELL I WILL SAY
FROM MY EXPERTISE AND
EXPERIENCE ESPECIALLY IN THE
LAST RECESSION- THERE SOMETHING
THAT I WOULD CALL AN UNHOLY
MARKETINGCYCLE. AT MARKETING
TOURNAMENT FINAL WHAT THAT
MEANS IS- THAT EXPERIENCE AT
THE FRONT END OF AN INSTITUTION
ENGAGES WITH THE STUDENT AND
ACTUALLY- IN. THAT PROCESS ON
THE PART OF FOR PROFIT COLLEGES
AS COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT'S
NOT WHAT WE DO BUT THERE ARE
THINGS THAT WE CAN DO SO ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE IDENTIFIED
AS A COMMON KEEPS PINPOINT
CROSSES INSTITUTIONS IT'S
IMPORTANT TO COUNTER ACT
AGAINST THE FOR PROFIT SAYS-
RECOGNIZING THAT WE WERE
COLLECTING DATA ON OUR STUDENTS
AND WHAT WAS HAPPENING TO THEM.
IN THE APPLICATION PROCESS IT
WITH FALLING OUT OF THE SYSTEM
WHY DO YOU THINK THE
APPLICATION AND WAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTING
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS AS
WELL AS ADULTS STUDENTS AND- WE
RECOMMENDED A SERIES OF CHANGES
THERE. THAT NOT JUST BENEFIT
ENROLLEES AT CALIBRATE STUDENTS
COMING FROM THE SEPARATE
POPULATIONS BUT THIS IS GOING
TO BE A PAIN POINT THAT OTHER
SYSTEM COLLEGES- ARE GOING TO
BE ARE EXPERIENCING AS WELL AND
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY I HAVE
SHARED THIS INFORMATION WITH.
THAT WHEN IT MANY OF THE
COLLEAGUES MANY THE- KITCHENS
I'VE HAD WITH. THE COLLEGES SO
THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF WAYS IN
WHICH BOTH ARE WORK BUT ALSO AT
THE WORK THAT WE DO BENEFIT THE
SORT OF COLLECTIVE STRENGTH WE
NEED OF THE SYSTEM IN ORDER TO
COUNTERACT SOME OF THAT THE
TACTICS AND THE EFFECTS THAT WE
SEE. OF THAT BACK RISKIER
APPROACH FROM THE. PREDATORY
FOR PROFITS. OKAY GOTCHA GREAT
THANK YOU ONE THING I. AND ALSO-
MEMINTA TO YOU IN THE PAST AS
AN- I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH YOU
INTERFACE WITH THE REST OF THE-
SYSTEM AND ON YOUR CREE. MORE
FOR SCANDAL. BUT IT'S- THAT- IT
WOULD BENEFIT IF YOU HAD A-
STRONG RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
OTHER HUNDRED. PLUS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. CAMPUSES AS WELL AND-
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT'S HOW
THAT'S GOING TO THE YOU CAN
BOTH LEVERAGE. ON BOTH AIR
STRIKES. NO THANK YOU I.
APPRECIATE THAT THE QUESTION WE
ARE- YOU KNOW WE HAVE OPENED
THE DOORS ON THAT ONE FOR SURE-
BOTH WITH OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. PARTNERS I HADN'T HAVE
HAD MANY MORE CONVERSATION WITH
COLLEAGUES. AT WE HAVE NO
EXISTING PARTNERSHIPS WITH
PLACES LIKE BAKERSFIELD AND
CONTENT- BUT WE'VE ALSO SIGNED
AGREEMENTS WITH THE KERN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT AND
THE COAST COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISRICT. TO EXTRAORDINARY
DISTRICT LEADERS OF COLLEAGUES
OF MINE WHO. WHO WHO SEE THAT
SHARE CHALLENGE THAT WE'RE
FACING UNDERSTAND THAT WORKING
TOGETHER ON CERTAIN ASPECTS OF
THIS ACTUALLY WILL. NOT WILL
ENHANCE WHAT EACH OF US WOULD
INDIVIDUALLY BE ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH SO YOU KNOW WE ARE
DOING THAT WE WILL DO MORE OF
THAT GOING FORWARD AT THE OTHER
PLACE FOR ENGAGING REALLY
DIRECTLY IT'S NOT JUST WITH OUR
SYSTEM COUNTERPARTS. BUT ALSO
WITH THE WORKFORCE SYSTEM SO
OUR NEW PROGRAMS ARE ACTUALLY
BEING LAUNCHED- IN IN. IN
ENOUGH CONJUNCTION WITH WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING WITH MORE AT
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. BOARDS
IN FOUR DIFFERENT REGIONS I'M
MORE OF THAT WORK IS- IS ON THE
HORIZON IS INTENTIONAL PART OF
THE WAY THAT WE'LL DO OUR WORK
GOING FORWARD. BECAUSE WE KNOW
WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT A SILVER
BULLET SOLUTION WE'RE NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE THAT SILVER
BULLET SOLUTION WERE SUPPOSED
TO BE ENHANCING VALUE AND
BUILDING THIS CAPACITY-
COLLECTIVELY WITH THE SYSTEM.
RIGHT I DON'T VIEW MYSELFAS-
ANYTHING SEPARATE OR APART
FROM. THEM WHAT WE CAN
ACCOMPLISH IN THE CENTER I
DON'T KNOW YOUR GOAL IS TO BE
AT. FIVE THOUSAND EVENTUALLY
WHAT WHAT DO YOU THINK YOU'RE
GOING TO BE NEXT YEAR. YEAH
IT'S A GREAT. SO WE I'M AND
HAPPY TO SHARE A LITTLE BIT
DETAILS LAPORAN HOW THE-
MOMENTS PROJECTIONS ARE- ARE
SORT OF CALC. WHAT WE REALLY AT
IS HOWEVER NEW PROGRAMS ONLINE
WE'LL START THOSE PROGRAMS
SMALL AND QUICKLY MOVED TO
ACCELERATE TO SCALES OF THE
SMALL CONDITIONS ALLOW FOR
QUICK TESTING. THAT QUICK
TESTING THAT ALLOWS US TO SCALE
IN A WAY THAT IS MUCH MORE HIGH
QUALITY AND SO WHAT YOU'LL SEE
IS- YOU KNOW ENROLLMENTS.
INCREASED MORE SHARPLY TOWARDS
THE END OF THAT THREE YEAR
WINDOW. AND THE INITIAL FOCUS
OF THIS FIRST YEAR WILL BE ON A
SETTING AND NO THREE THREE TO
PROGRAMS. ATTENTION EVEN MORE
BY THE END OF THE YEAR- AND- IN
USING THOSE. PROGRAMS TO GROW
ARMAMENTS. OKAY GREAT FAVOR YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU AGAIN THIS IS AN
INFORMATIONAL ITEM AS YOU CAN
AS YOU CAN SEE THERE'S A LOT OF
QUESTIONS A LOT OF WORK TO DO
WE'RE GONNA REVISIT THIS THE
AUDIT COMMITTEE'S GONNA BE
FOCUSING ON THIS IS A POLICY
BILL- SO THAT THIS IS NO ACTION
ITEM- FOR NOW. WE COULD COME
BACK LATER IN THE IN THE YEAR
DEPENDING AND TAKE A LOOK AT
THE- BUDGET FOR THIS AS WELL-
SO WITH THAT WE WILL CONCLUDE
THE HEARING AND PROCEED NOW TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IT LOOKS LIKE
THERE'S NOBODY IN THE ROOM. IN
PERSON SO WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO DO
ON- NOT ONLINE TO DO. THAT
THROUGH THE TELEPHONE. TOLL
FREE NUMBER IS. 1-877-692-8957
I THINK IT'S YOU CAN SEE IT TOO
ON YOUR SCREEN. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. ACCESS CODE ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. WILL
ALLOW INDIVIDUALS TO TESTIFY
FOR. ONE MINUTE SIXTY SECONDS.
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY QUEUED UP
OPERATOR. YES MISTER CHAIR WE
DO HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE QUEUED
UP TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME SO
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN YOU WILL
BE CALLED BY YOUR LINE NUMBER-
WHEN YOU'RE CALLED UPON TO
SPEAK WILL NOW GO TO LINE
FORTY. EIGHT LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY WITH THE REAR WITH
YOUNG INVINCIBLES- I APPRECIATE
THE INCLUSION OF FUNDING
THROUGH BASIC NEEDS- BUT AS
EPIDEMIC HAS LONG LOOKING BACK
ON SO MANY STUDENTS I AM
REQUESTING THAT SOME OF THESE
FUNDS. BE ON GOING SECURITY
COLLEGES RATHER JUST ONE TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'LL GO TO
WELL NOW GO TO ONE THIRTY NINE.
FORTY CHAMBER CARTY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. OF THE HOUSE EDUCATION
TRUST WEST ON BASICALLY THE
BEST AND WE SUPPORT THE ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT WE ALSO NEED TO
ELEVATE NEED TO BETTER SUPPORT
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
BY MAKING ONGOING INVESTMENTS.
INSTEAD OF A ONE TIME
INVESTMENT WE DO SUPPORT THE
THIRTY MILLION ON GOING FOR
MENTAL HEALTH AND TECHNOLOGY
NEEDS BUTWE DO ASK THE
LEGISLATURE TO ESSENTIALLY BE
TANGLED RESPONDED OUTLINES HOW
THIS ALLOCATION SHOULD BE
DIVIDED BETWEEN THOSE TWO
SERVICES- BASIC GUIDANCE ON
USAGE AND POSSIBLE EVALUATION
METRICS. TO MAKE SURE THE SUIT
REACHING STUDENTS. AND LAST
WEEK WE'RE EXCITED THAT
LEGISLATORS ON SUBCOMMITTEE ARE
LEADING THE CHARGE ON
MODERNIZING OUR FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM- IF DONE RIGHT THIS
PROPOSAL WILL PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED SUPPORT TO STUDENTS OF
COLOR AND LOW INCOME STUDENTS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. MANY OF
WHOM HAVE BEEN HARD HIT BY.
PANDA THANK YOU. I GUARANTEE.
ONE THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING STEPHANIE
GOLDMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
FACULTY OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE
APPRECIATE PROPOSED PAID OUT OF
THE DEFERRALS AS WELL THE
FUNDING FOR STUDENT BASIC NEEDS
AND CLASSIC PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT BROUGHT THE
GRATEFUL FOR THE COLOR BUT WE
BELIEVE IT SHOULD MATCH THE
THREE POINT 84% COLAS AT THE K.
TWELVE SYSTEM IS PROPOSED TO
RECEIVE. FURTHERMORE THE COLOR
SHOULD NOT BE CONTINGENT ON THE
CREATION OR IMPLEMENTATION OF
POLICY PROGRAMS AT THAT
UNDERMINE THE PURPOSE OF THE
CALL- WHICH IS TO MAINTAIN
DISTRICT PURCHASING POWER. WE
CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THE STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULAS NOT
BENEFITING OUR COLLEGES AS A
RESULT THE HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISION NEEDS TO BE EXTENDED
ONCE AGAIN IN THIS BUDGET TO
PREVENT FINANCIAL HARMS MANY OF
OUR COLLEGES WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU THROUGHOUT THE
BUDGET CYCLE IN SUPPORT. OF OUR
COLLEGES AND OUR STUDENTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. PINE. THIRTY
SIX. HELLO MY NAME IS DEBBIE
RUSHER WITH JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR USE WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE SUGGESTION
DISCUSSED HERE TODAY TO PROVIDE
ONGOING FUNDING TO CREATE BASIC
NEEDS CENTERS TO HELP STUDENTS
FACING FOOD AND HOUSING
INSECURITY WHAT WE UNDERSTAND
THE APPEAL OF A BLOCK GRANT
STRUCTURE WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
SUCH DISCUSSION WOULD RESULT IN
INCONSISTENT LEVEL OF SERVICE
ACROSS CAMPUSES WHEN IT COMES
TO SERVING STUDENTS WITH THE
MOST SEVERE LEVEL OF SPEED. WE
BELIEVE THAT A SPECIFIC
ALLOCATION FOR FOOD AND HOUSING
SECURITY IS A BETTER APPROACH
IF A BLOCK GRANT APPROACH
ISSUES WE WOULD URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE OUTLINED A CLEAR
MINIMUM STANDARD THAT ENSURES
ADEQUATE STAFFING AT EVERY
COLLEGE TO EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS
BASIC NEEDS. INSECURITY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE. THIRTY
SEVEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
MONICA CAN I AM THE ETHIOPIAN
CARE NEXTSTEP COORDINATOR FOR
FROM MY COLLEGE AND ALSO THE
EUROPEAN NATION BY PRESIDENT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON
CREATING A BUDGET THAT
INCREASES INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA'S MOST MARGINALIZED
STUDENTS I APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE CONTINUED THE COURT
OF APPEAL PS AND THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL OF THE COLD WAR
PROGRAM. THAT BEING SAID THE
OPIATES NEEDS YOUR SUPPORT TO
BE TO BETTER SERVE OUR STUDENTS
WHO HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
KOBE WE'RE REQUESTING THIRTY
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
ETHIOPIA FINANCIAL AID GRANTS
TO ENSURE WE CANCONTINUE
PROVIDING DIRECTION EQUITABLE
ASSISTANCE TO CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE ASKING FOR
ELEVEN POINT SIX MILLION ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR THE DREAM
RESTORED COOLEY AVON PROGRAM
CREATED BY EIGHTY SIXTEEN FORTY
FIVE. WELL NOT EVERY POLITICIAN
PLAYS THE PROGRAM WHICH IN
ETHIOPIA DOES IT HAVE ARE
UNDERFUNDED AND NEED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT OF ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED.
STUDENTS AND HAVE A LOVELY
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU. LYING. I
CAN MORNING CARBON LAWS ON
BEHALF OF LOS RIOS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT WELL
THROUGHOUT THE PARTS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
THE ONE POINT FIVE COLOR
BECAUSE OF LIVING INVESTMENT IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO YEAR LAST YEAR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES DID NOT
RECEIVE A COLOR WHICH COULD
STRAIN ON THE DISTRICT'S BUDGET
TRYING TO ADDRESS THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE PANDEMIC.
PLUS ALSO SUPPORTS PAYING DOWN
THE GRANT COLLEGE DEFERRAL THE
DISTRICTS WOULD ALSO SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL EFFORTS TO PAY DOWN
THE REMAINING BALANCE JIM
PREVENTIVE CHECKS CASH THAT YOU
ASIAN TERMINATE. SHORT TERM
BORROWING COSTS. FOUR ZERO.
SUPPORT THANK YOU OF GENERAL
FUND TO REDUCE THAT HOW THANK.
EMPLOYER COUNTRY RATE. OTHER
PARTS INCLUDE THE COURT
EXPANDING CAL GRANT AND
STREAMLINE THE TRANSFER PROCESS
FOR STUDENTS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. FIVE FORTY NINE. GOOD
MORNING OF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MISTER CHAIR THIS IS
CHRISTY VELMA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS. I AM HERE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF OUR- BY
FEDERAL PROJECT TO MAKE THE- US
SEEKING SUPPORT FOR A FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME FOR
EMT ONE AND PARAMEDIC PRE
APPRENTICESHIP ACADEMIES- THE
TARGET UNDERREPRESENTED- A
MEMBERS IN OUR WORKFORCE AND
WE- PROUDLY CONDUCTED TO EMT
ONE ACADEMIES WITH THE SUPPORT
ONCE OF THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE. WE WOULD HAVE LOVED TO
PUT THAT ON YOU LIFE MONEY TO
WORK IT WAS MENTIONED IN THE
PRESENTATION- TO CONDUCT MORE
ACADEMIES WE'RE PROUD TO SAY
THAT WE HAVE TWENTY ONE. OF OUR
THIRTY FOUR GRADUATES OF OUR
ACADEMY THAT ARE ALREADY
EMPLOYED- USING THEIR SKILLS
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO CONDUCT
ADDITIONAL COURSES WITH THE
SUPPORT OF THE LEGISLATURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE
THIRTY FIVE. PARDON ME ONE
THIRTY FIVE THE ONES OPEN. YES
GOOD MORNING THIS IS DEBBIE
KLEIN PRESIDENT OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHILE WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR MUCH OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED IN JANUARY
BUDGET WE ARE VERY DISAPPOINTED
TO SEE CONTINUED FUNDING FOR
CALIBRATE. THE OUTDATED CONCEPT
OF HOW BRIGHT IS EMBLEMATIC OF
FAILED EDUCATION REFORM
MOVEMENT POLICIES THE FACULTY
OF HAD CONCERNS ABOUT HOW
BRIGHT SINCE ITS INCEPTION
THREE YEARS LATER WE REMAIN
DEEPLY OPPOSED AS THE COLLEGE
CONTINUES TO FAIL TO MEET ITS
PROMISES THAT WE HEARD JUST A
MOMENT AGO. AT A TIME WHEN
FUNDING IS LIMITED IN ALL ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN ACCREDITED
COLLEGES HAVE GONE ONLINE IT IS
UNWISE TO CONTINUE INVESTING IN
UNPROVEN INSTITUTION SERVING
ONLY FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS WE
ARE CURRENTLY SPENDING MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS PER STUDENT AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA SAID
THIS MORNING WE COULD JUST
WRITE THEM A CHECK AND CHANGE
THEIR LIVES. AS FACULTY
CONTINUE TO TEACH ONLINE DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND BEYOND PLEASE
RE DIRECT RESOURCES TO THE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN COLLEGES
SERVING OVER 99% OF OUR
STUDENTS. MORE FULL TIME
FACULTY POSITIONS PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND PART TIME
FACULTY SUPPORT ARE DESPERATELY
NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT ALL
STUDENTS HAVE EQUITABLE ACCESS
TO OPPORTUNITY TO ACHIEVE THEIR
GOALS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE FIFTY. HELLO JERRY MCCARTY
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS SHEILA
AND I AM A STUDENT AT NOT THAT
INTO YOUR COLLEGE REGARDING
YOUR BASIC NEEDS STUDENTS WHO
ARE PUTTING HOUSING INSECURE
NEED ACCESS TO A PERSON WHO CAN
HELP THEM TO TROUBLESHOOT
ACCESS RESOURCES AND SUPPORT
THEM TRIMMING ENROLLED ON AN
ONGOING BASIS MY CAMPUS MANY
CAMPUSES HOWEVER WILL NOT HIRE
NEW STAFF WITH ONE TIME FUNDING
I UNDERSTAND THE APPEAL THE
BLOCK GRANT STRUCTURE BUT
STUDENTS ARE CONCERNED THAT
SUCH DISCUSSION WILL RESULT IN.
THAT LEVEL OF SERVICE ACROSS
CAMPUS WHEN IT COMES TO SERVING
STUDENTS WITH THE MOST SEVERE
LEVEL NEED TO RETHINK- THE
MINIMUM STANDARD REGARDING HOW
FUNDS ARE USED TO ADDRESS FOOD
AND HOUSING INSECURITY FOR
EXAMPLE THE COMMITTEE COULD
INSURE THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WILL OUTLINE A CLEAR
MINIMUM STANDARD THAT ENSURES
ADEQUATE STOPPING AT EVERY
COLLEGE EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS
BASIC NEEDS SECURITY TWENTY
THREE THIRTY IS A GOOD
INVESTMENT I THINK LONGER THAN
LEVERAGE TO ASSESS STUDENTS. TO
GAIN ACCESS TO FEDERAL
FINANCIAL AID CALPERS BENEFITS
MEDIKAL FEDERALLY FUNDED
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES AND MORE
GRADING DIVIDENDS IN THE STATE
INVESTMENT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AGAIN. MY COMMENT THANK
YOU. LINE. THREE HELLO SCHMADEL
FIFTEEN EMPLOYERS AREN'T I AM
STUDENT AT COLLEGE THIS IS VERY
GLAD ONGOING MEDICAL ALLOCATION
TO ADDRESS INTO. BONTA CALLED.
ONE COLLEGE HUSBAND OF THE
DIFFICULT. FOR- TRYING TO GET
YEAH GOOD GOOD BASICALLY FOR MY-
UP IN A VERY GOOD FOR PROCESS
TRYING TO OLD COLLEGE ALSO THE
CASE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR- THANK
YOU. I FIFTY. EIGHTEEN GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DANNY THIS
GOD I'M THE DIRECTOR OF STUDENT
SUPPORT SERVICES AT SAN JOAQUIN
DELTA COLLEGE AND THE CCC YOUR
HERE THEY ASSOCIATION PRESIDENT
ARE ONE OF FIRST THANK YOU- FOR
YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT OF
ETHIOPIA- WE ARE THRILLED WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL OF A
COOLER FOR OUR PROGRAM. HOWEVER
OUR STUDENTS ARE YOU'LL HEAR
HERE AND NEXT STEPS YOU NEED TO
HAVE REALLY BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
COAL THAT AND BECAUSE OF THAT
WE'RE SEEKING AN ADDITIONAL
THIRTY MILLION IN ONE TIME
FUNDING OUR TO HELP PROVIDE
FINANCIAL AID GRANTS TO THOSE
STUDENTS ARE IN ADDITION WE'RE
SEEKING AN ELEVEN POINT SIX
BILLION ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
EXTREMELY RESOURCEFUL GAVE OUR
PROGRAM THAT WAS CREATED AS YOU
KNOW BY EIGHT AB SIXTEEN FORTY
FIVE. WE KNOW THAT NOT EVERY
YOU'LL P. PROGRAM- HAD THAT
POSITION BUT MANY DO AND THEY
ARE REALLY IN NEED OF
ADDITIONAL FUNDING- TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT STAFF-  THANK YOU OUR
WORK FOR LOOKING AT A
CONTINUING TO CREATE AN
EQUITABLE BUDGET THAT GIVES US
THE OUTCOMES THAT WE'RE LOOKING
FOR IN THE CHANCELLOR'S VISION.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. BY.
SIX GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS
I'M NOT ABOUT THE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA X. COALITION HERE TO
COMMENT ON THE CAL GRANT DETECT
PROPOSAL WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF REMOVING BARRIERS
ELIGIBILITY LIKE AGE
REQUIREMENT COME OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL GPA VERIFICATION EACH
CHANGE OF MOOD BUT THE WAY FROM
PENALIZING ADULT LEARNERS AND
LIKELY TO BE BENEFICIAL TO
STUDENTS PURSUING TECHNICAL
SKILLS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
REAPPOINTMENT HOWEVER WE DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
LACK OF NEW FUNDING WE
UNDERSTAND THE BUDGET REALITIES
OF THE ALSO BELIEVE AND KNOW
WHEN YOU FIND THAT THE CHOICE
ESPECIALLY DUE TO THE LESS THAN
DRAMATIC CHANGE. TO THE STATE
BUDGET THAT WE HAD EXPECTED WE
RECOMMEND BUILDING AND
PROTECTION FOR THE ALREADY
INADEQUATE AMOUNT GOING TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE
NOT REDUCE FURTHER AND TO SEE
SOME ASSURANCES THAT THE ACT OF
THE WAR INCREASES OVER TIME SH
GRATEFUL TO TRIM MCCARTY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA AND
DETECTS BACK FOR THE ONGOING
WORK ON THERE WE ALSO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THE CRITICAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT SPENDING
AS WE KNOW THESE TYPES OF
TRAINING PROGRAMS PLAY A KEY
ROLE IN CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC.
RECOVERY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. FINE. FORTY HI
KATIE HARTMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
PTA APPRECIATE MANY OF THE
PROPOSED INVESTMENT FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE ASKED THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE A
COMPOUNDED THREE POINT 8%
COOPER COMMIT COLLEGES GIVEN
THAT THE CALL WAS NOT PROVIDED
LAST YEAR- AND ADDITIONALLY PTA
URGES THE LEGISLATURE TO
INCREASE INVESTMENT AND PART
TIME FACULTY AND PATHETICALLY
WE ASKED FOR AN ADDITIONAL
FIFTEEN MILLION ON GOING
FUNDING FOR PART TIME FACULTY
CATEGORICAL PROGRAM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FINE NINE. GOOD
MORNING ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS TODD PARR RESIDENT OF CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY PLAYED BY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OVERSEEING
THEIR FOOD PANTRY I APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR'S INCLUSION OF THE
FUNDING FOR STUDENT BASIC NEEDS
I'VE SEEN FIRST HAND THE GREAT
NEED OUR STUDENTS HAVE AND THE
LIMITED RESOURCES THAT OUR
COMMUNITY HAS AVAILABLE TO MEET
ONGOING BASIC NEEDS PLEASE
DESIGNATE A PORTION OF THE
BASIC NEED FUNDS ONGOING VERSUS
ONE TIME TO CONTINUE THE
REDUCTION OF STUDENT EQUITY
GAPS THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FINE
FIFTY EIGHT. PINE FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON THE LINE FIFTY NINE.
MORE NINE FIFTY ONE I GUESS. RT
ADVOCATES QUICKLY CALLED LEADER
CALIFORNIA WE APPRECIATE IT
BECAUSE THERE'S NO THERE YOU
COULDN'T AROUND THE BATES NEEDS
OUT FOR COLLEGE DISTRICTS WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO ENCOURAGE THE
CONSIDERATION OF BRITISH
RESOURCES BEING AVAILABLE
TOWARD DISTRICTS THAT CAN KEEP
PACE WITH INCREASING COSTED OF
THE TASK FOR THE STUDENTS TO
COMMUNITIES. IT ALSO BACKED OUT
JACKSON MICHAEL DOUBLE THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FOR
OFFICIAL MEETS THE STRICT
REPORT. THAT WE CONTINUE TO
EVALUATE ANALYZE GAPS BETWEEN
STATE AND FEDERAL SUPPORT TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE NOT
DUPLICATING EFFORTS IN SOME
AREAS OF THE HOUSE BEHIND.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TALKING.
THANK YOU. FINE FIFTY TWO. YEAH
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KEVIN
ARE THEY NOT WHAT THE COLDEST
CALIFORNIA WILL PROVIDE CERTAIN
TRANSITION TEAM WILL HELP
STUDENTS WERE TRYING TO GET
FOOD STAMPS SO OFTEN THAT THEY
CAN'T QUALIFY FOR THE FOOD
SENSE BECAUSE THEY DON'T MEET
THE FEDERAL RESTRICTIONS THEN
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO GET THE
COPPER INDUSTRY IMPAIR. COVER
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
COMMITTEE- COMMITTEE COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND THEN THEY COULD
BECOME ELIGIBLE FOR
CONSTRUCTION THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE PROMISE GRANT TO
REPLICATE CAL GRANT EIGHTEEN
CAL GRANT THE FUNDING PLAN THAT
WOULD STRUCTURE THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH PLAN TO BE DESIGNED IN
SUCH A WAY THAT WOULD MAXIMIZE
TO EXPAND PUBLIC BY FEDERAL LAW
STUDENT DELEGATES ABILITY PORK
CHOPS LEARNS. TO CHANGE IT WILL
BRING IN ABOUT A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS INTO THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY SO HOW FIRST BETTER PUT
THEM OF THE PANDEMIC OF BOBA
WILL BRING ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
BILLION BECAUSE DURING THE
PANDEMIC EVERY STUDENT WILL GET
TWO HUNDRED FOURTEEN DOLLARS A
MONTH AND I THINK THIS WILL
HELP THE STUDENTS IMMENSELY
THAT WOULD BE COMPLEMENT OF
TWITTER OUTREACH EFFORTS. WITH
DOING THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING.
HELPING STUDENTS. THANK YOU.
FIND FIFTH STAFF MARK. SOMEONE
MICHELLE AGAIN UNDER WHAT ON
THE OF THE AT THE OF CALIFORNIA
COLLEGES. REGARDING ISSUE ONE
WITH THE CALM BECAUSE WHAT
CONDITION AND THE FOR PAY DOWN
OF THE AND WE ARE REQUEST PAY
DOWN OF PENN BUT SOME OF WAY IF
ADDITIONAL FUNDS ARE. REGARDING
THE ISSUE TO ME OF OUR STUDENTS
ARE WELL KNOWN AND ONE GIRL
EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
DESPITE THE ONE TIME FUNDING
STRUCTURE HALF BUDGET IF IT
NEEDS PROGRAM ONGOING
OPERATIONAL COSTS THEREFORE
AFTER THAT REQUEST ONGOING
SUPPORT FOR SUSTAINING COLLEGES
BASIC NEED SERVICES AND THEN
FINALLY AUDITIONED FOR LIKE THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WE BELIEVE
THERE IS GREAT NEED FOR
EDUCATION TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE. AFTER STRONGLY
SUPPORTS EFFORTS TO EXPAND
BROADBAND ACCESS CLOSE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE FOR STUDENTS IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS
ACCESS TO STATE. OF THE ART
TECHNOLOGY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE YOU. FOR BY. THIRTY EIGHT.
HE TERRY APALA THE MOVE FREIGHT
LINE THIRTY EIGHT LINE WHAT'S
NOT VERY CLEAR AT ALL THAT THEY
CAN CLEAR THAT UP THEY CAN
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN TO
JOIN THE QUEUE- AGAIN IT'S
PRESSING ONES HERE TO JOIN THE
QUEUE AT THIS POINT WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO LINE. FORTY FOUR. MADE
BY WE'RE GOING TO GO TO ONE
THIRTY THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JOHN I DO MINE AND I
AND THE BASIC NEEDS COORDINATOR
FOR SAN DIEGO MESA COLLEGE
EVERY DAY I MEET WITH STUDENTS
WHO HAVE THE DESIRE AND THE
PASSION FOR ACADEMIC SUCCESS.
THAT WILL BE TO A CAREER WITH
MOVABLE WAGES ONLY THEY
STRUGGLE WITH BASIC NEEDS
INSECURITY AND MANY ARE
WEIGHING THE PROS AND CONS OF
FOOD ON THEIR TABLE FOR ROOF
OVER THEIR HEAD BURKE IS A LONG
TERM BENEFIT BUT IF YOU COULD
YOU COULD POSSIBLY PROVIDE. I
REQUEST ONGOING AND DEDICATED
FUNDING ALLOCATION TO ADDRESS
STUDENT BASIC NEEDS. PROGRAM
ATTENDING A MADE FOR THE GREAT
AUSTRASIAN- BUT OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE CAPABLE OF DOING
TO INSTITUTIONALIZE BASIC NEEDS
SUPPORT FOR THESE PROGRAMS BIG
DEDICATED LIFELINE OF FINANCIAL
SUPPORT FOR PERMANENT STAFFING
AND DIRECT SUPPORT OF RESOURCES
FOR STUDENTS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. NINE
THIRTY TWO. HELLO SIR MCCARTY
MEMBERS INTERNET CONSISTED NOT
FOLSOM LAKE COLLEGE ON BEHALF
OF THE STUDENT CENTER FOR
CALIFORNIA JUNIOR COLLEGES
REPRESENTING THE TWO POINT ONE
MILLION STUDENTS PICTURE
MCCARTY FOR LEADERSHIP OR
INCARCERATED STUDENTS AND ON
CALPERS REFORM WE SUPPORT FULLY
FUNDED RECALL DOESN'T CALL A
PARTY ALONG ONE K. TWELVE WE
ALSO ENCOURAGED AND WITNESSED
AN OUTPOURING OF STATE OF BUT
SUPPORT FROM STUDENTS
ORGANIZATIONS IN STOCK BUT
CALLED HIS FIRST FOREIGN GOING
FUNDING FOR BASIC NEEDS. YOU
HEARD THEIR STORIES AND THE
STOP. THE NEED IS REAL AN
ONGOING. SURE MCCARTY NUMBER
MA'AM IN A THE USE FROM OF
BASING CENTERS AND URGES. THOSE
WHO ONGOING FUNDING. IF THE
COMMITTEE PREFERS A BLOCK GRANT
WE URGE YOU TO CONSIDER THE
PROVISIONS OF AB SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE AND DEVELOPMENT OF THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. THE BILL
ISN'T JUST AN IDEA COMES
DIRECTLY FROM STUDENTS AND
STAFF ON THE FRONT LINES OF
BASIC NEEDS INSECURITY. THE
STUDENTS KNEW WHAT THE BEST
OPTION TO COMMIT DISPOSAL TO
ADDRESS BASIC NEEDS. BY
SUPPORTING BASIC NEED CENTERS.
THANK YOU CHAIR MCCARTY. THANK
YOU. LINE. SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ADDICTIVE
SONG WATER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING NEARLY A QUARTER
MILLION CLASSIFIED PARTIES AND
BOTH K. TWELVE AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WE APPRECIATE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
PROVIDE EIGHTY ONE AND A HALF
PERCENT QUALITY THE STUDENT
CENTER FUNDING FORMULA HOWEVER
THE COALITION NOT BE
CONDITIONED ON ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS WE ALSO URGE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR- TO PROVIDE IT THANK
COMPOUND EIGHT EIGHT AT THREE
POINT 84% COLLEGES COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO BE CONSISTENT WITH
THE CALL THAT THAT IT'S-
PROPOSED FOR K. TWELVE. WE ALSO
URGE A COMMENSURATE AMOUNT OF
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
FUNDING FOR OUR CLASS EIGHT
PROFESSIONAL MUCH OF THE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
FUNDING IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IS GEARED TOWARD
TEACHERS MANY FACULTY ARE
CLASSED BY PROFESSIONALS ALSO
AND SUPPORT STUDENTS WITH
DIFFERENT LEARNING AND GET TO
BE- TO RECEIVE TRAINING ON THE
LATEST DEVELOPMENTS AND BEST
PRACTICES IN THAT FIELD. AS
WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. PINE.
TWENTY HI MY NAME IS THE THIRD
JUMP ON HEALTH- I WAS A FORMER
AUSTRIAN STUDENTS FROM ALMOST
THE COMPANY COMMITTEE COLLEGE
SYSTEM BECAUSE OF THE SPORT OF
MY INSTITUTION I WAS ABLE TO
FINISH MY ASSOCIATES DEGREE AND
BECOME A MEMBER OF THE
CLASSIFIED STAFF AND FULL TIME
UPS NEXT THANK YOU TO CALLERS
ACCORDING TO COOK BURKE FORMER
FOSTER. YOUTH STUDENT. I HERE
TO ADD. FOR FUN GOING FUNDING
FOR THE BASIC NEEDS OF. COMPANY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT- IN A
VERY UNIQUE POSITION REALLY THE
KIND THAT REALLY CHANGES THE
TRAJECTORY OF OUR STUDENTS
LIVE. WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FOR A BETTER
LIFE THEIR EDUCATION- AND WE
ARE BEST EQUIPPED TO PROVIDE
THEM WITH. A SYSTEM OF SUPPORT
I'M NOT ONLY GOING TO GET THEM
THROUGH THEIR- THEIR
IMPOVERISHED BACKGROUNDS AND ON
OBSTACLES SO I JUST WANT TO
AGAIN INCLUDE NOT ARM I
WOULDN'T BE HERE IF IT WASN'T
FOR THE GOOD WILL OF MY FACULTY
STAFF AND- BOARD MEMBERS WHO
SUPPORTED ME THROUGH MY
JOURNEY. BUT I WISH THAT ALL
THE STUDENTS ABOUT THE LEVEL OF
SUPPORT FOR THEIR BASICALLY.
IMPORT THANK YOU. LINE. FORTY
TWO. HELLO MY NAME IS LAWRENCE
BANGOR GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
I'M RETURNING COLLEGE STUDENT
AN ADVOCATE WITH YOUNG
INVINCIBLES OTHER
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENT I'M HERE
TO REQUEST AN ON GOING AND
DEDICATED FUNDING ALLOCATION TO
ADDRESS STUDENT BASIC NEEDS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. PINE.
FIFTY ONE. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE MY NAME IS AGING MAKE
THEM LAUGH I'M FROM SACRAMENTO
AND THE STATION ACT SACRAMENTO
ST STE I'M SUPPORTING THE
ONGOING AND DEDICATED FUNDING
TO ADDRESS STUDENT BASIC NEEDS
MANY STUDENTS INCLUDING MYSELF
HAVE STRUGGLED WITH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING COSTS. FOOD AND
EDUCATIONAL NEEDS. STARK STATE
HAVE BASICALLY CENTER AND I
WOULD WAS A FRESHMAN AT THE
TIME AND I WAS UTILIZING IT AND
IT'S REALLY HELPED ME A LOT.
AND I THINK THAT WE SHOULD BE.
HELP STUDENTS EXPERIENCING FOOD
AND HOUSING. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. I'LL GO TO MINE SIXTY FIVE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS- MIKE WE
ON THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO PAY DOWN
RECOUP 70% OF THE EXISTING
DEFERRALS BUT WE ARE STILL JUST
MAKE SURE TO TAKE ACTION TO PUT
DOWN THOSE DEFERRALS IMPORTANT
TAKE THESE ACTION WELL THE ONE
TEN DOLLARS ARE AVAILABLE SO
THE BUDGET TOOL TO PROGRAM
AVAILABLE I ABUSING OTHER
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN- AS EARLY FOR
THE COLDER WE REQUEST THAT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES RECEIVED THE
THING THREE POINT EIGHT FOUR.
5% ADJUSTMENT AND- AND IF
YOU'RE IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
APPLES BURKE IT'S WILL- AND
ADDITIONALLY MAKING LEGAL THE
CALL IS NOT CONTINGENT ON THE
CREATION OF THE SORT OF
ARBITRARY- REQUIREMETS WE
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO GO AWAY AND LASTLY-
AS BUT IT WAS A REALLY
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION THAT THE
THAT THE MEMBER CARE AND
RELATED TO CALIBRATE- IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT DESPITE
OVER A HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF INVESTMENT NEEDS OF
THIS- CALIBRATE SYSTEM- CAL BY
REMAINS AN ACCREDITED IT'S
BUILT TO MEET ENROLLMENT GOAL
THAT OTHER BENCHMARK THEM
OPERATING DUPLICATIVE. OFFERING
TO- WITH AVAILABILITY IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM IT'S
REALLY JUST A WASTE OF
RESOURCES THAT WE STRUGGLE TO
SEE THE NEED FOR THIS PROGRAM
HOURS LEGISLATURE TO- TO CALL
BACK THOSE PLANS ELIMINATED
SYSTEM INVEST THEM INTO THE
COMMUNITY. COLLEGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BY THE SEVEN.
MORNING MCCARTY AND BUDGET
COMMITTEE MEMBER MY NAME IS
CODY WITH DETECTED THE NOT
CONTINUE IN WALNUT CALIFORNIA.
ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUES IN
CALIFORNIA CAN BE COLLEGES I
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR ONE TIME
ALLOCATION OF BASIC NEEDS WILL
REQUIRE ONGOING FINANCIAL
SUPPORT TO MAINTAIN BASICALLY
BECAUSE OF OUR STUDENTS.
ACHIEVE THEIR EDUCATIONAL GOALS.
WELL IN MY ROLE AT THE O'CLOCK
I PAD UP. TO WORK WITH
EIGHTEEN. BAKUL PR STAFF TO THE
COURTS TO THE COULD BE THE- OUR
COLLEGES COMPLAIN A CLIP ROLE
OF COURSE CON. AND PROVIDE TOP.
FOR OUR HARDWORKING. THIRTY
THOSE FROM MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES. YOUR SUPPORT OF
ONGOING FUNDING IN BACK IN THE
NAME OF THE PERSON THE BUCKLEY
STUDENTS I THANK YOU GROW ON
COMMIT. TO THANK YOU. NINE
SIXTY EIGHT. HELLO MY NAME IS
MICHAEL TRAVIS AMONG I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF LONG BEACH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT AND
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE NEED FOR ONGOING
FLEXIBLE BASED RESOURCES SO
THAT DISTRICTS CAN MEET STUDENT
NEEDS AND THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES
THAT YOU SERVE. COMING COLLEGES
REQUIRE ONGOING. BUT WILL BASE
OPERATING DOLLARS TO MAINTAIN
THE CAPACITY TO SERVE STUDENTS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FINE. SIXTY FOUR.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MCCARTY
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS PATRICE
NOT PREVENTION I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING AT
SOUTHWESTERN COLLEGE IN JACKSON
THE EAGLE COUNTY AS THE
DIRECTOR OF OUR RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE PROGRAM WE ARE MEETING
STUDENTS WHERE THEY ARE
INCLUDING THOSE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY AND FORMERLY
INCARCERATED THE CRITICAL WORK
OF PROVIDING ALL JUSTICE
IMPACTED STUDENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FOLLOW A PATHWAY
TO CAREER TO HIGHER EDUCATION
SPECIFICALLY THE DEGREE AND
CERTIFICATE PATHWAYS AND CAREER
EDUCATION PROVIDED AT OUR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
IS BOTH UNIQUE ANY CENTRAL
FURNACE MARGINALIZED POPULATION
TO SUCCEED I URGE YOUR SUPPORT
AT EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTEEN AND
CREATING AN ONGOING FUNDING
MECHANISM WITHIN THE STATE
BUDGET PROCESS FOR THE RISING.
SCHOLARS NETWORK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE. FOURTEEN HELLO
MY NAME IS REBECCA SILBERT I'M
THE SENIOR DIRECTOR OF THE
RISING SCHOLARS NETWORK AT THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES I
SUPPORT THE COLLEGES SERVING
THOUSANDS OF INCARCERATED AND
FORMERLY INCARCERATED STUDENTS
I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MCCARTY IN THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE FOR THEIR SUPPORT MAYBE
FOR SEVENTEEN WE KNOW THAT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE THE MAIN
POINT OF ACCESS FOR THESE
DOCTORS INVOLVED STUDENTS WE
KNOW IT CHANGES THEIR LIVES AND
OF THEIR FAMILIES. THE COLLEGES
ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN
WITH ALMOST NO FUNDING RELYING
ON VOLUNTEERS XTRATIME OVERTIME
ON GOING SUPPORT WILL MAKE AN
ENORMOUS DIFFERENCE NOT JUST TO
THE STUDENTS. BUT THE FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. BY
THIRTY EIGHT YES I READ TAKE
THE FINAL THREE AND THEY'RE
GONNA HAVE TO SHUT DOWN PUBLIC
COMMENT THANK YOU. MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DAVID NEVIN ON
BEHALF OF THE SANTA MONICA
COLLEGE. IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT THE THREE PRIORITIES
THAT ARE AT THE TOP OF OUR LIST
ON A LETTER THAT WAS SUBMITTED
HERE CAN SUBCOMMITTEE. WE
SUPPORT AN ADDITIONAL CALL
REFLECTING COST INCREASES FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE. YEAR AS
WELL AS ADDITIONAL PAY DOWN OF
DEFERRALS WITH A ONE TIME FUNDS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE. AND WE
SUPPORT GIVING DISTRICTS THE
FLEXIBILITY TO ADOPT COURSE
REPEATABILITY POLICIES FOR UP
25% OF ANNUAL COURSE OFFERINGS.
AGAIN THESE ARE DETAILED IN THE
LETTER THAT WE HAVE SUBMITTED
THE SUBCOMMITTEE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MODERATOR BUT WE
HAVE TO MARKET DOLLARS. A VITAL
TO YOUR CHART THANK YOU YES.
ONE SIXTY SIX OF ONE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR TIME TODAY MY NAME
IS SHANE REYNOLDS IN THE LAKE
TAKAMINE COLLEGE DISTRICT I
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE AN
ONGOING SUPPORT FOR INMATE
EDUCATION SURPRISED WE SUPPORT
THAT BUDGET THE BILL AND THE
RISING SCHOLARS NETWORK WITH
ONGOING FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY
FIVE. HI MY NAME IS MANIC HELLO
HI MY SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
WEST VALLEY MISSION COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE- LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS MANY OTHER-
SPEAKERS BEFORE ME HAVE ALREADY
STATED- VERY- IN FAVOR OF THE
ON GOING FLEXIBLE BASED SUPPORT
RESOURCES- AND WE ARE- BUT SAY-
AND NOT THE OTHER ASPECT IS
THAT- COMMITTEE COLLEGES
REQUIRED ONGOING FLEXIBLE BASE
OPERATING DOLLARS- TO MAINTAIN
THEIR CAPACITY AND TO SERVE
STUDENTS AS WELL AS THE
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH WE OPERATE
IT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THAT CONCLUDES
OUR HEARING FREESHEET THE
PARTICIPATION L. C. AUSTIN
THANK YOU. IF YOU MISTER CHAIR
HAVE A GOOD DAY